GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE TO THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY WE ARE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING EVEN THOUGH WE ARE IN
ONE OF THE LARGEST VENUES IN
THE CAPITAL WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE. IF YOU MEMBERS
MINIMAL CONTINGENTS THAT OFF
AND LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP SIX
FEET OF DISTANCING AND SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK- FROM THE ROOM THERE IS
ASSISTANCE AND AN OPPORTUNITY
TO APPROACH. THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. HE
WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT THE PLEASE OF
SERVICE. PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING. LIMITED ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
THE PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA AND
THE L. O. R. APPEARING REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. THIS
IS THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
THERE WILL BE NO VOTE AND THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU ARE WATCHING THIS OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL BE ABLE TO ASSIST
YOU. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
EVERYONE TO OUR JOINT HEARING
ON HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING A
SUBJECT WE WILL BE FOCUSED.
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS.
BEFORE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
BEGINS EVALUATING THE GOVERNOR
SINCE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL.
WE WANTED TO FOCUS ON THE STATE
ROLE BUT THE STATE ROLE IS
SOMEHOW. HOMELESSNESS AND
REVISIT PAST INVESTMENTS TO
HELP GUIDE US FORWARD. IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WITHIN L.
A. COUNTY. LA'S ANNUAL HOMELESS
COUNT RELEASED THEIR LAST
REPORT IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY. AND STATED THAT ABOUT.
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE PEOPLE RE NOW
LIVING ON THE STREETS AND
SHELTERS AND IN THEIR CARS
ACROSS THE COUNTY. THIS IS AN
INCREASE OF TWELVE POINT 7%
SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN. WITHIN
THE CITY LIMITS OF LOS ANGELES
ALONE THERE HAVE BEEN THERE HAS
BEEN A FOUR POINT TO INCREASE
OVER THE LAST YEAR RESULTING
IN. FORTY ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE%
SLICE OF HOMELESSNESS IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ALONE IS
UNPARALLELED. AMID A COVERT
NINETEEN THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS TOP
WAS 20% AT ITS PEAK. FOR
REFERENCE L. A. COUNTY
POPULATION IS TEN POINT FOUR
MILLION THAT MEANS CLOSE TO TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE. WERE
UNEMPLOYED AND WORRIED ABOUT
HOUSING AND THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AT ITS PEAK
IN MAY IN APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY. THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
WAS 16% THAT'S ROUGHLY SIX
POINT FOR CALIFORNIANS. WITHOUT
A JOB WITHOUT MEANS WORRIED AND
WONDERING AND FRIGHTENED FOR
THEIR FUTURE ON THE BRINK OF
HOMELESSNESS. ADDING TO ALREADY
EXISTING. EXHAUSTED RESOURCES.
I BRING THESE NUMBERS U TO
SHARE THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
REAL HUMAN LIVES IMPACTED BY
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
STRUGGLING AMID THE PANDEMIC
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
UNEMPLOYMENT LOOMING EVICTIONS
GENTRIFYING NEIGHBORHOODS
INCREASING RENTS. AND GENERALLY
A LACK OF AFFORDABLE AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING. HUMAN BEINGS
ARE IMPACTED BY CHRONIC
EPISODIC TRANSITIONAL AND
HIDDEN HOMELESSNESS AND ALL OF
US HERE HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH
BEING GOOD STEWARDS OF OUR
STATE BUDGET. THE PUBLIC TRUST
AND ENSURING BASIC RIGHTS IT IS
MY BELIEF. THAT EVERY HUMAN
BEING HAS A RIGHT TO HOUSING.
AND A RIGHT TO LIVE- COMMITTEE.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE
THREE PANELS ON THE SUBJECTS OF
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S ROLE ON
HOMELESSNESS LOCAL
PERSPECTIVES. AND LASTLY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM EXPERTS.
WE PLAN TO HAVE A QUESTION I
CAN ANSWER SECTION AFTER EACH
PANEL. I LIKE AT THIS MOMENT TO
TURN IT OVER TO THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR OPENING
REMARKS FOLLOWED BY REMARKS
FROM OTHER MEMBERS. MEMBERS
PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS CONCISE. AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LET ME FIRST START BY
THANKING- OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
HEARING. AS WELL AS THE NEW
CHAIR BUDGET SUB FOR AND REALLY
APPRECIATE HER ONGOING PERSONAL
COMMITMENT TO. FIGURE OUT HOW
WE AND HOMELESSNESS CARRYING ON
THE COMMITMENT OF HER
PREDECESSOR MISTER COOPER. AND
WANTED JUST THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES FOR
BEING PART OF THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION. HOMELESSNESS AS
I'VE OFTEN SAID IS THE MORAL
ISSUE OF OUR TIME IT HAS BEEN.
THE VERY TOP ISSUE ON THE MINDS
OF MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
GIVEN THE RECORD NUMBERS OF
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE SEE ON OUR
STREETS. I THINK WE ALL HOPE
THAT LAST YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
WAS GONNA BE THE YEAR THAT WE
TACKLE THIS TOPIC. FOR GOVERNOR
DEVOTED HIS STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS TO THIS- BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE KNOW WITH THE PANDEMIC WITH
THE RECESSION WAS SOCIAL AND
REST. THERE WERE MANY OTHER
CRISES THAT WE HAVE TO TACKLE
THIS PAST YEAR. DESPITE THIS
CRISIS THE ADMINISTRATION WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WORKED
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DIDN'T SEE EVEN HIGHER
SKYROCKETING RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. I WANT TO JUST
APPRECIATE THE WORK AROUND
PROJECT HUNKY ROOM KEY. THE
CRITICAL FUNDING THAT WE PUT
INTO LAW THIS BUDGET TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD. AS WELL AS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS HOUSE THERE
WERE HALF A DOZEN BILLS. THAT
WERE PASSED BY THE ASSEMBLY-
THAT UNFORTUNATELY EITHER WERE
STALLED OR GOT VETOED. AND I
THINK MANY OF US ARE EAGER FOR
A COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATION.
AND HOW WE TACKLE THIS TOPIC
HOW WE FOCUS ATTENTION ON
HOMELESSNESS. SHE WAS A MEMBER.
THUS FAR IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE OBVIOUSLY WILL HAVE.
A LOT MORE DISCUSSION ON IT-
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO WHAT I
PLAN TO BE FOCUSED ON IN THIS
HEARING AND MOVING FORWARD. IS
HOW WE TALK ABOUT. NOT JUST
ADDRESSING AND MANAGING
HOMELESSNESS A YEAR BY YEAR
BASIS. BUT HOW DO WE AND
HOMELESSNESS. ENDING
HOMELESSNESS. IS GOING TO
REQUIRE. A REAL STATEWIDE
COMMITMENT. TO A STRATEGIC
PLAN. IT WILL REQUIRE. ONGOING
RESOURCES NOT JUST ONE TIME
RESOURCES. AND REQUIRE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE PARTS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. STATE
GOVERNMENTS THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR AND EVERYONE IN BETWEEN-
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES AND I'M
HOPING WE WILL TACKLE. THIS
YEAR AND STARTING WITH TODAY'S
HEARING AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT BACK TO MEASURE. THANK YOU
ARE THERE OTHER MEMBERS THAT
WISH TO HAVE ANY REMARKS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
AM HAPPY TO BE HERE AS A MEMBER
OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE AND AS
THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON. HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE COUNTY.
I HAVE READ AND DIGESTED MANY
OF THE PROPOSALS BY THE STATE
AND HAVE HEARD MANY PROPOSALS
ONE OF THE THINGS I'M HOPING TO
HEAR IN THIS HEARING. IS HOW
DID WE DO WITH THE GOVERNORS OF
THE STATE OF THE STATE LAST
YEAR WHERE HE- MADE. MAJOR
POINTS ON US ACQUIRING STATE
LAND AND HOW WE MIGHT USE IT
AND LISA. AND BE ABLE TO USE
THAT FOR SOME HOUSING I KNOW
WITH THE PANDEMIC MANY THINGS
WERE PUT. UP ON HOLDER PUSHED
BACK SECOND THING THAT I'M
GOING TO BE WANTING TO HEAR
ABOUT IS I TO SUPPORT THE
PROJECT HOME KEY UP AND PROJECT
TURN KEY I GET THOSE MIXED UP-
BUT I WANT TO BE UNDERSTANDING
MORE ABOUT THE EQUITY. IN THESE
PROGRAMS AS FAR AS DOLLARS AN
ALLOCATION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BECAUSE AS I REPRESENT
ORANGE COUNTY- WE TO HAVE A
GROWING HOMELESS POPULATION
LIKE EVERY OTHER. COUNTY IN THE
STATE AND HOW ARE THESE DOLLARS
ALLOCATED AND HOW- CAN WE MAKE
SURE THAT TO WHEN WE APPLY WE
HAVE THE BEST POSSIBLE CHANCE
OF ATTAINING FUNDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
MEDICARE PPRECIATED AND- THANK
YOU ALSO TO OUR OUR HOUSING
CHAIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES- I AGREE THAT THIS
IS A I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
PERSISTENT AND CHALLENGING
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES FACING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I AGREE
THAT IT IS A GREAT MORAL
CHALLENGE. WHAT I'M HOPING TO
HEAR TODAY IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
AND HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
STOPPING PEOPLE FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS ARE CHARLIE
TO THE- IDEA THAT THE COUNT BY-
BY- THE MOST RECENT TWO
THOUSAND NINE HONDA ACCOUNT.
AND WHAT I FOUND MOST
INTERESTING ABOUT IS THAT ON
AVERAGE EVERY DAY IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN PEOPLE ARE MOVED INTO
HOUSING AND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN BECOME NEWLY HOMELESS. SO
EVERY DAY ARE HOMELESS PROBLEM
IS GROWING IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES FIND ADDITIONAL TWENTY
PEOPLE HUMAN BEINGS FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS PEOPLE THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF ITSELF. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WE'RE FOCUSED ON
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THOSE ON
THE STREETS BUT I ALSO THINK IT
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT WE THINK
ABOUT HOW ARE WE PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM BECOMING HOMELESS
IN THE FIRST PLACE. BECAUSE IF
WE DON'T ADDRESS THAT PART OF
THE EQUATION THAT WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO DIG OURSELVES OUT OF
THIS HOLE. THE OTHERS ARE VERY
EAGER TO HEAR ABOUT AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT IS THE ISSUE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING DATA DRIVEN
POLICYMAKING. I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED ON. HOW DO WE BRING
SOME REAL ACCOUNTABILITY SO WE
HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF WHAT
DOLLARS WE'RE SPENDING ARE
ACTUALLY MAKING A DIFFERENCE ON
THIS PROBLEM. I WHAT I WORRY
ABOUT IS THAT I'M NOT CONFIDENT
THAT THERE ARE FOLKS WHO COULD
SWITCH OF OUR INVESTMENTS ARE
ARE BETTER THAN OTHERS AND
WHICH ONES ARE REALLY GETTING
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND SO I
THINK BRINGING SOME REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
TO WHICH OF THESE. INVESTMENTS
HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE WHICH OF
THE INVESTMENTS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE- IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I KNOW OUR
CHAIR MENTIONED THAT BOTH
THOSE- STEWARDS OF THE TAXPAYER
RESOURCES. ARAFAT ALSO AS
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AS COMPASSIONATELY AS
POSSIBLE TO HELP FOLKS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE STRUGGLING TO
BRING THEM OFF THE STREETS I
THINK WE NEED. MUCH BETTER DATA
ABOUT WHAT PROGRAMS ARE WORKING
WHAT INVESTMENTS ARE WORKING
AND WHERE WE CAN RETARGET
RESOURCES SO THOSE ARE TWO
ISSUES THAT I HOPE. THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON TODAY AS WE
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU. MR GABRIEL ANYONE
ELSE OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE COMMENTS. BEFORE WE
BEGIN. SEEING NONE AGAIN THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE AND
I WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO THE PREVIOUS
CHAIRMAN SIR COOPER WAS GUIDED
ME THROUGH THIS PROCESS I SAY
AS I LEAD MY FIRST HEARING AS
WELL AS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
HAD TO STEP OUT FOR A MINUTE-
AND WILL BE RETURNING SO LET'S
GET STARTED ON ON THE PANEL UP
ON THE OVERVIEW OF THE STATE'S
ROLE ON HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE
LOTUS MORALIS WAS A PRINCIPAL
IN FISCAL. POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND SECRETARY LOU THIS
GOT TO CONSTRUCT A METIS- FOR
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY- MISS MORALIS
WHY DON'T WE START WITH YOU.
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING THIS MARVELOUS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AT THE
PLEASURE TO BE WITH- THE CHAIRS
IN THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS MORNING. I WILL BEGIN MY
COMMENTS FROM MY HAND OUT TO
GIVE ME A MOMENT I'LL JUST BE
SHARING MY SCREEN SO. YOU CAN
FOLLOW ALONG. I BELIEVE YOU ARE
SEEN MY SCREEN NOW. YES WE CAN
SEE IT THANK YOU. BY STAFF TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT FOR THE
DISCUSSION WILL BE TAKING PLACE
TODAY SO I WANT TO BEGIN BY
PROVIDING SOME BACKGROUND ON
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES THAT ALL TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS FACE TODAY I'M IN
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS SPEND
MORE ON HOUSING AND HOUSEHOLD
IN THE REST OF THE NATION AND
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE LOWEST
INCOME- FOR THESE HOUSEHOLDS.
PARTICULARLY THE OVER ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO SPEND MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME ON RENT
FACE DIRE CONSEQUENCES AND ARE
AT HIGHEST RISK OF HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS.
IN ADDITION WE KNOW THAT THE
NEED FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING
ASSISTANCE OUTSTRIPS THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES PROVIDED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES AT
THIS TIME. OUR OFFICE HAS
ESTIMATED THAT THE STATE WOULD
BE TO PROVIDE TEN BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO ENSURE THAT
LOW INCOME RENTERS PAY NO MORE
THAN 50% OF THEIR INCOME. ON
RENT A MONTH BETWEEN NO CERTAIN
THE THRESHOLD TO DISTINGUISH IT
SHOULD BE A RENT BURDEN. AND SO
WITH THAT IN MY ABILITY TO TURN
TO TAKE A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE
STATE'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
BEFORE I DO I WANT TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE CONTEXT INTO THE DATA
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE HERE.
THE STATE HAS HISTORICALLY
RELIED ON THE POINT IN TIME
COUNTS WHICH ON. MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
NOTED IN THEIR OPENING COMMENTS
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES WITH THE WAY THAT
DATA IS COLLECTED AND LIKELY
REPRESENTED. UNDER COUNT OF THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE. AND
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
WITH THE DATA COLLECTION THE
TWENTY TWENTY DATA IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WE KNOW THAT
THEIR CHALLENGES WITH THE
UNSHELTERED COUNT THAT- YOU
KNOW IT WOULD GENERALLY TAKE
PLACE IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR-
BUT A LOT OF UPON A POINT OF AN
OPTIMISM IS THE NEW DATA SYSTEM
THAT THE STATE IS SETTING UP
THE HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM. WHICH IS EXPECTED TO BE
OPERATIONAL IN THE SPRING AND
WOULD BRING TOGETHER SOME
STANDARDIZED DATA. FROM THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE THAT THAT-
PROVIDE SERVICES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. I'M AND WELL THEY'RE NOT
A REPLACEMENT OF THE POINT IN
TIME COUNT THE TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION AND COULD BE A
VALUABLE. TO- MOVING FORWARD.
AND SO WHAT BETTER MIND THE NAY.
COULD OF PAGES HIGHLIGHT.
TWENTY NINETEEN DATA. AT THE
TIME- THE DATA FOUND THAT THERE
IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND. PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THIS
IS THE LARGEST AMOUNT. IN ANY
STATE IN THE NATION. 72% OF
THAT POPULATION. WHAT'S AND
SHELTERED. AND AT THIS NEXT
FIGURE DEPICTS THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF HOMELESSNESS
IN THE STATE IS IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA. STILL
HISTORICALLY THE STATE'S ROLE
WE HAVE PLAYED A NUMBER OF
ROLES IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS FROM PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT THE BUILDING OF NEW
AFFORDABLY PRICED HOW ON
HOUSING. ENSURING THAT
HOUSEHOLDS CAN IN FACT AFFORD
HOUSING AND ALSO ARE PUTTING A
NUMBER OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT MAY
ASSIST IN THE PREVENTION OR IN
THE OVERCOMING OF HOMELESSNESS.
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
OPERATED OUT OF A NUMBER OF
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS.
SOME OF THE MOST NOTABLE ARE
EACH CD AT THE STATE AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY TAX IDENTIFICATION
COMMITTEE AND THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING FINANCE COUNCIL AS
WELL AS THE VERY MANY ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES.
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
FUNDING SOURCES- THAT THAT COME
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING. OVERALL THE FUNDING
HAS FLOWN TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE HAD A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THEY USE THE
VARIOUS FUNDING SOURCES TO
DELIVER HOMELESSNESS SERVICES
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE. FOR THEM.
HOWEVER IN RECENT YEARS AS THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IS BECOME
MORE ACUTE THE STATE HAS TAKEN
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN FUNDING
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE TABLE THAT'S
ON YOUR SCREEN NOW JUST
PROVIDES HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS SHE HAS MADE IN
RECENT YEARS. THE FOR CHO SAID-
THERE WAS THE KEEPING HALF
PROGRAMS WHICH TOGETHER
PROVIDED OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
OPERATED OUT OF. THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL UNTIL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND THEN THERE'S A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS WAS MENTIONED IN THE
OPENING COMMENT THAT HAVE. YOU
INTENDED TO RESPOND TO COPE AT
NINETEEN. SO THE NEXT PAGES OF
MY HAND OUT PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS OUTLINED IN THE TABLE.
I WANTED TO MUCH DETAIL ON THE
SPECIFICS HERE- OVERALL SERVICE
WAS THE FIRST MAJOR NEW
INVESTMENT IN IN THIS ERA ERA
FOR HOMELESSNESS WHICH PROVIDED
FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADDRESS THEIR
HOMELESSNESS NEED- THIS IS THE
PROGRAM THAT HAS FULLY
DISBURSED THE FUNDING TO
QUALIFYING CITIES AND COCS. AND
THE FUNDS MUST BE EXPENDED BY
THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR SO
THIS WILL BE SORT OF THE FIRST
PROGRAM WHERE WE DO START TO
GET REAL DATA ABOUT NOT ONLY
HOW THE FUNDS HAD BEEN USED BUT
WHAT ARE THE KEY OUTCOMES. FOR
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT I WALK
THROUGH AND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THE FUNDS BE FULLY
EXPENDED YET AND SO DATA THERE
IS MORE ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE
ARE SPEND RATHER THAN TO. CHIU
OUTCOME. EATERS SO AGAIN ON
THIS PAGE SORT OF THE LEFT THE
PROGRAMS NOTE IT HAS PROVIDE
SIX AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO. THE LARGEST CITIES COUNTIES
AND CSCS. HERE ONE OF THE FOCUS
OF THE PROGRAMMES WAS TO
DEVELOP MORE REGIONAL
COORDINATION. I'M SO THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN THEIR
BROADER REGION RATHER THAN YOU
A- MANNER. AS I MENTIONED THE
STATE DID HAVE TO HAVE IT WITH
THE EMERGENCE OF CODE IN
NINETEEN. TO ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND HEALTH
RISKS FACED BY INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE
INITIAL RESPONSE FROM THE STATE
WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
PROJECT ROOM KEY WITH A LOCK
FOR THE LEAST SEEN OF HOTELS
AND MOTELS ANOTHER OTHER
PROPERTIES. TO ENSURE THAT
HOMES OPERATIONS HAD A SAFE
PLACE TO SHELTER DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THIS FUNDING- HAS BEEN
EXPANDED. OVERALL AT THIS POINT
THERE ARE OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND ROOMS THAT HAVE BEEN
SECURED AND CURRENTLY.
OCCUPANCY IS ABOUT 70% OVERALL
ABOUT TWO THREE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SERVED ACROSS FORTY TWO
COUNTIES IN THE STATE FROM THE
ROOM KEY PROGRAM. THERE'S ALSO
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
PROVIDED EMERGENCY HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING- THIS WAS TO PROVIDE
SORT OF MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO HELP
ADDRESS. THE NEEDS OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION ONCE AGAIN
DURING DURING CO THAT AND THIS
FUNDING HAS ALSO BEEN
DISTRIBUTED. AND SHOULD BE
EXPECTED BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. THANK YOU SORT-OF WANT ONE OF THE MAJOR NEW
FEATURES OF. THIS NEW ERA WE'RE
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO THE
PURCHASE SEEN- AND RESTORATION
OF. HOMES TO ENSURE UNITS
EXCUSE ME TO ENSURE THAT AND
THERE'S MORE PERMANENT HOUSING.
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
HOMELESS. THIS FUNDING HAS BEEN
DISTRIBUTED AS WELL THERE'S
BEEN NINETY FOUR AWARDS NEED TO
LOCAL ENTITIES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES ACOSTA
RESULT IN ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES. AND LASTLY THERE
IS A CONTINUATION OF THE HOT
PROGRAM WHICH WHICH I MENTIONED
WAS A ONE TIME PROGRAM- FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- TO CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A REGIONAL
COLLABORATION THIS FUNDING HAS
NOT YET BEEN AWARDED
APPLICATION FOR DO YOU AT THE
END OF. THE MONTH AND LIKE THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM THIS FUNDING
WOULD GO TO THE LARGEST CITIES
COUNTIES AND COULD. CARE.
THAT'S A- QUICK OVERVIEW OF
SOME OF THE MAJOR FUNDING. OF
THE LAST FEW YEARS- AFTER THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE-
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
HAS DEDICATED- ON EXTREME
CONCERN AND INTEREST IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE- BUT TO
DATE THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
PROVIDED HAS BEEN ON A ONE TIME
TEACHER. AND SO CAN WHILE THE
STATE HAD TO ACT QUICKLY TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
COOK AT NINETEEN. THE SCALE OF
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN THE
STATE IS SIGNIFICANT AND
WITHOUT SUBSTANTIAL
COORDINATION EVEN LARGE
RESOURCES CAN BE DISTRIBUTED
WITHOUT MUCH PROGRESS AND SO
WHAT'S ON. THE FINAL TWO PAGES
OF MY HAND OUT OUTLINED ARE
SOME QUESTIONS TO CONSIDER THE
LARGEST YOU THINK ABOUT HOW
WHICH CHOOSES TO MOVE FORWARD.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS IN FACT
A STREET TO STRATEGIC PLAN TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THE FACETS OF
HOMELESSNESS AND TO ENSURE THAT
IT. IS ADDRESSED. PERMANENTLY
TENSION THAT THERE'S A CLEAR
GOALS TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
NO GOLD ABOUT THE PREVENTION
ENTERED AND THE RESPONSE AS
WELL. AND THAT THE SOLUTIONS
ADDRESSED ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT CAUSES OF
HOMELESSNESS BUT THERE ARE
CLEAR RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE
STATE- TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND THE FUNDING
STRUCTURE ALIGNED WITH THE
NEEDS PROGRAMS AND THEIR IMPACT
ON ON GOING NEEDS THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE AN ONGOING REVENUE
SOURCE IDENTIFIED- AND THAT
THERE IS A RIGOROUS OVERSIGHT
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED EFFECTIVELY AND- RE
ADJUSTS TO A FEATURES OF THE
PROGRAM IF. THERE ARE-
SHORTCOMINGS IDENTIFIED. THAT
HIGHLIGHTS- LIMINE. OF THE
PROGRAM ALL STOPS MY. AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE A OF YOUR AT THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
MORALIS WILL TAKING QUESTIONS
FOLLOWING THAT SECOND PANELIST
UP ON THIS PANEL. THAT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU. GREAT OKAY WE
ARE NOW GOING TO INTRODUCED US
SECRETARY CASTRO TREMENDOUS IS
MORNING- THIS IS SECRETARY
CUSTER TO MEET IS. GOOD MORNING
SECRETARY WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU
MAY BEGIN YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
I'M OVER THIS CUSTOMER JOURNEY
IT IS TONIGHT THAT'S THE
SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH- SHARE CUDDLY
YELL AND SHARE TO I IN MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT THE
STATE'S INCREASED LEADERSHIP
AND OUR EFFORTS. TO DEVELOP A
COHESIVE OUR SYSTEM AND A SET
OF SOLUTIONS TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS. AND LET ME ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR FOCUS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP I AM FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT OF
RESOURCES THAT HAPPENED A
DEDICATED- TO COMPREHENSIVELY.
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS ACROSS OUR
STATE. D. THAT I'M A- FOR. AND
THE C. S. H. OR THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING HOUSING ACROSS THE
CONTINUUM FROM HOMELESSNESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND TODAY I WILL
FOCUS MY REMARKS ON THAT THE
TWO PRIMARY ENTITIES WITH AN
AGENCY THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
HOMELESSNESS POLICY
HOMELESSNESS- FINDING- IN
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL
ENTITIES. AND THOSE TWO.
ENTITIES ARE THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. I JUST BRIEFLY ON THE
HOMELESS OF COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL IT WAS
CREATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY
STATE LAW. THE COUNCIL IS
ENTRUSTED TO IMPLEMENT AND
COORDINATE HOUSING FIRST
POLICIES GUIDELINES AND
REGULATIONS. THE COUNCIL-
CONSISTS OF NINETEEN MEMBERS OF
ONE MEMBER ISAPPOINTED BY THE
STATE SENATE. RULES COMMITTEE
AND ONE MEMBER BY THE SPEAKER
OF THE ASSEMBLY. I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT HOMELESSNESS IS
SOLVABLE I BET IT REQUIRES AS
MENTIONED EARLIER FOCUSED
COORDINATION ACROSS THE STATE
SYSTEMS GOOD DATA TO INFORM AND
MEASURE OUR PROGRESS STRONGER
STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
AND INVESTMENT IN INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES. AND OUR EFFORT ALSO
MUST BE GROUNDED IN THE
DRESSING THE RACIAL INEQUITIES
THAT EXIST WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
LIKE AMERICANS AND INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AT A HIGHER RATE THIS IS
LARGELY DUE TO STANDING
HISTORICAL AND STRUCTURAL
RACISM AND COBIT NINETEEN IN
MANY CASES HAS EXACERBATED
THESE INEQUITIES. HANDS AS WE
MOVE TOGETHER WE MUST ACT WITH
THE SHARED RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADVANCE MULTI PRONGED IN
MULTIYEAR SOLUTIONS TO MEET
PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS TO INCREASE
SHELTERING AND PERMANENT
HOUSING OPTIONS AND ALSO TO
PREVENT INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS. IN RECENT YEARS
OUR AGENCY HAS BEEN PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT OF HISTORIC LEVELS OF
FUNDING TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AS OUTLINED BY AT THE
LEGISLATIVE. ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND I NOTICE MORALIS. HEDT FOR
EXAMPLE HAS AWARDED. OVER ONE
POINT ONE BILION UNDER THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. ALSO SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
NEARLY ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN FUNDING HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND HOMELESS
CONTINUUM OF CARE THROUGH THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM
AND THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. THE FLEXIBLE USE OF
THESE FUNDS HAS BEEN CRITICAL
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES. ALSO
WITHIN THE STRUCTURE THERE IS A
SET ASIDE FOR A YOUTH- AND-
DOUBLE THROUGH THROUGH THE HEAP
AND HAVE PROGRAM AND HAVING TO
SET ASIDE HAS ENABLED
COMMUNITIES TO TARGET AT
STRATEGIES. FOR SERVING-
HOMELESS YOUTH. WE HAVE ALSO
SEEN AN INCREASE IN REGIONAL
COORDINATION AND PLANNING DUE
TO THESE ADVANCEMENTS. BUT IN
THE PROCESS OF ADMINISTERING
THE SPONSOR WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE GOOD DATA TO MEASURE OUR
IMPACT. THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS EMBARKED IN THE DESIGN OF A
ROBUST DATA SYSTEM TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL EFFORTS
TO PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY AT
B. C. S. H. BEGAN BUILDINGTHE
STATE'S FIRST EVER UNIFIED
HOMELESS DATA WAREHOUSE. THE
HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM AS WE CALL IT. WILL
ALLOW THE STATE TO ACCESS AND
COMPILED. FROM AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY FOR
CONTINUANCE OF CARE FOR CLC'S.
ALL FORTY FOUR COCS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE EXECUTED DE THAT
USED IT REMAINS WITH B. C. S.
H. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP IN FOR THEIR
CONFIDENCE IN THE STATE LED
EFFORT. WITH CONSISTENT AND
STANDARDIZED DATA WE WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED
PROGRAMMATIC AND POLICY
DECISIONS. LIFT OFF- BEST
PRACTICES IN ALSO DRIVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A LIVE
DEMONSTRATION OF THE HA AS A
WAREHOUSE ONCE IT'S LAUNCHED-
THIS YEAR. AS WE CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
HAVE A CONTEST OR A ROAD MAP
AND TO GUIDE OUR DECISIONS. SO
IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY
WE BEGAN DEVELOPING THE FIRST
HDL C. ACTION PLAN WITH INPUT
AND DATA GATHERED FROM COUNCIL
MEMBERS. PRACTITIONERS
PROVIDERS AND PERSONS WITH LIFT
EXPERTISE FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
HIS ACTION PLAN WILL INCLUDE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND SERVE
AS OUR GUIDING STAR IN OUR
CONTINUED WORK TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE. AT
THE OCTOBER TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY MEETING THE COUNCIL
ADOPTED THE ACTUAL PLAN
FRAMEWORK WOULD KEEP UP WITH
FIVE KEY AREAS BASED ON AN
EQUITABLE COLBECK NINETEEN.
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE AT THE
CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE COUNCIL FOR
THEIR WORK FOR THEIR DILIGENCE.
IN DEVELOPING THIS
COMPREHENSIVE ACTION PLAN AND
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ALL WILL BE
HEARING FROM ONE OF OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS TODAY ALSO MEMBER JODY.
I CATCH CATFISH RIGHT. IN
ADDITION TO FOR. OUR AND ACTION
OR TO LOSE SOLVING HOMELESSNESS
REQUIRE. THAT ALSO IN THAT THEY
IT IN THAT WE EMBRACE NEW UP.
THIS BEEN THE CASE AS BEEN OUR
NOTED- WITH ROOM KEY AND THE
HOME KEY INDUSTRY. PROJECT ROOM
KEY IS THAT BY OUR CALL IN THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL. I AND THEY
HAVE SUCCESS PROVIDE IN HOUSE
TO OVER THREE PEOPLE ACROSS
FORTY TWO COUNTIES. BUILDING ON
THE SUCCESS OF PROJECT HE THE
STATE CREATED HOKEY TO PURCHASE
HOTELS RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES AND OTHER HOUSING.
TO CONVERT THEM INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING FOR PERSONS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. HCD
LEVERAGE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF FUNDS PLUS FIFTY MILLION
AND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND AND
FORTY FIVE MILLION THAT WAS
LEVERAGED THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC
GIVING. IN A MATTER OF MONTHS
WE WERE ABLE TO SCALE AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL PROVIDING
OVER SIX THOUSAND UNITS UNDER
BUDGET AND ON TIME. WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE TO THE- EXTENSIVE
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS INCLUDING COUNTIES AND
CITIES HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN
TRIBES. THEY MADE THIS HAPPEN
AND THEY MADE A STOP IN AT IN
THE RECORD TIME. AS YOU ALL
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION TO DEVELOP HOUSING
NEEDED TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. FOR CONTINUED
HOME KEY ACQUISITIONS. WE'RE
ESTIMATING THAT NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL PERMANENT
HOUSING UNITS CAN BE FUNDED
WITH THIS ONE TIME INVESTMENT.
AND TO SUSTAIN THIS MOMENTUM HE
ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE EARLY
ACTION BY APPROVING TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION AND WEBER
CALLING HOME KEY TO POINT OUT.
LET ME ALSO SHARE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S INNOVATIVE HOW
HUNKY MODEL IS QUICKLY
DEVELOPING AS A BEST PRACTICE
ACROSS THE NET AT THE NATION
AND ALSO WITH INTERNATIONAL
RECOGNITION. TO DATE OUR TEAM
HAS SPOKEN TO OREGON TO
WASHINGTON TO VERMONT TO
MINNESOTA NEW YORK CITY NEW
MEXICO NEW MEXICO ADD TO OUR
FOLKS AT HYDE IN THE TEAM ALSO
FROM BARCELONA SPAIN. ALL OF
THESE PARTNERS AND INDIVIDUALS
ARE CONSIDERING HOW TO UTILIZE
THIS PROGRAMMATIC FRAMEWORK TO
EFFECTIVELY HOUSE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS QUICKLY AND
PERMANENTLY. FINALLY AS WE MOVE
WE MUST CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS TO INCREASE AWARENESS
OF THE CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN HEALTH AND
HOUSING. WE SHOULD ALSO INVEST
IN BUILDING LOCAL CAPACITY TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
ABLE TO EQUITABLY ACCESS
RESOURCES AND HOUSING WITH
DIGNITY RESPECT AND EQUITY. IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY- WE
LAUNCH WITH AN AGENCY THE
STATE'S HOUSING THIS
INITIATIVES. THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO LAUNCH THIS INITIATIVE- AS A
IN RESPONSE TO AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT. AT THIS LEGAL PLATFORM
ENABLES US TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
AND TOOLS TO PREVENT TENANTS
LANDLORDS HOMEOWNERS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS- TO ADDRESS
YOU KNOW HELPING TO KEEP
FAMILY'S HOUSE. UGH WE INTEND
TO LEVERAGE- USED. AS WE
CONTINUE OUR RAISING AWARENESS
AND EDUCATION ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS. I ALSO IN THE
COMING WEEKS WE WILL BE
ANNOUNCING THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CONTRACT GRANTS
TOTALING FOUR POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION. TO HELP GRANTEES. NOW
WITH THE FOCUS ON PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND A
PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS
RACIAL EQUITY AND SOLUTIONS FOR
YOUTH. EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. R. A. THAT AND
STAFF BEEN HER AT WORK. WE NOTE
BOTH INNOVATIVE IDEA AND VIEWS
WITH ACTION DATA FUNDING WELL
NAY TO SUCCESS AS WITH COUNTY.
ARE EAGER TO CONTINUE WORK. WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS
STILL MUCH MORE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. AND- I LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
THE TENSION LOOK FOR TO THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SECRETARY
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS TIME
TO OPEN IT UP TO THE NUMBERS
OF- THIS HEARING HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING.
MADAM SECRETARY FOR A COMING
TODAY REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
PRESENTATION. JUST THE
REGARDING THE- FEEDBACK I KNOW
THE- WE DID MAYBE MADE A
DECISION A COUPLE YEARS AGO TO-
ENSURE THE MONEY OUT ALL SPEED-
AND REALLY. DID DIDN'T- PUT AS
MANY STRINGS ATTACHED TO-
VARIOUS FORMS OF FUNDING
WHETHER IT WAS AROUND HE
PERHAPS- ONE CAN THAT I HAD
WITHIN- WE STARTED. THE
COUNTIES OUTSIDE OF OUR OUR
CHAIRS COUNTY- I'VE BEEN
CONCERNED THAT MANY OF THE
HELLO ESPECIALLY THE LARGER
CARRIERS HAVE TAKEN THE MONEY
BUT NOT REALLY- FOR THE MONEY
TO HIM CHAU OR SHELTER. IN AS
FAST OR EXPEDITIOUS A MANNER AS
POSSIBLE CAN YOU CAN YOU GIVE
US A SENSE- BUT I KNOW YOU'RE
STILL- GETTING THE DATA-
GETTING THE DATA- OF PROGRAM TO
SPEED BUT GIVE US A SENSE OF
JUST SORT OF. YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER OF UNITS OR NUMBER OF
SHELTERS OR- THE BROAD AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE THAT WERE HOUSE
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATIONS.
FROM THE LAST FEW YEARS. THANK
YOU ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT FOR
THE- I AM LET ME ALSO MENTION
THAT- I'M JOINED BY OUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR HOMELESSNESS AT
TODAY- ALLEY ASSET IN- INTO
SHE- CAN CONTROL- ALSO SORT OF.
IN THE AUDITION DETAIL- WITH
REGARD TO YOU KNOW THE OLD- AB.
I GUESS IT DOES SORT THAT TO
PARK WHICH IS IN TERMS OF. TO
SUPPORT OUR- I SHALL- THE- DOG
WE AND HE BENT- ARE YOU KNOW
ELEGY. DOES ARE ELIGIBLE- ENDED
UP IN. KOBE NINETEEN- COURSE
THE ADDITION GUIDE WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH- SERVICE HOME
WRIST. THAT ARE RISK FOR EIGHT
MINUTES. ADEQUATE SHELTER IN AT
INCH. THAT THE GUIDE. THE
COMPANY GUY WERE. INSTEAD AB-
SAFE SHALL. IN SEVEN THAT WEEK-
AID. THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE
HEAP AND HAVE DOLLARS AND THEIR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WAS A VERY HELPFUL. WITH REGARD
TO THE DATA- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
WHICH THAT SHARED THAT ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY- THIS. OP
FOCUSED ON THE H. C. A. S.
SYSTEM HAS BEEN A PRIORITY FOR
US IS TO BE ABLE TO- BETTER
UNDERSTAND. THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING SERVED
ACROSS THE STATE OUR AND THE
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED. I DON'T THINK
THAT I CAN- STATE CURRENTLY
THAT WE HAVE THAT THE ABILITY
TO DO THAT AS A STATE. I AND
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS WITH THIS HVAC SYSTEM.
TO BE ABLE TO GATHER DATA FROM
THE LOCAL CONTINUUM OF CARE
THAT ARE TRACKING PEOPLE SERVE
TYPES OF SERVICES BEING UP
BEING PROVIDED. IN OUTCOMES IN
THE GATHERING THAT INFORMATION
INTO A OUT STATE- THE DATABASE
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE- A
COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS OUR STATE. AND
SO I WOULD MAYBE JUST AN
INVITE- ALLEY IF YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SPECIFIC INFORMATION.
AT THE WAY IN. GOOD MORNING- I
WOULD JUST ADD AS- ON- KEEP.
NEED YOU AND HAVE ANYWAY THAT
WERE DUE TO LAST JANUARY FIRST
I'M WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
ANALYZING THOSE ABBOTT HAVE
BOTH EXPENDITURE DATA BASED ON
CATEGORY AS WELL AS- SOME
GENERAL INFORMATION AROUND
NUMBER SERVICE THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU MORE.
UPDATED INFORMATION HERE IN THE
NEXT MONTH OR SO ON THOSE
NUMBERS AT THE DATA WE HAVE TO
DATE IS IT ONLY UP THROUGH
JUNE- BUT I WILL SAY FROM FROM
THE DATA THAT WE RECEIVE FROM
JUNE AT OVER 50% OF. THE HEAT
FUNDING HAD ALREADY BEEN SPEND
DOWN- THE MAJORITY OF THAT
ONLINE- TO YOUR POINTS FOR THE
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS AND
SHELTERING EFFORTS- SO WE DO
HAVE SOME OF THAT DATA BUT IT
IS OVER SIX MONTHS OLD NOW AND
WILL BE GETTING NEW WORK
PRESSURE DATE AFTER SEPTEMBER.
HERE IN THE NEXT MONTH OR SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WHEN IT
COMES AND- IF I IF I MAY JUST
FOLLOW UP WITH THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY. SO GIVEN- THE JUNE
REPORT IN 50% OF THE MONEY THAT
WAS SPENT CAN YOU GIVE US A
SENSE SENSE OF HOW MANY- PEOPLE
FAMILIES. WERE ASSISTED. I
DON'T WITHOUT. THROUGH YES
THROUGH THE QUARTERLY WE'LL ASK
FOR EXPANDED DATA ANNUAL
REPORTS CONSUMER IT WHERE WE
NEED REQUESTED ADDITIONAL DATA-
FROM THEM SO THAT WILL BE
COMING IN AND YOU KNOW HERE IN
THE NEXT MONTH OR SO WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
PEOPLE SIR I'M SO WE DON'T WE
DON'T HAVE DATA THAT'S THAT'S-
BUT- REALLY GOOD ONLINE IT'S
WELL OVER A YEAR OLD AT THIS
POINT SO I WOULD. I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT WE WAIT TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION I'M
HAPPY TO THE SECRETARY'S POINT.
AND THAT WILL BE SOME OF THE
DATA WE WILL BE ABLE TO PULL IN
IN MUCH MORE LIFETIME ONCE EACH
DAY. GREAT DO WE DO WE GET A
REPORT JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. HE POINTED I WOULD I
NEED A MINUTE TO JUST PULL
THOSE UP AND I WOULD JUST- I
WOULD I WOULD NOTE THAT I'M NOT
SURE WE HAVE THAT LEVEL OF
DETAIL IN. MEANING FOR THAT
ANNUAL REPORT WE WERE NOT.
ASKING PEOPLE HOW MANY PEOPLE
THEY SERVED. YES NUMBER SIR I
DON'T THINK WE WOULD
NECESSARILY CARE POINT AROUND
BROKERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT WE
DON'T GET TO THAT LEVEL WHAT
KIND OF SERVICES IN A REPORT
YOU'RE COLLECTING- FOR TWENTY
TWENTY. YEAH I KNOW I THINK IT
JUST BE GOOD TO KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE SERVED IN AND THEN
GOING JUST BACK TO MY QUESTION
REGARDING THE COUNTIES- I KNOW
THAT WHEN WE WENT TO. HOP THAT
WE DID INCLUDE THE COUNTIES AYE
I WAS VERY CONCERNED THAT A
NUMBER OF THE COUNTIES-
TRADITIONALLY- HADN'T-
DEMONSTRATED SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF ACTION IN THE HOMELESSNESS
ARENA I JUST WANTED TO- SORT OF
GET YOUR VANTAGE POINT ON- AS
SOON AS COUNTY STARTED TO SPEND
THE KEEP MONEY ON IF YOU GOT A
SENSE OF WHERE THAT WAS BEING
SPENT AND WHETHER YOU THOUGHT
THAT COUNTIES WERE ACTING AS
AGGRESSIVELY AS YOU KNOW AND
FEEL A SENSE OF URGENCY THAT WE
WERE ALL FEELING UP HERE AT THE
STATE. YEAH I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT- PERHAPS SPENDING WHICH
ARE JUST A REMINDER. I JUST GOT
ACCESS TO HERE IN MAINE AND SO
WHAT WE'LL BE SEEING A LOT MORE
OF THAT ADDITIONAL. DETAIL HERE
IN THIS. IN THE NEXT TEN REPORT
I MENTIONED BUT BUT FROM THE
APPLICATIONS RECEIVING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE'VE BEEN
DOING WE DON'T HAVE ANY REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
SPENDING THAT MONEY DOWN IN
ANY. SORT OF MASS LIKE LESS
QUICK- EFFICIENT WAYS AND THEN
CITIES AND INTO YOUR SEATS. ONE
OF THE REASON I ASK IS BECAUSE
WE ONE OF THE REASONS WE- RE
APPROPRIATED MONEY FROM THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INITIATIVE- WAS
IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO MANY
COUNTIES NOT. ACTING ON
HOMELESSNESS. IN SO HAVE YOU
SEE. ANY PATTERNS BECAUSE-
WITHOUT LOCK OF ACTION. NO I
THINK THE ONE THING I WOULD
MENTION THERE IS- YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN SEEING QUITE A BIT-
OF COORDINATION AND SPENDING
COORDINATION BETWEEN CITIES
COUNTIES AND CRCS PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO KEEPING FOLKS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS STATE
FROM CORBIN. I'M SO I WOULD%
EXPECT THAT WERE SEEKING- YOU
KNOW WHETHER THIS IS SPECIFIC
OR SPECIAL ACCESS TO THIS YEAR
OR NOT I THINK WE DID SEE AND
HAVE SEEN. IN THAT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WE GAVE OUT FOR
KOBE- THAT AND THAT COUNTY
RECEIVED PART OF. FUNDING AS
WELL AND NOT FINDING. WAS SPENT
ON QUITE QUICKLY. RIGHT STATE
TAKING THEM SAFE- AND RANCHO
WILL BE INTO. SITE SOME QUITE.
ACTION THIS YEAR SPECIFICALLY
IN RELATION. TO SOME OF THE NEW
AROUND. THE NATION GREAT FOR
THAT LET'S MEMBER TO THE NEXT
WILL HAVE SOME LOCAL PER. AS
WELL TWO SOME MORE OF THAT
DETAIL CONVERSE. PERFECT IN
JUST LAST QUESTION IS WOULDN'T
WANT THAT DATA GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE FROM. THE JANUARY
FIRST REPORTS. THERE WERE EIGHT
FOR MID. SO THREE TO WEEKS NOW
WE SHOULD HAVE AYE AYE SUMMARY
AYE BOTH. HAPPY AND THAT THE
CROSSOVER BETWEEN. OKAY GREAT
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO TAKE
MORE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
FONG AND COOPER MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- I HAD A SPARE
QUESTIONS VERY MUCH ALONG THE
LINES OF- OKAY CHAIRMAN TANG
AND I WIVES WANT TO THANK THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY THE CHANCE TO
DISCUSS EARLIER WITH HER SOME
OF OUR- DATA COLLECTION
INITIATIVES AND WAS REQUIRED BY
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. I GUESS I
WOULD JUST ASK- GET OUT DO YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE OF THE AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
THAT HAVE BEEN ON SPENT EITHER
IN TOTAL DOLLAR AMOUNT OR
PERCENTAGE OR IS THAT SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT FOR
FEBRUARY TO GET AND THEN. JUST
ALL THE BROADER QUESTION OF HOW
MANY FOLKS WE CERTAINLY DO YOU
HAVE ANY INCLINATION IS THIS
TEN THOUSAND IS A FIFTY
THOUSAND IS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
WHITE HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THE MONEY
THAT WE'VE ALLOCATED. IT TO AND
THAT THIS THE SPEND DOWN PIECES
I THINK WE WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. THREE SEPTEMBER-
IN THAT THE FEBRUARY REPORT
MEETINGS YOU CAN GIVE TO YOU
ALL. AND WE'RE TRACKING KEEP
SPENDING A PARTICULAR QUITE
CLOSELY RIGHT NOW KNOWLEDGE IN
THAT THAT MONEY IS SET TO
EXPIRE. AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR- ALL. BUT IF A FEW
PERCENTAGE POINTS OF THAT
FUNDING IS ALREADY BEEN
OBLIGATED WE ARE EXPECTING.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE NEEDS
AROUND CO BUT THAT THAT MONEY.
WILL BE SPENT QUITE QUICKLY.
I'M SO I DON'T THINK WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE'RE-
WE'RE TRACKING OBLIGATION RATES
QUITE CLOSELY FOR HAPPEN SO
WE'LL KNOW MORE ABOUT THAT. IN
THE NEXT ROUND AND- AGAIN THOSE
ARE ONLY FOR TO THOSE TWO
LARGE. TOPPING STRANGER NOT
REPEATING SOME OF THE OTHER
STATE. STATE CONSERVATION. I'M
AND THEN I BELIEVE- I REQUEST
WAS IN RELATION TO THAT TO.
SERVE YOU KNOW WE- WILL WE HAVE
BETTER DATA WITH WITH AGE I
THINK IT WAS ON LIKE A BROKE
RECORD- BUT I THINK FOR SOME OF
THE THINGS WE SUFFER FOR COPING
IN PARTICULAR. IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE KIND OF SERVICE
SOMEONE IS RECEIVING AND SO YOU
KNOW WE STOPPED ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND FOLKS I'M BEING
SERVED. FOR SOME OF THE
CONCRETE SHELTERS IN AND KOBE-
AGUIAR-CURRY HE OUR YOU KNOW WE
SAW THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
THE ESTIMATED TO BE SERVED OR
SOME OF THE HYGIENE STATIONS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO- IT
REALLY DOES DEPEND ON. THE KIND
OF LEVEL OF INTENSITY OF
SERVICE THAT'S BEING PROVIDED.
AND IS THERE THANK YOU AND IS
THERE I MEAN SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF A DATA
LACK HERE RIGHT I MEAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET. INTO MID
FEBRUARY NUMBERS FROM SEPTEMBER
IS THE REASON WHY WE HAVE TO
WAIT SEVERAL MONTHS TO KNOW
ABOUT WHETHER MONEY'S BEEN
SPENT I MEAN THAT SEEMS TO BE A
FAIRLY EASILY. EASY THING TO
KEEP TRACK OF. ORDERLY EXPECT.
REPORTS FROM. THE THAT REQUIRE
SOME DELAY FROM THEM. ASK MORE
THAN THAT. THREE MONTHS WHICH
MORE THAN WHAT IS STATURE. WERE
BUT WE ARE GETTING. AT LEAST
YOU KNOW THEY THEY HAVE SOME
GREAT TEAM THEY NEED TO GET
THAT INFORMATION FROM THEIR SUB
GRANTEES. THEY NEED TO COLLECT
THAT AND THEN SEND THAT TO US
AND THEN WE NEED TO ANALYZE IT
SO THERE IS A BIT OF A LACK OF
EXPENDITURE DATA- THAT'S THAT'S
NOT. PARTICULARLY DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER WAYS WE'VE SEEN
ACROSS THE STATE. BUDGET
FUNDING PROGRAMS. AND YOU ACT
YOU ANTICIPATE THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO CUT DOWN ON THAT. DELAY
WITH THE NEW SYSTEM THAT YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT. EIGHTY
ASKED DOES NOT. EXPENDITURE
DATA. IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
DOLLARS IT INCLUDES FUNDING OF.
FUNDING FUNDING STREAM FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT WOULD START.
THE WILL STILL NEED TO BE
COLLECTING EXPENDITURE DATA-
AND THERE IS A LACK FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PARTICULARLY THIS
YEAR GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF WORK.
I WOULD I WOULD. I ENCOURAGE
OUR LOCAL PANEL AFTER THIS TO
SPEAK TO SOMEONE BACK- BUT
GIVEN THE WORK IN THE URGENCY
OF THE EMERGENCY THAT THEY HAD
THIS YEAR. AND WE HAVE BEEN
VERY UNDERSTANDING OF DELAYS IN
GETTING US DATA. AND HAVING
THAT BEING SUBMITTED TO US SO I
ON THE EXPENDITURE PIECE. I'M
THERE IT'S JUST A NATURAL DELAY
AND THERE'S EVEN MORE SO DELAY
IN DATA COLLECTION THIS YEAR
GIVEN SOME OF THE URGENCY
MICHAEL. I'M BUT BUT BASS I
ASSIST IN WILL BE ABLE TO TELL
US THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE BEING
SERVED IN MUCH MORE LIFETIME.
THANK YOU JUST AND JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION ON THIS ONE AND I
WE CAN CONTINUE TO. OFFLINE I
GUESS BEST. GET YOUR REFERENCE
THAT SOME OF THE DATA YOU HAVE
IS FOR HE PERHAPS FOR THE
LARGER PROGRAMS BUT THAT THERE
ARE OTHER STATE FUNDS ARE THERE
OTHER STATE FUNDS WERE
ALLOCATED WHEN WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING ANY DATA RELATED TO
IT. OR OR OR THEIR DATA SYSTEMS
AND YOU ANTICIPATE THAT IN THE
FUTURE. WE'RE GONNA BILL TO
COLLECT MORE DATA AROUND THESE
OTHER STATE EXPENDITURES.
OUTSIDE OF HIP HOP. LET ME
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. WE HAVE.
OTHER ADAM. A MAN. YOU KNOW
EXAMPLE. TRYING TO GROOM KEY-
THE TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS SERVED AS WE ARE
NOW TRACKING THAT DATA. HOME
KEY SIX THOUSAND UNITS- THE
BUILT IN WE ARE TRACKING THAT.
DATA AS IT SHOULD TO I THINK
TO. TO THIS POINT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING. THE
ABILITY TO. GATHER THIS
INFORMATION IN. ONE PLACE AT
IT. IT CURRENTLY DOESN'T EIST
IN ONE PLACE- DEBT DAD LEVEL OF
REPORTING. IS TIED TO A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR- ADMINISTERING A DOSE- THAT
PROGRAM FUNDS. AND SO. YOU KNOW
I DO RECOGNIZE- HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO HAVE A- COMPLETE
PICTURE. H. D. A. S. I BELIEVE
WILL- GIVE US DATE THE PLATFORM
IN THE FOUNDATION NECESSARY TO
BE ABLE TO. TO BUILD THAT
COMPLETE SYSTEM. THANK YOU YEAH
I THINK HAVE A COMPLETE PICTURE
THREE REALLY AND SO BEING ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND IT LOOKS
HOLLISTER HOWARD MONEY HOW MUCH
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT WHAT THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS HOW
MANY PEOPLE WERE HELPING. IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IF WE
HAVE TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
DATA AND DO DATA DRIVEN POLICY
MAKING I WOULD BE VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR THAT SO APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS ON THAT FRONT. YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. I THANK YOU
MEDICARE I JUST. WANT TO- THE
SIM BEING THE CENTER VALLEY WE
ALSO HAVE CERTAIN- CAN WE HAVE
THIS ENORMOUS CONCERNS AND
HOMELESSNESS- AS DO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE BAY AREA AND
LOS ANGELES- AS SOMEONE WHO AS
ADVOCATE AND INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION ON CREATING A MORE
ROBUST AND FUNCTIONAL STATEWIDE
DATA SYSTEM I'M TRYING TO
RECONCILE RECONCILE. THE AS MY
AS MY COLLEAGUES IN THE BAY
AREA IS MENTIONED THAT SENSE OF
URGENCY TO INVEST RESOURCES-
ALONG WITH THE DATA LAG AS A MY
COLLEAGUE LOS ANGELES MANSION-
IS THERE A WORK AROUND RIGHT
NOW WHERE I KNOW THAT COUNTIES
ARE COLLECTING BEARS H.
INPUTTING INFORMATION IN THEIR
LOCAL AGENT MY **** DO YOU GUYS
REGULATE TALK TO THE COCS TO
GATHER THAT DATA- AND AT LEAST
TO HAVE THAT. HAVE A OF A MORE
REAL TIME PICTURE. AS A WE AS
YOU DEVELOP THIS. STATEWIDE
DATABASE. ONE YES. TAG TEAMING
HERE- YEAH SO IT REALLY SHOULD
EACH DANCE WITHOUT GETTING TOO
IN THE WEEDS HERE THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE SYSTEM WILL DO
I'M SO WE WILL BE COLLECTING
ALL FORTY FOUR ZERO C. LOCAL
HMIS DATA INTO ONE STATEWIDE
WAREHOUSE I'M SO THAT WILL
INCLUDE THE ABILITY TO HAVE AND
I'M AT THE DATA IS BEING
ENTERED IN DANGER WE WILL BE
DOING I'M A FREQUENT PULLED OF
THAT DATA. INTO THE H. CARE ACT
SYSTEM TO BE ABLE. TO LOOK AT
THAT. EXACTLY YES. ON SOME OF
THE OF YOUR MONEY WHAT THE TIME.
FOR THIS I'M AWARE OF AS YOU
MENTIONED BEFORE WE'RE
OPERATING ON. SIX MONTH SIX
MONTH OLD DATA- AND- SO- IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT YOU JUST
CALL THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
ACCESS OR HMIS DATA. AGGREGATED
AND AT LEAST HAVE THAT GOING ON.
ISN'T THAT NOT KNOW OR MY
SIMPLIFYING IT. YEAH IT'S SADLY
NOT THAT SIMPLE- WE WISH IT
WERE- IT IS ACTUALLY QUITE
COMPLEX BERMAN DATA SECURITY
STANDPOINT FROM ACTUALLY
BUILDING THAT THE DATA SYSTEM
ITSELF WE DO HAVE A VENDOR IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW- AND A TEAM OF
FOLKS AT WITHIN HCFC THAT ARE
ARE ARE VERY VERY- INTENSELY
BUILDING OUT THE SYSTEM WE HOPE
IT WILL BE READY- BY THE END OF
MARCH EARLY APRIL- FOR THE
PUBLIC J. C. DASHBOARD AND
THINGS LIKE OF THAT NATURE BUT-
I'M QUITE A BIT THAT IS
INVOLVED IN TEAMS OF PULLING
THAT DATA AND- THE DUPLICATING
AT DE IDENTIFYING IT AND BEING
ABLE THAT TO VISUALIZE IT IN
WAYS THAT MAKE SENSE FOR
GENERAL PUBLIC. OKAY TRANSIT I
WILL I'LL SAY THAT THE BIGGEST
FILLED WAS TOUTED AS ONE OF THE
FEW CITIES THAT THAT I GUESS I
STILL ZERO WE'RE NOW AS THE-
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. HOMELESSNESS IS
STILL A CHALLENGE JUST BASED ON
DEFINITION SO- I THINK I WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THAT- YOU KNOW WE
PROBABLY NEED TO MOVE A LITTLE
FASTER OR WE NEED MORE REAL
TIME DATA AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE COMPLICATIONS OF CREATING A
STATEWIDE DATABASE BUT- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE'S-
PROBABLY A NEED TO. FIGURE OUT
A PARALLEL PROCESS TO COLLECT
THAT THEY COLLECT INFORMATION
SO THAT WE ACTUALLY- UNDERSTAND
THE EFFICACY OF THE FUNDING
THAT WORD THAT'S BEING ALLOCATE
ESPECIALLY AS THE AMOUNTS ARE
GROWING- SIGNIFICANTLY I'M
GOING TO THE COCS- I MEAN IS
THERE DISCUSSION I AM AT MY
LAST QUESTION IS THERE
DISCUSSION TO KIND. OF OR HOW
OFTEN DO YOU. GATHER DATA NOT
BEFORE THIS. FOR THE DATABASE
SYSTEM BUT JUST. TO UNDERSTAND
IT WHETHER WE'RE AFFECT.
REDUCING HOME. YEAH. THIRTY
THREE YEAH I WAS JUST GOING M.
AND MANAGE AND YOU CAN IN HERE
ALLEY AT I THINK THAT IT'S TIME
IT'S ALSO AS WE LOOK AT- THAT
DATA TO YOUR POINT RIGHT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE
ACCELERATING AND DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO GET THE
H. E. I. S. SYSTEM IN PLACE AND
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE IT UP AND
RUNNING BY THE END OF MARCH AND
SO WE'RE WORKING WITH A SENSE
OF URGENCY ON THAT-
ADDITIONALLY- IT WITH REGARD TO
THE REPORTS THAT ARE COMING IN
FROM- GRANT HE SAID HE'D BEEN
HAPPY- DOLLARS. AND YOU KNOW WE
TAKEN NOTED THAT IT TOOK YOU
KNOW IMPORTANT ALSO- TO AT TO
BE ABLE TO SHARE THIS
INFORMATION AND- AND SORT OF
PICK EXTRACTING A MORE. HOW IAN
AND INTO WE TAKE THAT BACK A
BIT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- I YOU KNOW KIND OF
REITERATE- THE EFFORT THAT IS
UNDERWAY THROUGH THE HDFC
COUNCIL TO DEVELOP A STRATEGIC
ACTION PLAN WITH A SET OF GOALS
OBJECTIVES. I AND YOU THE CLIP
WE SHOULD ALSO SORT OF IDENTIFY
AND THAT THE VERY ESPINO STATE
AGENCIES AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING TO
IMPLEMENT THAT ACTION PLAN. AND
IN THAT THE CONNECTION THERE TO
THE DATA IS GOING ON ASKED WE-
OF FINALIZE OUR ACTION PLAN AND
ESTABLISH YOU KNOW AT A SET OF-
STANDARDIZED THE DATA THAT IS-
YOU CAN SORT OF KNOCK COMMON.
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING WE
WILL BE ABLE TO- TO. MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS ABOUT ABOUT
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES AND ALSO
M. S. YOU KNOW MENTIONED
EARLIER BE ABLE TO LIFT UP THE-
GOOD WORK THAT IS HAPPENING IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS BEING OUT AT
THE STATE. I'M IN BUT ALSO YOU
KNOW- PROVIDE TARGETED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY BUILDING
AND OUR SUPPORT. SO IMAGINE
THAT BECAUSE- WERE WERE MINDFUL
WE ARE WORKING WITH A SENSE OF
URGENCY AND WORK YEAH WELL
FOCUS BOTH ON AT ESTABLISHING A
DATA SYSTEM THAT ENABLES US TO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION TO MAKE
THOSE INFORMED DECISIONS. BUT
ALSO- TO MAP OUT AN ACTION PLAN
THAT DRIVES THE WORK THAT IS
HAPPENING- ACROSS AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR AND A IS AN I
THINK THE DAY IS- EXTRA
IMPORTANT AS AS A REAL TIME AS
WE CAN GET I'VE- TOWARD NUMBER
FACILITIES UNLESS AND- THE- OF
THE BUDGET CHAIRMAN AS HAD
NUMBER HEARINGS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BAY AREA- SO
YOU KNOW WE AND I HAVE ACTUALLY
ACCESS AND LOOKED AT MY AGE IN
MY SYSTEM IN KERN COUNTY- WITH
THE COLLABORATION FOR THE CITY
IN OUR COUNTY SO I MEAN I'VE
SEEN THE DATA I- IT'S BY NAME
IT'S OUT THERE. I CAN CALL
EVERY COUNTY HMIS I CAN ACCESS
OR I CAN ASK FOR INFORMATION
AND I AGREE AGGREGATE THE DATA
SO IF I CAN DO IT IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE LIKE IF WE
WHEN WE IS OF THAT LEGISLATION
SHOULD BE OPERATING AS MUCH
REAL TIME AS POSSIBLE- INSTEAD
OF OPERATING ON SIX MONTH
INFORMATION WHERE THINGS HAVE
CHANGED SO DRAMATICALLY
ESPECIALLY WITH COVERAGE-
EVERYTHING IS CHANGING BY THE
MOMENT AS AN YOU KNOW AND
HOMELESSNESS CONTINUES TO
POSSIBLY GROW ADDRESS PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL AS A BIG
CHALLENGE SO I THANK THE CHAIR
FOR THE ADOPTING THIS QUESTIONS.
AND BECAUSE WE WORK. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG I THE PART
OF. THIS IS. OF THE FACE OR
SELL AND IS THAT COUNTY
OPERATES. DID YOU SYSTEM
SYSTEMS A DOES NOT COMMUNICATE
WITH EACH OTHER. MUCH LESS WITH
THE STATE. SO THANK YOU
SECRETARY FOR YOUR EFFORTS IN
THIS NEW DATABASE THAT BRINGS
IN. A LEASE INFORMATION ON THE
ON THE FEDERAL SIDE- AND
HOPEFULLY WITHIN. NOT TOO MANY
YEARS FROM NOW WE ARE ABLE TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT TALKS TO
EACH OTHER WHERE WE HAVE CITIES
AND COUNTIES- BEING ABLE TO
ALSO GIVE US THE INFORMATION
THAT WE NEED TO. ENSURE THAT
WE'RE DOING GOOD POLICY. I WANT
TO BE- I LOVE THAT WE HAVE THIS
INCREDIBLE AND ROBUST
CONVERSATION- WE DO HAVE. A LOT
OF MEMBERS THAT WISH TO SPEAK
WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
QUICK SILVA A QUICK SILVA. AND
I ARE GOING TO- A CHAIR TODAY
FROM HOUSING ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK SO.
MISTER COOPER ALL. YEAH I'LL BE
BRIEF MESSAGE. OF A YOU MESSICK
THANK AND YOUR- FOR ALL YOU DO.
NOT JUST FALL ON THE FONG
QUESTIONS- DID. FORTRESS WHICH
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS- ALL TIMES
COMMITTEE AND IN MY BIG ISSUE
IS THAT I THINK YOU ALLOWS YOUR
SAYING ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
POPULATION. HAS SOME TYPE OF
MILK MENTAL ILLNESS AND 70%
HAVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS I
WAS NUMBERS ARE DRAMATICALLY
HIGHER WITH THAT. WE SPENT
POINT FOUR BILLION SINCE YOU
KNOW TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND I
BELIEVE MISS MORALIS SAID THAT
THEY'RE ABOUT SEVENTY PERCENT.
OF THE FOLKS ARE IN THERE AND
INNER EARLIER STATEMENTS. WAS
ANY THAT MONEY EITHER PROGRAMS
TARGETED FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. OR JUST
HOMELESSNESS A PERIOD. I KNOW
DEFINITELY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER AND IT FINDS OUT BOTH
WITHIN H. ET- AT THE NO PLACE
LIKE HOME PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE
AND IS FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR INDIVIDUALS I WENT AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND- YEAH THE
NEEDS AND I CAN I ALSO ASK OUR
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- COASTAL
THE LAST KISS WAS RELATIVELY
NEW AT THE STATE GOVERNMENT AND
TO JOIN US FOR THIS HEARING AND
SO- IF I MAY I CAN ASK HIM TO
PUT A PROVIDE JUST AT SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THAT
PROGRAM- BUT- YEAH. DEEPLY INTO
BASICALLY THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS YES THE YOUNG
DOLLARS ARE ALSO BEING ADDED
THAT USED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
SUPPORT OF SERVICES WE ARE ALSO
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
AS WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
POPULATIONS THAT REQUIRE THE
COMBINATION OF HOUSING AND
SERVICES APART- ABLE TO ACCESS
YOU DON'T THAT LEVEL OF
SUPPORT. AND SERVICE DOUBLE
WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PROVIDE AND JUST SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM YEAH
APPRECIATE SECRETARY THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK YOUR QUESTION IS
SO IMPORTANT WE CANNOT. FULLY
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT.
ADDRESSING. THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH. S. N.
SEPT OR DEGREE AND LIMITS YOU
KNOW THEY KNOW PLACE LIKE HOME.
WORLD BUT IT'S NOT THE- ONLY
ONE GUY ADDRESSES I. AT HOME
BUSINESS AND MENTAL HEALTH
CABINET- ARE ADMINISTER ALSO BY
H. COME. EMERGENCIES TO PROGRAM
THE HOUSING FOR HEALTH CAN YOU
PRO THAT MEMBER CHIU WHAT DAHLE
INVOLVING- BOB BOB OF GETTING-
GETTING. LIST ARE YOU GENERAL
THE NOT. FOR ME. SO IN TERMS OF
THIS SCALE THE VOLUME BECAUSE
OF THE ROUGHLY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN FEDERAL AND STATE
MONEY ADMINISTER AT H. U. D.
FOR THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. NO PLACE LIKE HOME IT'S
PROBABLY A YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
DISBURSEMENTS MAILED TO THE
PAYMENTS ALREADY MADE MORE THAN
A BILLION OF THOSE. AB THREE
BILLION DOLLARS SO REALLY
ROUGHLY A THIRD MORE THAN A
THIRD SO IS THIS- IS VERY
CRITICAL THAT. WE THAT WE MAKE
MORE MORE EFFORTS ARE IN
PROGRAMS LIKE- LIKE MOBY DICK
CYCLE AND I WAS I WAS FOLLOWING
THE DEBATE AROUND THE DATE ACT-
I THINK YEAH A LOT OF
COMPLEXITY IN TERMS OF IN A
GREAT RIGHT DATE WITH. WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BUT- THERE
IS A LEVEL ALL DATA AT THAT AT
A MINIMUM AND- IT. NEEDS TO AND
HAS BEEN COLLECTED IN IN
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS AND I THINK
NO PLACE LIKE HOME IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE BECAUSE- WE DON'T ASK
FOR THINGS LIKE PROJECT
LOCATION. SERVICES AND
AMENITIES WE ASK FOR THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSEHOLDS
SERVICE AND THEY'RE VETERAN
STATUS WHICH THEM QUALIFICATION
UPON MORE. AT AS IN AS HOMELESS
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AT RISK OF
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. A NUMBER
OF TENANTS WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE SERIOUS MENTAL DISORDERS
OR THE NUMBER. OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT SERIOUSLY EMOTIONALLY
THIS CHART- AND YOU KNOW THE
AGES CHILDREN ADULTS. ARE HEAD
OF. GEN REYES NEEDS. ARE
CURRENTLY LEVELS AND J. IN THAT.
ARE WHAT DO YOU WERE. WEBER
LEAVING ON THIS VERSUS DOES NOT
COMING SHELTER ALL THESE DATA.
IS EXTRA RICH WE ARE. FOR THE
NOT LIKE. SOMETIMES IT TAKES
MORE TIME TO THE- AT COLLEGE
FROM LOOK JUDGED BUT THAT I
THINK IS THE AIRPORT THAT THE
SECRETARY AND THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY WERE MENTIONING
ABOUT. INTEGRATING ALL OF THESE
ABOUT A MINIMUM WE SHOULD BE
DOING BASS IS SPECIFICALLY WITH
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE IS
ADMINISTERED. ADMINISTERING
SUCH AS THE MARKETS LIKE-
ARKANSAS. SO SKEWED ME RIGHT
NOW RIGHT NOW IT'S A CRIMINALS
IT WAS FREEZING TODAY WAS
THIRTY DEGREES OF FOR MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SOUTH WAS
COLD AS HELL APPEAR. SO THESE
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE THE THING
IS THE REFUSAL KNOCKING TELL ME
WHAT THE UNIVERSE IS WHEN
THEY'RE GOING OUT THERE THESE
PROGRAM CITY OR COUNTY WHAT A
GETTING FOR REFUSALS HOW MANY
FOLKS REFUSING SERVICE AND HELP
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY. BUT TO HAVE THAT
AND I NEVER HEARD ANYONE FROM
ANY STATE AGENCY IN THE SEVEN
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE. THESE
PEOPLE ARE SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL TALKING ABOUT PUTTING THEM
SOMEWHERE IN HOUSING THEM
GETTING THEM. A SHALLOWER
SHELTER MEDICATION AND SOME
USEFUL TOOLS WILL GET. EVENED
OUT AND BE ABLE TO GO ON THEIR
OWN BUT NO ONE'S ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE THE AND THAT'S WHO
PEOPLE SEE EVERY DAY-
CHRONICALLY MENTALLY ILL
THERE'S BEEN NOTHING ADDRESS
THAT WHATSOEVER. FROM ANY STATE
AGENCY TO DEAL WITH THAT. AND
LIKE I SAID IF IT'S FREEZING UP
HERE AND SOME WAS OUT WALKING
WITH NO SHOES. AND NO COAT ON
THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT'S AN
ISSUE AND WE NOT ADDRESS THAT
SO I'D LOVE TO SEE SOME NUMBERS
ON YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID THE 70%
NUMBER WHATEVER WAS SEVENTY
THOUSAND. BUT PEOPLE REFUSING
WHAT IS THE ONE COMMON
DENOMINATOR AND I BELIEVE IT'S-
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND IT'S HARD TO GET OF
OF THOSE IF YOU HAVE A JOB AND
A HOUSE. LITTLE BEING HOMELESS
SO IT'S GREAT THESE PROGRAMS
AND A LOT BUT OUR OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE. INCREASED NOT TO MENTION
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
CUSTOMER BESIDE READ. VERSES
YOU. PAYING YOUR BILL. AND GAS
BY THE NAY SO IT'S COMPOUND. IN
REALLY HURTS PEOPLE BUT I THINK.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ON ITS COVER.
ABOUT THIS ABOUT THE MENTAL
ILLNESS. ABOUT THE SUBSIDIES IN
AND OUT OF SECRETARY. I'D LOVE
TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER I YOU KNOW
I BELIEVE THAT WHEN WE- WHEN WE
SPEAK TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS HOLISTICALLY AND-
BOTH IN TERMS OF PREVENTION AND
LISTEN AS- AS WAS. MENTIONED
EARLIER ALSO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU- IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THAT
WE FOCUSED. THE ROOT CAUSES OF
HOMELESSNESS- WHICH- IN MANY
INSTANCES- ARE A RESULT OF. THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN
MANY CASES IT'S ALSO THE RESULT
OF THE LACK OF ACCESS TO PROPER
HEALTH SERVICES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. IT'S ALSO A
RESULT OF THE LACK OF- HAVING
YOU KNOW. ECONOMIC JUSTICE FOR
ACCESS TO AND A AT A GOOD- JOB
ON THAT YOU KNOW ALLOWS FOR
FAMILY TO BE ABLE TO NOT HAVE
TO SPEND MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR
INCOME ON. HOUSING COSTS
INCIDENT. AND YOU WERE YOU KNOW
CORRECT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
BE- HOLISTIC AND HOW WE ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL HEALTH-
SERVICES IN ENSURING THAT. THE
STATE IS- IN OAK DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO SUPPORT
TO COORDINATE AND ALSO TO GUIDE
THE EFFORTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
TODAY I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WILL BE HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR- THE DIRECTLY FROM-
PROVIDERS AND LEADERS
UNDERGROUND AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL- TO GET THEIR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
HAVING IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE
TO. IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS IN
THE FUNDS THAT THEY'RE
RECEIVING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. I AM ALSO OF COURSE
YOU KNOW VERY. EXCITED TO SEE
THAT THIS NEW FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
AND HOUSING AND HEALTH SERVICES
WITH IT YOU KNOW WITH A FOCUS
ON MENTAL. HEALTH AND SO I JUST
CLEAN AND LOOK TO CAN TO WORK
WITH YOU THE LEFT. ASKED WE-
YOU KNOW IT'S SAW. IN ADDRESSED.
THAT DEFEAT THE ASSISTANCE
ACROSS OF FROM KNOW WE TO ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE DATA AND HAVING
GOOD RELIABLE DATA TO INFORM
OUR DECISIONS BUT I THINK IT'S
ALSO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
RAISING THIS THAT IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND. THAT
COMPLEXITY OF HOMELESSNESS IN
SOME CASES- AND THE NEED. TO
ENSURE THAT WERE- PROVIDING. US
SERVICES- FOR POPULATIONS THAT
ARE STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ADJUSTED FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE OF THE HEARING THE NEXT
PANEL IS READY TO GO SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
COGNISANT OF- SO WE CAN MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT TWO PANELS THE
ADDITIONAL PANELS WILL ALSO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH THE
MENTAL HEALTH CALLENGES AND
PANEL THREE BUT I DO WANT TO
GIVE THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY EXPRESSED AN INTEREST
TO ASK QUESTIONS TO ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS SO WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PORTAL SILVA. MR CHIU
INDUSTRY KINDLY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KIRKSVILLE THE PLACE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND- I KNOW
TIM IS GOING BY BUT THIS IS
SUCH A VITAL CONVERSATION AND I
HOPE THAT SOME OF YOU WILL STAY
WITH US EVEN AFTER YOUR PANEL-
AGAIN I WILL BE A SPEEDY HERE
BUT- TO THE MADAM SECRETARY
HOUSING DIRECTOR OF ALASKA'S
AND I'M SORRY I DIDN'T GET HER
LAST NAME BUT KELLY. I DO WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU I KNOW THAT
WORKING ON HOMELESSNESS IS NOT
ONLY DIRE BUT IT IS NEVER
ENDING AND TO ALL THOSE
PROVIDERS OUT THERE THAT WORK
TIRELESSLY BUT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
KNOW AND A- IS THE DEATHS.
EVERY DAY WE'RE LOSING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE NOT ONLY TO
COALBED BUT BEFORE THAT IT WAS.
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. IN
ORANGE COUNTY- WE ARE NOT THE
ORANGE COUNTY HOUSE WIVES WE
ARE ORANGE COUNTY LOSING. UP TO
FORTY PEOPLE A MONTH. THAT ARE
DYING ON ORANGE COUNTY STREETS.
SOME OF IT IS NO COVERT RELATED
BUT THIS WAS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC SO A FEW OF THE THINGS
THAT I DID STARTED MY FIRST
COMMENTS AND I REALLY REALLY
WANT. AND EMPHASIS IS ON THIS
IS AS THE GOVERNOR TALKED LAST
YEAR ABOUT USING STATE LANDING
COUNTY LAND IN BRINGING IN
MOBILE UNITS AND BRINGING IN
TENTS AND SHELTERS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO KNOW IS
WHEN COVE IT DIES DOWN WHAT
WILL WE DO WITH THOSE
FACILITIES AFTER BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL GOING TO HAVE HOMELESS
THAT IS A QUESTION. SECOND
LIGHT BASICALLY AGING AS WE
KNOW WITH CO THAT ARE FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS. ARE- MARKETS ANY
PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO USE THE
FACILITY HAS BASICALLY BEEN
CLOSED DOWN. AT THE CORE OF OUR
STATE. OUR NATION TO JUST HAVE
A SAFE PLACE FOR SOMEBODY TO
WASH THEIR HANDS AND USE A
BATHROOM IS NOT PROVIDED. SO
ONE OF MY **** IS WHAT TO OUR
CONTINUUM OF CARE STAR HEALTH
PROVIDERS. IS AT THE LEAST WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET
FACILITIES OUT WHERE WE KNOW
HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE
CONGREGATING. THIS SHOULD BE A
VERY BASIC RIGHT HOUSING SHOULD
BE OUR RIGHT BUT SIMPLY TO USE
A BATHROOM AND I WANT YOU TO
IMAGINE YOURSELF DRIVING. AS I
DID FROM FULLERTON SERVICE
SACRAMENTO THERE IS NO PLACE TO
USE THE FACILITY UNLESS YOU'RE
AT A REST STOP OR AT A GAS
STATION AND WE KNOW ARE
HOMELESS DO NOT HAVE CARS. AND
IT'S NOT A PLEASANT THOUGHT.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO BETTER SO
DATA IS IMPORTANT I MEAN WHAT I
KNOW BUT I CAN TELL YOU WE CAN
GO ON. TO OUR LIST OF PEOPLE
WHO DIED AND WE CAN COUNT THOSE
EVERY SINGLE MONTH THERE'S A
PRIEST AND FULLER TEN. FATHER
DENNIS REPORTS THIS EVERY
SINGLE MONTH OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
DIE IN ORANGE COUNTY. SO DATA
IS IMPORTANT BUT WE GOTTA FOCUS
ON WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE AND WHY
THEY'RE DYING. AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED MR JIM COOPER WE KNOW
THAT MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION ARE PART OF THE
STORY. AND WE HAVE THE VAST
STATE LANDS THAT ARE NOT BEING
USED. AN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
AND WE OF NORWALK THESE ARE
PLACES THAT USED TO HOUSE
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
HOUSING PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. SO I'VE SAID A
LOT HERE I'M GOING TO KEEP
SAYING THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK BUT IT IS ABOUT DATA. BUT
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING
AND I KNOW SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF I MAY I JUST
BASICALLY WANT TO MENTION THAT-
D. SPONSORED WERE MADE
AVAILABLE PARTICULARLY THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION- THAT
WAS MADE AVAILABLE BY AND IN
THE PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
THAT THIS PAST SUMMER AS A
RESPONSE ACTUALLY IT WAS IN.
MARCH APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
ACTED RESPONSIBLY NINETEEN NOT
ENABLED AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO BE ABL TO PURCHASE- HYGIENE
STATIONS- AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
AND YOU KNOW. ITEMS TO GET TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND IT'S TAKING GENERAL.
AND I WILL ALSO MENTION IN IN
TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING THE- EXCESS- SITES
OUR THE EXCESS STATE SITES AND
THAT IS KEYNOTE CONTINUED FOCUS
OF OURS WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
THROUGH A CD AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES. TO LOOK AT
THESE LOCATIONS AND TO WORK
WITH PARTNERS TOOK ME OUT TO BE
ABLE TO. ESSENTIALLY- THE
COMFORT AND THE SITE INTO
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS I IF
I MADE MY TO JUST MAYBE BRIEFLY
AND ASK- DIRECTOR OTHER
ALASKANS TO PROVIDE A QUICK
UPDATE FOR YOU IF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. THANK YOU. I WOULD I
WOULD DISASTROUS TO RELAX
BECAUSE IF WE COULD BE CONCISE
AND OUR COMMENTS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH A TO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AND THEN MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR NEXT PANEL. THANK YOU.
IT. YEAH. ZERO SIX NINETEEN
THAT ORDER BOTH EIGHT CD AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE ACCESS TO STATE
OWNED PROPERTY AND AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUE SUSTAINABLE INNOVATIVE
ARE STACKED AT SIX HOUSING
PROJECTS WITH A BIG FOCUSED ON
THOSE AT THE LOWEST- SPECTRUM
OF INCOME AS WELL AS A HOMELESS
BUT IDENTIFIED SO FAR YOU KNOW
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF THESE
EXERCISES FIFTEEN TO TWENTY OF
THEM ARE THE SITES THAT I WOULD
CONSIDER READY I MEAN WHERE
DEVELOPMENT AB GROUPS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED- WORKING WITH
DIFFERENT RULES THE FROM
FUNDING PROGRAMS AT EIGHT C.
THE TO GET THIS- THESE. NEW
HOUSING OUR NEW NEW PROJECTS
AND GETTING A FUND THAT
INVOLVED THE GROUND SO THAT'S
THE NUMBER- THAT I HAVE FOR YOU
AS A STATEWIDE AYE KNOWING
ORANGE COUNTY WE'RE KEEPING AN
EYE ON THE DOOR AT PROJECTS
THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WITH THE SPOKEN. VIEW
IS THAT IT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
HUNDRED THAT THAT- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO- JUST
DECIDE. IN THE NEAR FUTURE SO
WERE WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT AS
WELL SO THAT'S KIND OF THE UNIT.
LARGEST GIVE YOU AN EXPECT ALL
HOW MUCH PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
ON ACCESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I FELT THREE WILL ALSO
HAVE MORE EXPERTS ON MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES IN CONNECTION
WITH HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
SOME OF THE PROJECT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND A LET ME START
BY THANKING MADAM SECRETARY
YOUR TEAM FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING HERE AND- IN
PARTICULAR AROUND DATA. SUPER
EXCITED THAT YOU FINALLY
TALKING ABOUT THIS STUFF IDABEL
ON THIS TOPIC DURING THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION. MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH A CD WE WERE
PROMISED FOR YEARS WHAT HAPPENS
I'M GLAD. IT'S HAPPENING I KNOW
THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE BUT-
WANT TO JUST MENTION THAT.
RELATED TO THIS- IF WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT HOW WE END
HOMELESSNESS AT SOME POINT NOT
JUST HOW DO WE MAINTAIN THE
CURRENT LEVELS- BUT WANT TO
BRING UP THE TOPIC. OF A GAPS
IN ITS ANALYSIS ONE THAT I
THINK YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
IDEA IS. FOR A COLLEAGUES IF
WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO END
HOMELESSNESS. WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS CURRENTLY
BEING DONE. WHAT THE LEVEL OF
THE PROBLEM IS AND WHAT IS THE
GAP BETWEEN WHAT IS BEING DONE.
AND WHAT THE NEED IS A GAPS IN
ITS ANALYSIS AND- I TO BUILD
THE SPACE LAST YEAR I WAS TOLD
BY THE NOOSA MINISTRATION THAT.
YOU WOULD BE WORKING ON A GAPS
IN ITS ANALYSIS- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU PROBABLY KNOW FEDERAL
HARD- WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THIS.
COULD YOU GIVE US A STATUS ON
THE CONVERSATION AROUND GAPS IN
NEEDS ANALYSIS. AND WHERE THAT
IS AT THIS POINT. YES IT IS. SO
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU- I
WILL ASK YOU TO ALLEY TO
PROVIDE. MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION BUT- I DO THINK
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A YOU KNOW
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT INTO
IDENTIFYING. THE AREA OF- GAPS
OR THE AREA OF NEED. ONE- STEP
IN GETTING TO THAT PLACE IS-
HAVING THE DATA AND THE
INFORMATION FROM THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE. AND AS I MENTIONED YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ALL FORTY FOUR
CONTINUES OF CARE THAT HAVE
EXECUTED- BEAST. USED
AGREEMENTS DATE ABOUT 80% OF
THAT CONTINUES OF CARE TO DATE
HAVE ALREADY PROVIDED THEIR
DATA AND IT'S GOING INTO THE
SYSTEM. AND SO HAVING THAT
LEVEL THE INFORMATION WILL BE
AT CRITICAL- BUT THERE ARE
OTHER STEPS IN THIS PROCESS AND
SO LET ME- ASK KELLY TO IT TO
JUST BE A PRIVILEGE TALK ABOUT.
SOME OF THE OTHER EFFORTS. YEAH
TO SO PART OF AD THAT HAPPENS
APPLICATION WHICH IS DUE THIS
COMING SATURDAY- IT IS
SPECIFICALLY ASKING COMMUNITIES
TO CEMENT THEIR LEVEL ACCESS
ASSONANCE. I'M SO TAKING A LOOK
AT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM- FROM
SHELTER AND OUTREACH TO
PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS TO
PREVENTION EFFORTS IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY'RE
POPULATION- WHAT WHAT KIND OF
INTERVENTIONS THAT THE HOMELESS
POPULATION MIGHT NEED. I AND
WHERE THEY ARE CURRENTLY
FUNDING AND SORT OF THE
VARIATION IN GAPS ACROSS THOSE
DIFFERENT INTERVENTIONS STRINGS
SO WE WILL BE TAKING UP A
REALLY CLOSE LOOK AT THOSE
APPLICATIONS AS THEY COME IN- I
WILL SAY WE HAVE HEARD FROM
MANY COMMUNITIES THAT. THAT
THEY NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN
DOING THAT KIND OF WORK AND SO
WE HAVE- SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CONTRACTS WE EXPECT
TO BE IMPLEMENTING HERE IN
AFFECTS MY OR TWO. HELP
COMMUNITIES GET LITTLE BIT MORE
IN DEPTH ON THEIR ON THEIR DATA
AND THEIR NEEDS- NEED
ASSESSMENTS LOCALLY SO WILL BE
WILL BE TAKING A LOOK AT WHERE
WE HAVE- GOOD QUALITY GAS
ASSESSMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
AND REALLY I'M HELPING
COMMUNITIES TO BETTER. I'M
WEIRD WHERE THEY THINK WE NEED
THAT INFORMATION THE SUPPORT.
AND I WOULD SAY MADAM DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF WE COULD MAYBE
AFTER THIS WE GET AN UPDATE
FROM YOU ON. SORT OF WHERE
THINGS STAND WITH THAT
INFORMATION. AS WE- TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT CERTAIN STEPS ON OUR
AND JOB. HOW WE WERE MEAN FOR
THE GAPS IN THE ANALYSIS. ON
DOES. AS YOU THINK ABOUT A AND
IT'S AN- WOULD ALSO CALL ALSO
AGENTS IS OUR- TO. THE STATE AS
FAR AS THAT GAPS IN ITS
ANALYSIS. THE WAY THAT WE THINK
ABOUT THIS IS LOCALLY- THERE'S
YOU KNOW THERE'S STATE FUNDING
THAT'S COMING AND LOCAL EITHER
LOCAL FUNDING THAT THEY'RE
HAVING THEIR SPIRAL FUNDING
THAT'S COMING AND IT'S NOT
REALLY A SOMETHING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL NEED TO HELP SUPPORT. AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY HAVE GAPS
WITHIN THEIR SYSTEM THAT THAT
LEVEL AND THEN RAISE THAT UP TO
THAT TO A STATE LEVEL I'M SO I
WAS DOING IT WE ONLY HAVE A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE BUT REALLY
WORKING THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR FULL RANGE OF.
FUNDING STREAMS IS SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITIES ON
THIS YEAR THE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE DOES THE STATE. FUNDING
SUPPORT WHAT PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE THAT YOUR LOCAL FUNDING
SUPPORTED YOU HAVE THAT AND
WHAT. THE PENALTIES ARE FEDERAL
FUNDING AND HAVING BREAK THAT
ALSO TO GET TOGETHER- SO I
THINK STARTING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL UNDERSTANDING AT THE
STATE LEVEL AS MANY PEOPLE THAT
A LOT. IT IS OUR CURRENT
THINKING- AS WE AS WE GET THAT
DATA IN. THE COMING WEEKS.
THANK YOU AND OUT OF RESPECT
FOR TIME- LOVE TO ENGAGE WITH
YOU MORE ON THIS- OFFLINE SO.
APPRECIATE THAT THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU SOME
MEMBER K. WELCOME AND THE ALLEY
IS LATEST HERE HAS- I YOU KNOW
A LACK OF THE LAW TERM. AS
INHIBITING MEANINGFUL ON THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS- AND- YOU
KNOW WE'RE SEEING EVEN BEFORE
POPE IN NINETEEN I CALIFORNIA
SPENDING MORE MONEY AND YET THE
PROBLEM WAS CONTINUING TO GET
WORSE WHICH WAS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WAS HAPPENING ELSEWHERE IN
THE COUNTRY IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I BELIEVE
THAT- NATIONWIDE HOMELESSNESS
WOULD HAVE DECLINED IT HADN'T
GONE UP SO MUCH IN CALIFORNIA
IS OVERWHELMED- THAT NATIONAL
FRIENDS SO- I QUESTIONS EITHER
FOR THE SECRETARY OR DEPUTY
SECRETARY IS. HI WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT'S WHY DO YOU THINK
CALIFORNIA'S HAD SUCH. A
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE THAN THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. ALL. WELL
LET LET LET ME ANSWER TO FROM
THE START BY- IN MENTIONING IT
BUT I THINK WE ON THEY'LL SORT
OF YOU KNOW BEFORE GOING INTO
THIS YOU KNOW PANDEMIC WE KNOW
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE IN THE
PORTABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
PLACE WHERE ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION OTHER ON LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WERE ALREADY
PAYING OVER 50% OF- THERE-
INCOME TOWARDS RENT AND SO
THERE'S AND YOU PRIORITIES FOR
US ARE. PRESERVING AND
EXPANDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
ADDRESSING THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS AND IT'S NOT DIRECTLY
CONNECTED OF COURSE YOU KNOW TO
THE- THE CHALLENGES ARE HAVING
AS A STATE YOU KNOW ISN'T IT
UNITED RELEASE TO HOMELESSNESS
I THINK THIS LAST YEAR WITH THE
AT THE- AND QUITE FRANKLY IN
ONGOING BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
VERY MUCH IN AN EMERGENCY AND
INDUSTRY A PANDEMIC- PROVIDERS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL HAVE BEEN
STRETCHED- TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO PROTECT INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
PROVIDE YOU KNOW SAVE-
SHELTERING TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO PROPER LEVELS-
SUPPORT- TO ALSO ADAPT AND TO.
THE CHANGING PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES- COMING BOTH FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND FROM
THE STATE AND QUITE FRANKLY I
THINK THAT THEY HAVE DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB- WITH AT THE
STATE SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN-
PROVIDING- A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE O WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES
I DO THINK THAT YOU KNOW AND-
THAT THE SUCCESS OF THE HOME
KEY PROGRAM IN THE ABILITY OF
THE LOCALS TO BE ABLE TO STAND
UP ON A PURCHASE THE SCALE-
ASSETS AND CONVERT THEM TO
PERMANENT HOUSING. ALSO IF YOU
DON'T DEMONSTRATES- THAT AB
THROUGH THAT LEVEL OF
COLLABORATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- AND- AND OF COURSE
THE FUNDING AND MADE AVAILABLE-
BUT WE YOU KNOW EVEN IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC- ARE ABLE
AND CAPABLE OF. MAKING PROGRESS
I YOU KNOW I THINK WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE- DOING WHAT WORK.
CURRENTLY WHICH IS TO DEVELOP A-
ACTION PLAN VERY SPECIFIC-
STATE OUR GOALS IN THE- THAT
CLEARLY IDENTIFIED THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS THE STATE AGENCIES IN
TERMS OF SOLVING- IN THE
DRESSING AND CO INVESTING- TO
SOLVE. HOMELESSNESS I THINK WE
NEED TO CONTINUE- DRIVING.
ALLEN AT CALEDONIA BY HAVING A
COMMON- DATA LANGUAGE- OR
COMMENT SYSTEM TO GAUGE HOW
THAT YOU KNOW SERVICES ARE
BEING- PROVIDED AND- WE ARE YOU
KNOW THERE MAY BE. GAPS I AND I
WOULD ALSO SAY YOU KNOW HAVING
US- YOU KNOW SPENT- A FEW YEARS
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WORKING AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
THAT IT'S GOING YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO HAVE- OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS- INVEST MORE FUNDING I
TO- COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSED
YOU KNOW THAT THE HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGES. THAT WE'RE HAVING
AT THE STATE. SO I AM IN NO- I
DO THINK WE- THE PHONE- THE
LEADERSHIP THE AT THAT THE
LEVEL OF COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION- THAT THAT NEEDS
TO. GET UP BUT WE WILL
DEVELOPING AT THE STRONGER AT
COORDINATION AND INTEGRATION
SYSTEM BUT I DO THINK THAT THAT
WERE HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND
YOU KNOW. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND SO I THINK THE OTHER
ONE THE SORT OF DIFFERENTIATING
FACTOR BETWEEN CALIFORNIA OTHER
STATES THAT I HEARD YOUR
RESPONSE WAS THE AFFORDABILITY
OF HOUSING WHICH IS CERTAINLY
TRUE OUR HOUSING SITUATION IS
MUCH WORSE THAN ANY OTHER
STATES HOWEVER. EVEN HOLDING
THAT CONSTANT I THINK THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE- IN THE EFFICACY OF
INTERVENTIONS WITH RESPECT
HOMELESSNESS- FOR OTHER STATES
VERSUS CALIFORNIA STILL HAS
YOUR ADMINISTRATION LOOKED AT
WHAT OTHER STATES THEY'RE DOING
A GOOD JOB OF DOING AND TRIED
TO MODEL- IT'S PRACTICES AFTER
THOSE THAT HAVE PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL ELSEWHERE CAN YOU
GIVE ME A FEW. EXAMPLES OF
WHERE YOU'VE DONE THAT. YES
DEFINITELY- WE JUST YES
YESTERDAY- DEPUTY SECRETARY-
SATIN AND I WERE ON THE CALL
WITH- HM NUMBER FOR THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE TO END
HOMELESSNESS. WHO IS ACTUALLY
WORKING ON A RESEARCH STUDY ON
HOME KEY AND OTHER- STRATEGIES.
DURING THAT CONVERSATION WE-
SPOKE EXTENSIVELY ABOUT- THE
WORK THAT IS UNDER WAY TO
STRENGTHEN THE HDFC COUNCIL TO
STRENGTHEN THE- THE GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE IN THE INTER AGENCY
COORDINATION. AND SO WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE ON MINNESOTA. IN
THE INTER AGENCY HOMELESSNESS
COUNCIL STRUCTURE THAT WAS PUT
IN PLACE. AND THAT YOU KNOW OF
COURSE WE ARE CONTINUING TO
LOOK AT STATES LIKE WASHINGTON
THE KING COUNTY. AND- IN
PARTICULAR HAS BEEN REALLY
INCREDIBLE JOB. AND THEN THE
LAST THING THAT I WILL MENTION
IS- AS A FORMER. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A HOUSING
AUTHORITY- IN SAN ANTONIO AND
THEN ALSO SPENT TEN YEARS
WORKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN
LA. FOR THE WORKING FOR THE
ONLY CITY HOUSING AUTHORITY.
THE ROLE OF HOUSING AUTHORITIES
IS ALSO REALLY AND IMPORTANT WE
HAVE SOME HOUSING AUTHORITIES
IN THE STATE THAT ARE DOING.
REALLY AN INCREDIBLE JOB YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO USE IT RENTAL
SUBSIDIES TO USING EITHER A
PUBLIC HOUSING DOLLARS. AT TO
ADDRESS- HOMELESSNESS. AND
ACROSS YOU KNOW THE COUNTRY
THEY ARE ALSO- OTHER RECOUNT
COURTS HOUSING AUTHORITIES THAT
ARE EITHER REPLICATING THE
MODELS- HEARING IN CALIFORNIA
OR- YOU KNOW CREATING. THEIR
OWN SORT OF APPROACHES- YEAH I
THINK IT LEND THEMSELVES WELL
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO- TO
REPLICATE HERE WITHIN THE STATE.
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY GOOD HEAR
I AND IS A CALL. I WANT TO ASK
WHAT YOU AS THE LEGISLATURE
ROLE- WHEN IT COMES TO
OVERSIGHT OF HOMELESSNESS-
RELATED SPENDING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN
RESISTANCE TO THOSE EFFORTS I
HAD AN AUDIT THAT WAS OPPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. I HAD A BILL
THAT WAS VETOED. BY THE
GOVERNOR AND SO- WHAT DO YOU
HOW DO YOU ENVISION THAT
RELATIONSHIP. I ENVISION THE
RELATIONSHIP AS YOU KNOW- BEING
IN A RELATIONSHIP THAT IS NOT
TRULY COLLABORATIVE JUST
TESTING OUT. YEAH I THINK I
HAVE BEEN WITH THE STATE FOR.
NINETEEN MONTHS AND MY
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN THAT- WE
HAVE HAD A VERY COLLABORATIVE
OPENED- RELATIONSHIP AT. IN
ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO. TO
SOLVE THESE COMPLEX ISSUES. I
THINK WE NEED TO OF COURSE.
WORK ACT TOGETHER TO BRING A
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE. I THINK THE
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
TODAY ARE. IT WITH REGARD TO
DATA AND- IT ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE A GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT-
AND- CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
RIGHT. AND SO. YOU KNOW THAT
THAT IS IN YOU KNOW THE- AT.
THE ROLE- I BELIEVE YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
BE ABLE TO- TO. TO ASSESS- HOW
OF DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING
APPROPRIATED- ARE BEING- SPENT
AT THE IMPACT THAT THEY'RE
HAVING- ALSO LOOKING OF COURSE-
TO ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT. WHAT IS
WORKING WHAT IS NOT WORKING-
WANTING A PROGRAMS ARE- AT
SUCCESSFUL WHAT THE PROGRAMS
ARE NOT BEING SUCCESSFUL. I
EATABLES WILL SAY SORT OF A
TENT AND GENTLY YOU KNOW SORT
OF RELATED TO ENOUGH TO IT TO
THE COP TODAY'S CONVERSATION.
WITHIN THAT HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WE'RE CURRENTLY.
WORKING ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB FOUR THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS
A BILL- THAT SIGNED INTO LAW BY
THE GOVERNOR IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THAT WILL- MOVE HCD TO
CONSOLIDATE A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS AND TO DEVELOP. A
STREAMLINED- FUNDING- APPROACH
OR YOU KNOW. SOME WILL CALL IT
A SUPER NOTICE OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY APPROACH. AND THAT
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT- IS THAT
AS AN. EXAMPLE IS- IT DIDN'T
EXAMPLE- THE LET'S- AT REALLY
LOOKING FOR- TO IN IN THAT OUR
AS YOU'LL STAY AGENCY WERE WERE
AT TO- THE BEST SERVICE
POSSIBLE TO- INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE- ON THE DISNEY IN A DAILY
BASIS OUR ORGANIZATIONS ARE
WORKING ON- YEAH. DEVELOPERS OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
THAT ARE NOT DOING THEIR BEST
TO EITHER PRESERVE OR EXPAND
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY WHEN THEY
CAN YOU KNOW COME TO THE STATE
TO APPLY FOR DOLLARS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
STREAMLINE. THE PROCESS WHILE
ALSO HAVING THE PROPER LEVEL
OF- OVERSIGHT AND THE PROPER
LEVEL OF. CHECKS AND BALANCES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
THIS HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLY
ROBUST CONVERSATION FOR OUR
FIRST PANEL I WANNA THINK OF
MISS MORALIS FROM THE ALEJO'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS SECRETARY GOT
SORT OF METIS AND MISS SUDDEN
AND MISTER VELASQUEZ FROM THE-
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL OF THE- INCREDIBLE
CONVERSATION TAKING PLACE TODAY
CLEARLY THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS. HAVE R.
ASKING AROUND TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND NEXT STEPS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION- PLEASE- FEEL FREE
TO STAY ON IF YOU WOULD LIKE-
IN CASE OR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- I'M GONNA HANDED
OVER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
WHO'S A JOINT CHAIR ON THIS-
HEARING AND ALSO LET THE
MEMBERS KNOW THAT WE ARE A
LITTLE- CONSTRUCTED ON TIME AS
THE NEXT PANEL COMING UP SOME
SOME FOLKS DO HAVE TO- JUMP OFF
AT NOON UNFORTUNATELY
UNFORTUNATELY SO LET'S BE AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE FROM
RICHARD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY AND TO THE FIRST
PANEL. SO ARE. AS MY FELLOW
CHAIRED ALLUDED TO- THE SECOND
PANEL WE WANTED. TO MAKE SURE
WE HEARD THE LOCAL PERSPECTIVE
FROM EXPERTS RUN STUDENTS
TOPICS THAT WE HAVE THREE.
GREAT PANELISTS AND I WANT TO
INVITE THEM. TO MAKE A FIVE
MINUTE PRESENTATIONS. FROM THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES AT THREE IT'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HEIDI
MARSTON. FROM THE OFFICE OF.
ERLITOU SHAFT FROM OAKLAND- FOR
HER HOMES POLICY DIRECTOR PETER
REDUCE AND REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF
TURNING POINT OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA JUDY. TO DECIDE ONE
I SUGGEST THAT WE PROCEED IN
THE ORDER IN WHICH IT- THE
NAMES ARE LISTED IN THE AGENDA
FOR COULD FIRST HEAR FROM MS
MARSTON. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME AB EVERYONE
CAN HEAR ME OUT OKAY- GOOD
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH
YOU TO TEAR CAREER FOR THE ODD
I'VE GOT A PRETTY GOOD FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS HEIDI MARSTON I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY. WE LEAVE AT AND T.
FOR LA CONTINUE ON THE AIR AT
AND THEN WE ALSO BEAT ALL THREE
HOUSING EFFORTS FOR THE COUNTY
OF LOS. I YOU KNOW THE WHOLE OF
THIS CRISIS- EXISTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT WITH
YOUR BEFORE COPING. OUT THERE
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND- OVER SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND OF THOSE WERE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE. AND
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WILL BE IT IS
VERY LIKELY TO MAKE THAT CRISIS
WORSE. AND THE THOUSANDS OF
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE HAD THEIR LIVES
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN BY FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTY YEAR OLD MEXICAN
GAS. AND IT REALITY IT'S
COUPLED WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVING FEWER RESOURCES TO
RESPOND TO THE CRISIS. IN LA
WHERE WE RELY PRETTY
EXTENSIVELY ON MEASURE RATES OF
TAX REVENUE. DAN ARE HOMELESS.
AND I IN THAT SORT THE LONGER.
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. BUT
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES AND
THROUGH COLLABORATION WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT PARTNERS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO LEVERAGE
OTHER LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO RESPOND OKAY IT
LASTED SIX MONTHS WE'VE BROUGHT
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND OF OUR
VULNERABLE NEIGHBORS INSIDE
YOUR PROJECT ROOM HE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH EIGHT AND
OTHER JOINT EFFORTS ACROSS THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY. WE KNOW
HOWEVER THAT THE WORK DOESN'T
STOP WITH BRINGING PEOPLE
INSIDE IT WHETHER IT'S A HOTEL
OR SHELTER OUR FOCUS IS NOW
REALLY KIDDING. PERMANENTLY
HOUSE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
BROUGHT IN BROUGHT IN FIVE
TEMPORARILY INTO THE SHELTER.
OUT WHAT WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN IS
THAT WE CANNOT GO BACK TO THE
STATUS QUO WE'VE MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS AND WE'VE
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO BUILD
MOMENTUM PARTICULARLY IN LA
REVIEW GOT BIRTH. SO WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE THOSE PEOPLE GOING
BACK TO THE STREETS- OUT SO
THAT HIS. HEART OKAY. I IN LA
HOW ARE CONTINUE ON HIS BILL.
ACTIVE THREE HOW WHICH- OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS ALL. WE
HAVE SIXTY ONE. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT PEOPLE. WHICH IS NEARLY
THE SAME NUMBER OF OUR TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. LAST YEAR ALONE
WE HOUSE TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE DAY AND TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE FELL
IN THE WHOLE WORLD BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE DAY SO WE CONTINUE
TO SPEED UP THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE CALLING IN IS OUTPACING
OUR- ATHLETES MOVE PEOPLE OUT
QUICKLY. THIRTY TRULY ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IF WERE TALKING
ABOUT IN THE FIRST PANEL WE
REALLY NEED IT EQUALLY POWERFUL
HOMELESS PREVENTION MACHINE
THAT STOPS PEOPLE FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS. AS WELL AS
REALLY MASSIVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUPPLY GENES THAT
CREATE YOU YES- AND IN A
PORTABLE UNIT. THAT PEOPLE HAVE
A PLACE TO GO. FIRST THIS BY
HAS TO SIX. STEPS WERE HELPING
A BUILD BACK DOWN AND- WE WANT
TO WORKING ON THAT AND BUILDING
ON THOSE SUCCESSES. THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION EARLIER ABOUT THE
HEAT FUNDING AT THE BEGINNING
OF TWENTY NINETEEN- AS OF
SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR. IN LA
HE HAS SERVED OVER SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED UNIQUE PEOPLE ACROSS A
LAKE COUNTY. WE USED OUR KEEP
DOLLARS. PROBLEMS ALL WE CAN
FIND AT AND THAT ONE REALLY
PROVIDES FLEXIBLE DOLLARS
INFUSION OF CASH TO PEOPLE WHO
NEED. TO QUICKLY RESOLVE
PROBLEMS THAT COULD LEAD TO OR
PROLONG THEIR WHOLE OKAY SO IF
ANYTHING FROM PAYING THEIR
BACKGROUND. TO SECURITY DEPOSIT
YOUR CAR REPAIR- IT'S INTENDED
TO BE A FLEXIBLE POSSIBILITIES
BEING GREAT OUTCOMES FROM THAT.
WE ALSO USED. NAMES AND REALLY
CORE PARTS OF OUR SYSTEM
INCLUDING PROVIDING THAT THEY
NEEDED SHELTER BAD. BUILDING
PLACEMENT OF OUR FAMILIES INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND HOUSING
BUT OCCASION OTHER CRITICAL
COMPONENTS TO HELP PEOPLE MOVE
YOUR ARSS. DOWN INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING. OUR HALF FUNDING WE
RECEIVED IN THE OF TWENTY HAS
ALSO ALREADY SERVED UP TO THE
FEET ALL WITH VERY SIMILAR. TO
ASKING WHO HOUSING. BEING OVER
QUIRKY. AFTER WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO ADDRESS POINT IS A THE
STATE WILL ON GOING FOR FROM
THE STATE LAW. AT BELIEVED ON
SYSTEM WEEK- HOW TO PREDICT THE
BILL IN THE BY DAY AND WE HAVE
TO COME BACK EVERY YEAR. YOU
HAVE BUT BASHING AS- THAT THE-
ONLY REALLY ON CHURCH. YEAH OF
THE PROGRAM YOUR- I EVERY TIME
START UP A PROGRAM. YOU KNOW
QUITE TIME FUNDING FROM THE AN
END THE TO WRITE DOWN AND
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF INFLUX OF
THIS PROJECT BECAUSE. HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT IT WAS VERY. IS A
CRISIS THAT RELATIVE THE OF
UNDER- SO THOSE. THOSE OKAY
HERE IN LA CAN WE'RE SURE FIVE
HUNDRED AND I THOUSAND UNITS OF
A FOR A HOUSING- AND NOT JUST
BE A HOUSING EAST COAST BEING
NAY IT COMES TO ON IF REALLY
AND IN CREATING ABLE SYSTEM
THAT CAN QUICKLY READ ALL. WE
ARE ARE REALLY WANTING TO
CONTINUE ON OF CARE TO THE T.
MORE ROAD. INTENTIONAL YOU TOO
REGIONAL DISCUSSION. IF YOU'D
LIKE LOS THAT ARE RALLY GREAT
AND SURE WE ADDRESS LOOKING-
REGIONAL. IT ACTUALLY IN MY WHY
LA WHERE WE HAVE A WHOLE OF
OVERLAP DURING. BECAUSE OF BOTH
SIZE AND COMPLEX. PEOPLE WORK
ALL MASS SHOULD BE SERVED ON
PRODUCT STREET THERE ON THE
FIELD YOU CAN FOR WITH NEEDS TO
LEVERAGE HEALTH AND- OUT
RESOURCE THE METAL. AND ALSO
PUT THAT WITH CITY READ THAT
REGULATE LAND USE AND BRING ALL
THE- TOGETHER AND WILL PUT THE
APPROACH. INDIVIDUALLY FOR FUN
TO BUILD OUT AND- LAW TERM OF
SIX OF ABJECT HOME HE IS REALLY.
TO ADDRESSING. PROJECT HOMES IN
PERSON A VERY. FACTOR AND WE
MAKE THE GOVERNOR OFF FIRST.
THAT EFFORT HOWEVER WE DO NEED.
ONGOING TO FIX YOUR HOME. AB
SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS THE KNOW
IT ALL UP BY SIMPLY READ BLOOM
AT SHARED YOU CAN ALSO REALLY
HELP AT THE DRIVE THE ISSUE IS.
EIGHTY SEVEN ONE PROVIDE
FUNDING HELP LFE. THAT WE DON'T
WORK LIKE PRIVATE TOLD HE AND
ALSO FOR NEED FUNDING OPERATE
THE SITE AND SOLUTIONS RENTAL.
AT AT THAT PREVENTION THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT I'M SURE BOTH
HOUSES WHICH IS REALLY THE WAY.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO THE
RIGHT THAT. THE LAST TWO YEARS
ARE WE- THE- HAD HOW ABOUT.
THOUSAND PEOPLE THROUGH RAPID
REHOUSING AWHILE. WE REALLY
WANT TO BUILDING ON THAT THAT.
WE AS YOU BEEN DISCUSSING AND I
GOT A- AB SEVENTY BUT YOU
STAYED TO ESTABLISH MY GOAL AND
READ FOR DRESSED AND THAT ARE
WORDED FUNDING OUT HOW BELIEVE
HE IS. IMPORTANT TO MAKE THAT
YOUR OR MEETING ALL THE WE WANT
TO BE THAT I'M GOING BE ABLE.
AND WE KNOW IT'S JUST BY TO
MAKE SURE THE FUNDING IS BEING
IN A WAY THAT HOLD PEOPLE. AND
IS IN FACT ENTERED THAT WORK IN
IT IN AFTER ENDING THAT. AB
SEVENTY ONE WOULD INCREASE OUR
CLOCK. BETWEEN YOUR EITHER
EITHER WAY THAT. PROPOSAL NOT.
AND WE'VE ABLE TO. IN ALEC.
COLLABORATE IF CRITICAL TO OUR
BACK. IF WE WANT TO REDO PUBLIC
WE NEED TO ENSURE CITY. YOUR
ARE WORKING. I A REACH APPROACH
TO ENDING RIGHT THAT. THAT
REALLY RAN UP MY AS I STILL.
ALL OF YOUR AND LISTENING TO
TODAY I'M COME THAT WE CAN
STRETCH. OUR PARTNERS BETWEEN
EIGHT AND A LOCAL CHURCH. IN
THE CRIED. I'M REALLY HAPPY HAD
ON MY LOOK TO YOUR- AND
PARTNERING WITH THE FURTHER.
THANK YOU MISS MARCIN R. ONE
WHICH IT OVER NOW TO MISTER
READY FROM CITY OF OAKLAND. IS
MR DO AVAILABLE. I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WAITING FOR
MR RIGHT DO I DO UNDERSTAND
THEM AS MARCIN HAS TO LEAVE BY
NOON SO IF ANYONE HAS A
PARTICULAR QUESTION FOR HER
HAPPY TO. ENTERTAIN THEM AT THE
MOMENT. OKAY TO MY VOICE. HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M SORRY FOR
THE DELAY R. ONE WE I JUST.
WANT TO PASS MY PRESSURE IF YOU
DON'T DO WHAT OKAY. AND AND I
ALSO UNDERSTAND IS READY TO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE
CHILDCARE. ISSUES AND IT'S
GREAT TO SEE THE CUTEST MEMBER
OF. TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME I. WANT
TO APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE AND
JUGGLING OUR SIX MONTH OLD
CHARLIE AND SELL- TEAMMATE
CHIMED IN WITH UNWELCOME- AND
INVITED PUBLIC COMMENTS AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT IN ADVANCE-
SO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
MENTIONED THE- DISCUSSION RIGHT
NOW ABOUT SCOPING FROM A
FUNDING PERSPECTIVE. THE
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM STATEWIDE-
WITH AN ANALYSIS OF GAPS IN
NEEDS. WE'VE DONE THAT WORK IN
OAKLAND- HAND- WE HAVE ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND OF THE STATE'S ON
ANY GIVEN NIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
SO I JUST WANT TO FRAME IT IN
TERMS OF THIS GAPS NEEDS
ANALYSIS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
DONE TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS ISSUE FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF OAKLAND. SO
OUR ANALYSIS HAS FOUND THAT THE
ANNUAL COST BE WEAK AT NEED TO
ACHIEVE FUNCTIONAL ZERO IN
OTHER WORDS BEING ABLE TO
QUICKLY RESOLVE HOMELESSNESS.
FOR ANYONE WHO EXPERIENCES A
HOUSING CRISIS WITH A GOAL OF
YOU KNOW NINETY DAY FEWER IS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
CAPITAL EXPENSES. I'M
INTERESTED TIME ALL REFRAIN
FROM GOING INTO DETAIL I'M I'M
HAPPY TO FIELD ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT- EXACTLY THE
TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS THAT
THAT WOULD FIND IN WHAT THEY
WOULD DO WE HAVE THAT DETAIL
AVAILABLE BUT SUFFICE IS TO SAY
THAT THAT HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
MILLION. TOWARDS THE EXPANSION
OF MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW ALREADY WORK IN OAKLAND IN
THAT WE'RE ALREADY PUTTING IN
PLACE. I'M THINGS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE TO SCALE UP. OKAY HAS.
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT OKAY
IS ALSO A LEADER ROLE IN INTO
MERE SHE WAS COACH OF THIS- TO
DO YOU. AS SYSTEMS MY- GAPS IN
NEED TO NOW OF THE WEB IN
ALBANY COUNTY I AM A I DON'T
KNOW FOUND THERE AT THREE TWO
OF DINNER. THAT WE DESPERATELY
NEED BUT WOULD HAVE NO OKAY OR
FUNDING FOR IN ADDITION TO SOME
OF THE TRADITIONAL
INTERVENTIONS THAT WERE ALREADY
PROVIDING THE NEED TO SCALE UP
WITH RAPID RE HOUSING.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING-
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE. THE NEED
FOR ESSENTIALLY ON GOING
FUNDING TO SUBSIDIZE RENT FOR
PEOPLE IN THREE DIFFERENT
AREAS- ONE IS FOR A POPULATION
OF FOLKS WHO DON'T NEED A VERY
DEEP LEVEL OF ASSISTANCE.
THEY'RE JUST A LITTLE BIT TOO
POOR FOR A RENTAL MARKET AND SO
THEY COULD BENEFIT FROM SHALLOW
SUBSIDY. IS PROVIDE A SMALLER
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT TO HOUSEHOLDS
THAN TRADITIONAL DEEP
SUBSIDIES. LIKE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING I ARE IN OUR
SYSTEM THAT WE NEED ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY OF THOSE
ANNUALLY- WE ALSO NEED A MORE
INTENSIVE INTERVENTION FOR SOME
OF OUR SENIORS OAKLAND HAS.
BEEN EVEN HOMELESS POPULATION
AND SO WE FOUND THAT WE NEED
SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN UNITS
ANNUALLY OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR SENIORS.
THIS WOULD BE A NEW AND MORE
INTENSIVE INTERVENTION. THAN
TRADITIONAL PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BUT NOT
QUITE AS INTENSIFIED SAY A
BOARDING KERR. HI AND THIS AND
MOST IMPORTANT KEYS IS THAT WE
NEED WE HAVE A GREAT MADE
ALMOST TWO THOUSAND UNITS IN
FACT. A DEEPLY AFFORDABLE UNITS
WITH NO NEED FOR SUPPORT
SERVICES. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE EXPERT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND OAKLAND. ARE NOT DISABLED I
DO NOT HAVE- AT DISABILITIES
THAT THAT REQUIRED THEM TO
RECEIVE SUPPORT SERVICES.
THEY'RE JUST TOO POOR FOR THE
RENT AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE A
DEEPLY AFFORDABLE. HOUSING
STOCK IN ORDER TO KEEP THEM
HOUSE. AND SELL AT THE COST OF
THESE THREE INTERVENTIONS.
TOGETHER ALONG WITH THE SEVENTY
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THAT'S AN ANALYSIS OF WHAT
WE NEED IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
HAVE. OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS
WE HAVE RECEIVED. FORTY THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE RESOURCES. WE ARE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. I
INSULARIS COULD KICKSTART AND
NUMBER OF OUR INTERVENTIONS-
AND HAVE. SHE WHAT IS KICK
STARTING NUMBER. HE'S EXCITED
ABOUT HER IN TO- THE RESOURCES
FROM THIS HAVING US OPEN TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO DADS OUR
COMMUNITY CABINS PROGRAMS I
SAFE PARKING SITES FOR A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE ARE
THESE- I'M MERGING SEA ONE
HUNDRED EMERGENCY SHELTER BEDS.
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BEDS AND
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
COLAVITA ISOLATION BEDS AT THE
STATE ARE PROVIDED FEMA
TRAILERS- AND SO THAT'S DIED
SPACES FOR ALL TOGETHER SIX
HUNDRED NINE SIX HUNDRED NINE
BEDS IN PARKING SPACES- ANARCHY
FUNDED PROGRAMMING HAS SERVED
OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE TO
DATE AND IT IS BEEN RESPONSIBLE
FOR PERMANENTLY HOUSING OVER A
HUNDRED PEOPLE. TO DATE- WE'VE
ALSO JUST RECEIVED OVER TWENTY
SOME TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN HOME HE FUNDING
WHICH IS LEVERAGE LOCAL
RESOURCES TO CREATE TWENTY ONE
NEW UNITS OF FAMILY SHELTER AND
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR UNITS
OF PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR SENIORS VETERANS
AND OTHER OAKLAND OR SEARCH
DANCING HOMELESSNESS- THE CITY
WILL ACTUALLY OPEN ONLY BE
OVERSEEING THE OPERATIONS AND
SERVICES AT ONE OF OUR HOMES
YOU PROJECTS THE QUESTION HALL.
WHICH WILL SUPPORT TWENTY ONE
FAMILY SHELTER UNITS AND FORTY
TWO PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE
UNITS- FOR SENIORS TO ACQUIRING
RE HAVE THE BUILDING WE OF
COURSE USE THANK YOU DOLLARS
AND WE LEVERAGE LOCAL BOND
DOLLARS AND HOUSING TRUST FUND
DOLLARS- BUT HE FOR THE SUBSIDY
IN THE SERVICES MOVING FORWARD.
WE WHAT WE PUT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN CAP TO A CAPITALIZE
OPERATING RESERVES- FOR THE
PERMANENT HOUSING IN THIS FUNDS
THE PERMANENT HOUSING
OPERATIONS. FOR THIRTEEN YEARS.
IN THE EVERYTHING YOU.
INSURANCE TO THE- ARMED
SERVICES COSTS AND SO- THAT IS
THE WAY TO STRAY ONE TIME DAHLE.
OUT TO HAVE THEM GO FURTHER-
AND HAVE THEM. K. I. TO
MULTIPLE YEARS AND WE ARE
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO CONTINUE TO
DO MORE OF THAT HERE IN
OAKLAND- SO MOVING FORWARD IF
WE WOULD OF COURSE NEED TO
IDENTIFY AND SECURE ANOTHER
SOURCE OF OPERATING. SUPPORT
AFTER THIRTEEN YEARS ONCE AT
AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS- AND
SUBSIDY ON THE RENTER'S EXPIRES
AND WE ALSO NEED TO MORE
RESEARCH RESOURCES TO FIND.
OPERATING RESERVES AT FUTURE
HOME KEY PROJECTS- ALL OF OUR
HAPPEN AND ONE BROWN'S WANTING
TO HAVE BEEN ACCOUNTED FOR- AND
SO ON THAT'S THE SORT OF A- A
AND NOW THIS IS WHAT WE NEED IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE RECEIVED FROM
THE STATE- THREE FUNDAMENTAL
ISSUES ABOUT O'QUINN'S HOMELESS
BUDGET SITUATION THAT I WANT TO
BRING TO THE- TO. YOUR
ATTENTION. AND I HOPE THE
ASSEMBLY WHAT WILL KEEP IN MIND
FROM A LOCAL PERSPECTIVE AS YOU
BEGIN YOUR BUDGET DELIBERATIONS
FOR THIS YEAR- FIRST OBVIOUSLY
IS THE GAP BETWEEN WHAT WE HAVE
AND WHAT OUR DATA DATA ANALYSES
HAVE SHOWN IS THAT WE NEED-
OAKLAND'S HOMELESS BUDGET FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
IS JUST UNDER SIXTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS BUT IMPORTANTLY ROUGHLY
TWO THIRDS OF THAT IS ONE TIME.
INCLUDING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS IN JUST
UNDER TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL COLLUDED
FINDS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED- WE
ACTUALLY ONLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND RELIABLE ON GOING
REVENUE. AND THESE COME FROM
FEDERAL AND LOCAL GENERAL FUND
SOURCES I AND SO THAT'S JUST A
LITTLE OVER ONE FIFTH OF WHAT
ARE NOW SO GAPS IN NEEDS
ANALYSIS HAVE SHOWN IS THAT WE
NEED. IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
FUNCTIONAL ZEROING IN OAKLAND-
SECOND IS THE FACT THAT THAT
GAP IN TERMS OF THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WE HAVE
ALL WE NEED IS THAT IS ABOUT TO
GROW WIDER. AS ONE TIME STATE
AND FEDERAL RESOURCES EXPIRING
GET EXPANDED. BY THE MIDDLE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE HAVE
FORTY POINTS MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME. THAT WILL BE EXPAND.
THESE FUNDS THE- TO HUNDRED AND
TWO P. CASH. THAT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT AT THE NEW KOBE ISOLATE
BEDS THE PHOENIX. ONE HUNDRED
GB TRADITIONAL BEDS SAFE
PARKING FOR A HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE R. VIEWS. AS WELL AS
PERMANENT HOUSING EXISTS FOR UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
HOUSEHOLDS ALMOST PREVENTION
RESOURCES FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS. AND
PORTAPOTTIES AT FORTY OF OUR
ENCAMPMENTS IN MOBILE SHOWERS
AND LAUNDRY AND UP TO EIGHTEEN
ENCAMPMENTS PER WEEK. UNLESS
THOSE RESOURCES ARE REPLACED OR
BACK FIELD MOVING FORWARD WE
RISK LOSING OUT. I AM THIRD AND
FINALLY IS THE MISMATCH BETWEEN
THE NATURE OF THE ONE TIME
RESOURCES. AND THE BIGGEST NEED
IN OUR SYSTEM WHICH AE LOCAL
ANALYSIS IS I'VE AS I'VE TOLD
YOU. HAVE DEMONSTRATED IS
PERMANENT WE SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING. ONE TIME DOLLARS
CANNOT BE USED TO PERMANENT WE
SUBSIDIZE HOUSING WHICH WILL GO
WHICH REQUIRES AN ANNUAL
OUTLAY. I SEE THIS IS WHY MAYOR
SCHAAF'S SUPPORTS AB SEVENTY
ONE. WHICH WOULD CREATE THE
FIRST PUMP PERMANENT FUNDING
SOURCE OF ITS KIND FOR
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA I
WOULD BE OF A CRITICAL PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE FOR US LOCALLY- SO
WITH THAT I'M PROBABLY OVER
TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE- I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. WITH
WITH CHARLIE HERE I DO HOPE
THIS IS BEEN HELPFUL AND. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE PRESENT. AND TO YOUR SISTER
CHARLIE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WELL. AS A SUPER
PARENTS APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
STRUGGLING WITH RIGHT NOW. AND
IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE OUR
BEST MEMBERSHIP HAS BEEN A TRUE
CHAMPION- ON THESE ISSUES AND-
APPRECIATE- APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. WITH THAT WHEN WE
GO TO OUR FINAL SPEAKER THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF TURNING
POINT OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
MISTER JUDY CATCH ASIDE. SHARES
MY NAME IS JODY CATCHES SIGHT
ON THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF
TURNING POINT OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO SERVE AS THE
VICE CHAIR ON THE FRONT MADERA
CONTINUUM OF CARE. I'M OPERATE
PROGRAMS IN THE KINGS TULARE.
HOMELESS ALLIANCE OR CONTINUUM
OF CARE. JURISDICTION I'M SERVE
ON THE HOME OF COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL AND I AM THAT
BOARD CHAIR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. I'VE BEEN
WORKING IN THIS FIELD ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS I STARTED
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOME. AND
TODAY I WORK SERVING ALL
POPULATION EXPERIENCING A MUST
MISS. THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA THAT I
WILL TRY TO GET THROUGH TODAY
AND SPEAKING PRIMARILY FROM THE
VIEWPOINT OF MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU. TULARE
COUNTY WINDSTAR CASH FUNDS TO
CREATE TWO FIFTY TWO STRATEGIC
PLANS ONE FOR EACH COUNTY AND
THE GOALS OUTLINED IN THE HOME
LAST PLANS COUPLED WITH CUTS
PERFORMANCE MEASURES ARE WHAT
GUIDES AND DRIVERS ARE METRICS
TECH COMBAT HOMELESSNESS IN THE
AREA OUR REGION DOES HAVE THE
FOURTH HIGHEST UNSHELTERED RATE
IN THE COUNTRY WITH THE OTHER
LARGELY URBAN C. O. C. S.
CATEGORY WITHIN THAT CATEGORY.
WE HAVE YES THEY KEEP IN CASH
AS WELL AS CITY GENERAL FUNDS
TO CREATE A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS-
pOF PORTERVILLE WE THERE WERE
PREVIOUSLY NO SERVICES FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS ASIDE FROM
A PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROJECT PROJECT OPERATED BY
TURNING POINT OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA I AND WE USE THOSE
FUNDS TO ESTABLISH A NAVIGATION
CENTER WHERE ALL RIGHT AS OF
YESTERDAY WE HAD SERVED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND NINETY UNDUPLICATED
INDIVIDUALS WITH DAYTIME
SERVICES LIKE MEALS AND CASE
MANAGEMENT. FILTERED THIRTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS- AND SEE AN AVERAGE
OF ABOUT EIGHTY PEOPLE COME
THROUGH THE DOORS DALY FOR
PERSPECTIVE PORTABLES TWENTY
TWENTY A POINT IN TIME NUMBERS
WERE JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED
UNSHELTERED PEOPLE SO WE CAN
SEE THE PIC COUNTS NOT A
PERFECT MEASURE OF HOMELESSNESS
AND THEY DO POSE SOME
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY FOR
COUNTING YOU. THEY DO PROVIDE A
WAY FIRST YEAR STUDENTS TO
MEASURE PROGRESS TOWARDS
ADDRESSING SHELTERED AND
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF FUNNY
ROBERT LOW BARRIER NAVIGATION
CENTERS THE ONLY FUNDING SOURCE
AVAILABLE OUTSIDE OF HEAP AND
HAPPEL CURRENTLY IT IS.
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS GRANT FUNDS.
THIS COMMUNITY S. NOT A ENTIRE
REACH WERE IN. FUNDS ARE
AUTOMATICALLY. IT WE TO CAN BE
FOR THESE AND- IN TWENTY. NINE
OR AWARDED TO THE- SO THE S.
THAT LEEDS. REGIONS RIGHT I IN
FLYERS COUNTY IS. AFTER AND
STOP PROGRAM EACH YEAR AND-
ALSO YOUR RV HAS IMPACT ON
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AS
FOLKS DON'T OFTEN TIME EVEN GET
A FULL YEAR OF ASSISTANCE. THE
GREAT THING ABOUT THESE ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS WAS THAT THEY
GAVE US THE FLEXIBILITY TO FIND
WHAT'S NEEDED IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND OUR SYSTEM OF SYSTEM
SUPPORT WE CAN'T DO THE WORK
WITHOUT THE SYSTEM SUPPORT
FIRSTLY THE- LEAST SUCCESSFUL
ASPECT OF THESE FUNDS IS THAT
THEY ARE ONE TIME WHICH WE'VE%
HEARD FROM OTHER PANELISTS IT'S
HARD TO FIND FUNDS TO SUSTAIN.
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS CREATED
THROUGH THE USE INVESTMENTS I'M
GOING I'M GOING RESOURCES ARE
REALLY WHAT IS NEEDED YOU CAN'T
CONTINUE THE WORK OR IN OUR
MAINTAIN THE STAFFING AND THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES- AND LYFT.
SOME OF THE THINGS I'M GOING. I
KNOW EXAMPLE WHERE FOR THE BILL
IS CRITICAL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE VARIOUS
KINDS OF INTERVENTIONS. NEEDED
FOR YOU THERE'S NO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL SOLUTION- OR WHAT
YOUNG PEOPLE FACE- THEY NEED
SHELTER TIME I WHETHER IT'S
TIME LIMITED SUPPORTED. RAPID
RE HOUSING OPTIONS COUPLED WITH
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS FOR
APPOINTMENT EDUCATION IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. ALL OF THESE
ARE PATHWAYS OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS FOR YOUTH
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE
CRUCIAL AND ASSISTING THEM.
WITH REACHING THE GOALS THAT
THEY HAVE TO AND THEY'RE
HOMELESSNESS. ANOTHER STRATEGIC
REQUIREMENT OF THE STATE
FUNDING WAS SUPPORTING
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEMS. THIS
IS BAN A SUCCESS AND NEEDED IT
WOULD. IT'LL HELP TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD ON THEIR SUCCESS BY
ENSURING THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
HAVE A YOUTH CENTER COORDINATED
ENTRY SYSTEM OR YOUTH CENTER
TOOL CURRENTLY MANY COMMUNITIES
ARE USING THE V. I SPENT THAT.
I'M STILL ASSESSING NEED ABOUT
IT IS THE ADULT VERSION ARE NOT
THE YOUTH ARE SENT OR ANY
SPECIFIC TO ALL. HISTORICALLY
PREVENTION HAS BEEN DRASTICALLY
UNDERFUNDED INSTANCE WHERE
COUNTIES HAVE ESTABLISHED A
LANDLORD MITIGATION FUND. AND
DIVERSION FUNDS HOWEVER WILL
ALLOCATIONS TEND TO BE MUCH
SMALLER. THAN A LARGER URBAN
AREAS WHICH LEAVES LITTLE ON
THE TABLE TO YOUR SALAS.
PREVENTION ONE ARE LOOKING AT
FUNDING YOU KNOW SOME OF THEM.
THE MORE EMERGENCY
INTERVENTIONS. THE LEGISLATURE
VISION ABOUT AND HAVE BEEN. SET
ASIDES THAT REQUIRED
COMMUNITIES MAKE SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS AND SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS. YOUTH HOMELESSNESS A
STORE NECESSARY- YOU SETASIDES
ARE ARE A HUGE STEP TOWARDS
CHANGING THE STATE'S LONG
HISTORY OF UNDER INVESTMENT IN
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHERE ROUGHLY
FOURTEEN THOUSAND UNACCOMPANIED
YOUTH ARE HOMELESS ON ANY GIVEN
NIGHT. I THE KINGS TO LARRY C.
O. C. RECENTLY PARTICIPATED IN
COHORT SIX HUNDRED A CHALLENGE
TO ADDRESS YEARS YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. THE CHALLENGE
TOOK PLACE FROM JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY. AND DURING THIS TIME WE
HAVE MOST FORTIETH AND LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARD THAT WILL LAUNCH IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE'VE USED
ARE YOU FUNDING SET ASIDE. TO
SET ASIDE BEDS AT NAVIGATION
CENTERS BRIDGE HOUSING AND SOME
PERMANENT. SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROJECTS. ONCE WE HAVE BAD WITH
THE TO THE TO POPULAR I'M
LOOKING TO. AFTER THE YOUTH
ASIDE FUNDS SPENT. DUE TO THE
SMALL ALLOCATION OF. THE YOUTH
SET ASIDE. THERE YOU KNOW IT'S
AN IN A SMALL COMMUNITY LIKE
PORTER BELLE. I JUST FOR SOME
PERSPECTIVE THAT 8% IS REALLY
ONLY ABOUT TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF THE ALLOCATION SO
OPENING A NEW PROGRAM SPECIFIC
TO YOUR- JUST ISN'T REALISTIC
WITH THAT SORT OF ALLOCATION.
BECAUSE COMPETING PRIORITIES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL CAN BE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS. ONE OF THE KEY
ROLES THAT THAT THE STATE CAN
PLAY AS BY CONTINUING SET
ASIDES. THAT REQUIRED OR
RESTRICTIONS TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS THAT OUR- MENTOR AT
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE GAPS IN
THEIR LOCAL SYSTEMS. THAT
PROTECT UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
LIKE YOUTH. BECAUSE THEY ARE
SOMETIMES INVISIBLE COMPARED TO
OTHER POPULATIONS. AND IT KEEPS
THEM FROM BEING OVERLOOKED
ENTIRELY. WHEN IT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
INVEST IN SOLUTION FOR YOU THEY
BUILD STRONGER SYSTEMS OF CARE.
UNFORTUNATELY FROM TALKING TO
SOME OF MY PEERS IN THE FIELD
I'VE HEARD THAT THE YOUTH SET
ASIDE. WAS AND STILL IS BEING
VIEWED AS A FUNDING CEILING
RATHER THAN A FUNDING FLOOR- I
THINK WITHIN NOT- IN IN
PROBABLY MOST CONSISTENTLY IN
THE RURAL AREAS- COMMUNITIES
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE LESS THAN
A HUNDRED THOUSAND SPREAD OUT
OVER THREE. TO FIVE EIGHT YEARS
DEPENDING ON. HOW EFFICIENT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE. OF
GETTING THOSE RESOURCES OUT.
AND THAT GEOGRAPHIC AREAS ARE
SO VAST IT MAKES IT CHALLENGING
TO CREATE TAILORED SOLUTIONS
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU. HARDS UP
A PER THAT MEETS THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
NEEDS OF YOUTH WITHOUT LITTLE
FUNDING. ON HOME. FOR THE RURAL
COUNTRYSIDE ACADEMIC. WRAP IT
UP IN ABOUT A MINUTE IF YOU CAN.
YES OF COURSE I KNOW HOME HERE-
THE ALLOCATION WAS ONLY ENOUGH
TO ACQUIRE. BEING THERE AND
PROPERTIES AND NOT ENOUGH. IT'S
LIKELY THAT WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
FINISH THE CONVERSIONS ON
EITHER OF THE PROPERTY TAX. I'M
AND THE LAST THING I WANT TO
LEAVE YOU WITH IS THAT IN
FRESNO COUNTY THEIR THOUSAND
OBJECTIONS PENDING AT THE
COURTHOUSE. IF THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM DOESN'T GET
EXTENDED. WE'RE GOING TO FIND A
THAT ALL RELATIONS OF PEOPLE
ARE AFFECTED BY THOSE
ADMISSIONS INCLUDING. YOU SO IT
WOULD DEFINITELY THE STATE
SHOULD EXTEND ANY LENGTH OF
STAY REQUIREMENTS FOR FOLKS.
EXITING PROGRAMS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. GREAT THANK FOR YOUR
TIME. AS I MENTIONED BEFORE I
KNOW MS MARC HAS TO BY NOON SO
THERE ARE ANY. TO OUR FOR BIG
GRINS PANEL WANT TO ENTERTAIN
THAT AT THIS MOMENT. IF NOT.
MISS KOREA CENTER. THANK YOU UP
ACTUALLY IT'S- IT COULD BE A
QUESTION FOR ALL THREE
PANELISTS BUT MY OWN PERSONAL
INTERESTS OF COURSES- THE CITY
THAT I REPRESENT THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY LOS ANGELES
BUT I THINK THIS QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY IS RELATED TO OUR
OUR CURRENT EXPERIENCE IN
COVERT NINETEEN AND I'M JUST
WONDERING IF- GIVEN THE ROLE OF
VARIOUS TENANT PROTECTION
POLICIES SUCH AS ADDICTION
PROTECTIONS RUNS DEBILITATION
AND VARIOUS ANTI DISPLACEMENT
STRATEGIES. OTHER THE STATE- IS
MOVING FORWARD WITH IN THE
PREVENTION OF HOMELESSNESS WHAT
WORK DO WE NEED TO DO FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE TO STRAIGHTEN THIS
THESE KINDS OF POLICIES DO THEY
WORK TODAY NOT WORK AND WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE CONVERSATION ON THE
GROUND AND I APPRECIATE THAT
ARE YOU HAVE ALL TOUCHED UPON
IT ON VARIOUS DIFFERENT POINTS
IN YOUR PRESENTATIONS BUT I
THINK THAT WE ARE WE ARE FACING
A DIRE SITUATION AND NIGHT I
REALLY LIKE TO KNOW FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE- WHAT IS IT THAT WE
CAN DO TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I.
JANIE ROWNTREE IS ON THE NEXT
PANEL AND SHE WILL BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO THIS EVEN MORE THAT I
CAN'T BUT WHAT I CAN SAY FROM
THE GROUND. IS IN TERMS OF
STRENGTHENING THERE'S AN
ENFORCEABILITY AFTER THAT
BECOMES REALLY IMPORTANT AND-
WE TEND TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE AND
EITHER AS THEY'RE BEING
AFFECTED OR THEY'RE AT THEY
HAVE LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. AND SO THE WORK TO TRY
TO GET THEM CONNECTED TO LEGAL
SERVICES AND LEGAL SUPPORT IS
ALWAYS A RUSH AT THE LAST
MINUTE. SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO
THE STRENGTH AND THAT YOU'VE
EXTEND MORATORIUM THAT ARE IN
PLACE AND MAKE THOSE AND
FORCIBLE- WILL BE REALLY
HELPFUL AIMED AT. LOWERING THAT
AND THEN LOOKING AT LONGER TERM.
HOW DO NOT ONLY HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE
AFFECTED BECAUSE OF RENT THAT.
BACK- IT PEOPLE CAN'T PAY RIGHT
NOW IT'S TO. THEM PAY IT
INCREASE RENTS. THE MAKE FOR
THEIR PAY BUT THEN. HOW TO WE-
FIND THE BALLOT BETWEEN. AND
THE- I DIDN'T THE LAMB. FULL
AND WORK IN THE STATE. AND FOR
THE FOR GOVERNMENT AFTER- YOU
TO MAKE THAT CALL AND CREATE
NUMBER. NOTHING FROM. THAT WE-
START FRESH WITH BOTH THEY'RE
NOT TO BE OUR RISK OF A FALLING
IN. YEAH I- I'M BACK BECAUSE- A
WOMAN ISSUE. OUT ACTUALLY KOBE
AND WORK THAN WE WERE NORMALLY.
I LIKE TO READ. UP MIDWAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- AND I
APPRECIATE A TEST TESTING
ESPECIALLY FROM HER I THOUGHT
THAT WAS COMPELLED SIX CHARLIE-
WHY TO ASK I GUESS I'LL THE
LOCALS- WHAT I APPRECIATE ALL
Y'ALL'S WORK YOU WHICH ARE THE
ONES ON THE GROUND IMPLEMENTING
THESE PROGRAMS AND REALLY KIND
OF ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE-
OF THIS EPIDEMIC OF HOME A
SECOND EPIDEMIC SO I THINK YOU
PROVIDE A REALLY UNIQUE AND
IMPORTANT PERSPECTIVE FOR US IS
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
BUDGETARY. ISSUES AND CONCERNS
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
INVEST AND WHOEVER WANTS TO
ADDRESS THIS WOULD BE GREAT-
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT ARE
THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU'VE YOU
ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE IN
COMBATING THE PROBLEM YOU HAVE
HE PAP HOME HE- SO WHAT I THINK
IS MOST EFFECTIVE- WHICH WHICH
OF THE PROGRAMS ARE IT MUST
EASIEST TO NAVIGATE FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF DEALING
WITH RED TAPE AND BUREAUCRACY
IN OTHER THINGS- AND THEN THE
LAST QUESTION I HAVE AND I
THINK I KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS
BUT WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM
YOU. DO YOU THINK THE FUNDS
THAT WERE PUTTING FORCE- MATCH
THE NEEDS IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
SORRY FOR ALL THREE OF THOSE
ARE THROUGH THIS QUESTIONS THAT
WOULD JUST LOVE TO GET YOUR
ALSO PERSPECTIVE ON WHOEVER
WANTS TO TAKE IT. I'M HAPPY TO
GO PERSON THAT THE L. A.
PERSPECTIVE. I RIGHT WE GET THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT CONGRESS
STATE FUNDING DON'T TEND TO BE
AS STRINGENT AS WHAT WE SEE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
BACK APPRECIATED THE PERSON
FLEXIBILITY THERE. WHERE WE
HAVE SEEN THE MOST VALUE IN
THOSE DOLLARS IS WITHOUT
PROBLEM SOLVING RESOURCE THAT I
MENTIONED SO. WE SEE AN
INCREASED NEED FOR. I THINK
THAT IS VERY FLEXIBLE AND NON
RESTRICTIVE AND THINK THAT
PEOPLE ACT- AND AS A ROOMMATE
TO GIVE THAT ONE TIME OR SHORT
TERM INTERVENTIONS THAT. RESULT
HOMELESSNESS BEFORE PEOPLE
LANGUISH FOR TOO LONG IN THE
HOME OF THE SIX DOT ORG. HOUSE
SO. BRINGING THAT UP WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND THEN
JUST GOING BACK TO PUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WE'VE MADE
BEFORE OR ON THE- ON GOING
FUNDING HE FELT. ANYTHING THAT
CAN BE DONE TO CREATE A LEVEL
OF PREDICTABILITY AND WE'VE
BEEN HAVING CONVERSATIONS HERE
AND ELSEWHERE. ABOUT HOW WE DO
THAT LOCAL FUNDING. FOR THE
LEAD FROM OUR NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS AND OUR PARTNERS.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD EVEN
PERFORMANCE SPEED DECREASE
BUDGET. PREDICTABLE BUT AT-
THAT WE COULD THEN BUILD ON OUR
ON DEMAND- INCREASE OVER TIME.
BUT THE WAR THAT WE CAN PLAN
AND BOOK THE- MORE THAT WE CAN
GET AWAY. FROM HAVING TO RAMP
UP PROGRAMS OF RAMPANT I'M
REALLY QUICKLY. THE BETTER
BECAUSE WE CAN SEE THAT THE
FUNDING IN THE IN FACT THAT YOU
DON'T BURGER. SO THE EXAMPLE
PRODUCT REVIEW THE PHENOMENAL
ONE BECAUSE WE ARE ABLE TO
CONVERT A LOT OF THOSE.
PROBLEMS HE- AND NOT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ALL THE START UP OFTEN
AND ALL THE EFFORT THAT COMES
WITH THAT. AND WE ARE ABLE TO
KIND OF LEVERAGE. WITH ALREADY.
EXISTING AND BILL. WITH YOU AND
I DON'T KNOW- PETER TO ME TO
PUT YOU ON THE SPOT BUT SINCE
YOU ARE IN MY CITY LOVE TO SEE
IF YOU HAVE A REAL TO THAT IS A-
ABSOLUTELY- THANK YOU SOME WITH
THEM. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO- TWO
THINGS FOR YOU. IN IN. WITH
RESPECT. PROGRAMS THAT WE- TO
BE. THE MOST AFFECTED- WE- HAVE
AS A YOU KNOW IT'S- MEMBER A
LARGE. WITH IN CANTON AND STRAY
HOME WAS. AND IN OUR EFFORTS.
TO MITIGATE SOME OF THE WORST
IMPACTS. OF ENCAMPMENTS. BRING
PEOPLE INSIDE. WE FOUND THAT
SHELTER PROGRAMS AND OTHER
INTERN HOUSING PROGRAMS. THAT
HAVE VERY LOW BARRIERS TO
ENTRY. TEND TO BE THE MOST
AFFECTED AND WE LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT. FOURTEEN IN OAKLAND.
FIVE BEING. THE ABILITY TO
BRING YOUR HAD. BRING YOUR
PARTNER. I'M COMING WITH YOUR
PARTNER- HAVE STORAGE FOR YOUR
POSSESSIONS. WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SLEEP AT EIGHT WITH IT WITH
YOUR OWN PRIVACY AT NIGHT SO
THOSE FORTIES AT TAX PARTNERS
POSSESSIONS IN PRIVACY- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FOUND TO BE
PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY CABINS PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE WHICH HAS A HIGHER
UPTAKE RATE IN SOME OF OUR
TRADITIONAL SHELTON- IN TERMS
OF- AS SOME OF THE RED TAPE
REDUCTION- PROJECT HOME HE I
THINK WAS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF.
WHAT CAN BE DONE WHEN THE STATE
WHEN THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PARTNER WITH AN
AGGRESSIVE DEADLINE- AND WHEN
THE STATE HELPS MOVE AWAY SOME
OF THE REGULATORY BARRIERS IN
TERMS OF PERMITTING PROCESS
THESE OTHER. THINGS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO GET PROJECTS LIKE.
WE CAN BE VERY QUICKLY. THREE
MONTHS WE OPENED A HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR UNITS THAT- HOUSING.
AND I THINK I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT TIME IF YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAPPY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LIKE TO
KNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK'S OF- THANK YOU TO THE
PRISONERS AND CHARLIE TO- I
LIKE SEEING THAT- WELL WE GET
TO SEE ALL OF THAT- WORK THAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING AT HOME AND A
LOT OF IT IS JUGGLING- TEACHING
AND BABIES AND SO FORTH- AND I
AND I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
JUST THIS INFORMATION OF THE-
FOR PEACE THAT THAT IS A VERY
GOOD WAY TO BRANDED AND- BUT
CERTAINLY IF YOU HAVE WORKED
IN. THE HOMELESS COMMUNITY
YOU'LL KNOW THAT THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES TO DEAL WITH
IT'S EASY TO SAY WHY PEOPLE
DON'T GO ON BUT IT'S HARDER TO
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO GET PEOPLE
TO COME IN TO SHELTER SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I AM. STILL
INTERESTED IN IS AS WE LOOK AT
THE FUNDS THAT ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED- WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
SAID OR HEARD SEVERAL TIMES IS
TO KEEP PEOPLE INTO THEIR HOME
SO IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PANEL OR EVEN HERE WITH LISA
THAT CAN. ANSWER WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF FUNDS DO WE HAVE
THAT ARE SIMPLY AVAILABLE FOR
IF YOU WANT TO SAY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE THAT CAN GET
DIRECTLY TO SOMEBODY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT- KEEPING SOMEONE IN
THEIR HOME EVEN IF THAT IS
RENTAL DIRECT RENTAL ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE MUCH LESS COSTLY THAN
ONCE THEY FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS TRYING TO GET THAT
INFECTION OFF THEIR- RECORD
TRYING TO GET A FIRST AND-
LAST. PAYMENT SO WHAT WHAT TYPE
OF RENTAL ASSISTANCE IF WE CAN
IN A PERCENTAGE ARE WE ACTUALLY
SEEN OUT. OF ALL THE HOUSING
DOLLARS OUT THERE. IF ANYBODY
KNOWS. ANYONE ON THE PANEL WANT
TO COMMENT ON THAT. I THINK
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT THE FIRST
TEN DIGITS AWAY KEEP TOP
LAWYERS ARE HALF DOLLARS FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE GOING TO SOME
SORT OF PERMANENT HOUSING
SUBSIDY OPPOSE THAT RICHARD
SHELTER. RIGHT OR EVEN COUNTY
YOUR BECAUSE WE KNOW MONEY
FLOWS FROM THE STATE TO THE
COUNTY SOMETIMES TO THE CITIES.
AND AGAIN ALL MANY TIMES OR
STRINGS ATTACHED SO JUST BEING
ABLE TO GET A RENTAL VOUCHER IF
YOU WANT TO SAY IS NOT VERY
EASY. BUT IF THERE IS THAT TYPE
OF FUNDING DO WE HAVE ANY
ESTIMATE IS IT IN 1% OF THE
TOTAL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS 5% DO
WE HAVE ANY IDEA. YOU CAN LOOK
INTO IT FURTHER I CAN TELL YOU
FROM THE LA PERSPECTIVE IT IS
AT LEAST HALF IF NOT THE
MAJORITY OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
GOING TO SOME SORT OF PERMANENT
SUBSIDY- WHAT WE TRY TO FIND
NOW IS THAT. OFTENTIMES WE NEED
SUBSIDIES A LONGER SO THERE'S
PEOPLE WHO NEED A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WITH FULL
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT'S KIND
OF WHAT WE CALLED THE PLATINUM-
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO NEED THESE RAPID RE HOUSING
SUBSIDIES. FOR MORE THAN THE
TWO YEAR TERM THAT THEY'RE
OFTEN PROVIDED FORCED TO WORK
TRYING TO SUPPLEMENT PATH TO
SAY. WE CAN USE THE SCALE
APPROACH SO WE MIGHT COVER A
100% OF YOUR RENT FOR THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS AND THEN TAILOR IT
DOWN OVER TWO THREE FOUR EVEN
FIVE YEAR PERIOD. BUT THE GOAL
OF BEING A DECREASE ENVESTNET
BUT LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY IN
HOUSING AND MAKING SURE THAT
THAT THAT RISK OF FALLING BACK
IN- IT DEGRADES. SO ALMOST CITY
BY. UP THE THOSE. IF YOU WANT
TO SAY HOW. DEPARTMENTS ARE OR
COUNCIL MEMBERS MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS DEPENDING ON THEIR
CONSTITUENCY. IT DEPENDS ON THE
TYPE OF FUNDING SO YOU KNOW
FEDERAL FUNDING IS KIND OF
DICTATED THE LOCAL FUNDING IS A
COORDINATION EFFORT BETWEEN THE
PROVIDERS TO SEE- YOU GET A
CITY- AND THE COUNTY AND THE
STATE DOLLARS ARE SIMILAR IN
THAT SENSE TOO SO I WOULD SAY
IT'S KIND OF ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I RECALL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY I WANT TO THANK
THE THREE PANELISTS OF FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND- FOR JUGGLING ALL
THAT YOU ARE JUGGLING THAT-
PRITCHETT YOUR WORK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR THIRD PANEL LET ME
INTRODUCE FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE
LINE AND JOINING US REMOTELY-
DOCTOR BELIEVES ADAMS KELLUM
WITH SAINT JOSEPH CENTER
CENTER- JANIE ROWNTREE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB AT UCLA
DR JONATHAN SHERIN DIRECTOR OF
L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND WE ASK THAT
EACH PANELIST- KEEP THEIR CALM
THERE'RE- INTRODUCTORY
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS TO FIVE
MINUTES IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
AND SO THAT WE CAN GET TO-
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS. WE
CAN BEGIN WITH THE DOCTOR OF
LISA ADAMS KELLUM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU SOMEONE CARRILLO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO PUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
JOINT HEARING OF YOUR
COMMITTEES. I JUST HEARD MY
NAME IS DR ALICIA ADAMS CALLUM
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
SEEN JUSTICE CENTER. I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH YOU
TODAY. ST JOSEPH CENTER HAS
BEEN WORKING TO ADDRESS POVERTY
AND HOMELESSNESS IN LOS ANGELES
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS. AND TODAY
WE REACH MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE ANNUALLY OUR PRIMARY
LOCATIONS ON THE WEST SIDE AND
SOUTH LOS ANGELES IN DOWNTOWN
LA. AND OUR STAFF WORKED OUT L.
A. COUNTY HELPING PEOPLE
OVERCOME HOMELESSNESS THE FOUR
PILLARS OF OUR WORK OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT HOUSING MENTAL
HEALTH. AND EDUCATION AND
VOCATIONAL SERVICES. ENABLE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
LAUNCHED ITS AD HOC COMMITTEE
ON BLACK PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THE COMMITTEE WAS
CHAIRED BY LOSS OF COMMISSIONER
JACQUELYN WAGNER. AND I WAS
APPOINTED TO SERVE AS THE
WORKGROUP LEAD TO THE
COMMITTEE'S REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. COMMISSIONER
WAGNER IS SORRY THAT SHE'S
UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY. ALSO
CREATED COMMITTEE IN
RECOGNITION OF THE PERSISTENT
OVER REPRESENTATION OF BLACK
PEOPLE AMONG THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND THESE NUMBERS
ARE STARK. IN L. A. COUNTY
BLACK PEOPLE REPRESENT JUST 9%
OF THE GENERAL POPULATION BUT
MAKE UP 35% OF THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
STATEWIDE THE GAP IS EVEN
LARGER BLACK PEOPLE ARE JUST
SIX POINT 5% OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION BUT AGAIN 40% OF
THOSE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
SADLY THIS SAME
DISPROPORTIONATELY IS SEEN
ACROSS. THE UNITED STATES. THE
COMMITTEE FOUND THAT THIS VAST
DISPARITY IS ROOTED IN OUR
COUNTRY'S GRAHAM HISTORY OF
STRUCTURAL AND INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM. SUCH TRAGIC TRAGEDIES
AS SLAVERY JIM CROW REDLINING
AND MASS INCARCERATIONS
UNDERMINE THE BLACK COMMUNITY
FOR GENERATIONS AND
SYSTEMATICALLY PREVENTED BLACK
FAMILIES FROM ACCUMULATING
RESOURCES. THESE LONGSTANDING
DISPARITIES HAVE PLAYED OUT THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL WITH TERRIBLE
CONSEQUENCES AND L. A. COUNTY
WE'VE SEEN KOBE NINETEEN IMPACT
PEOPLE OF COLOR AT RATES MANY
TIMES HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION BOTH IN TERMS OF
INFECTION RATES. AND SADLY IT
HOLIDAYS ONE AREA OF HOPE HAS
BEEN THE PROJECT ROOM KEY AND
PROJECT HOME KEY UNLESS HOUSING
INITIATIVES THAT WE DISCUSSED
TODAY. AND THEY WERE FUNDED OF
COURSE BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
MANY OF YOU SUPPORTED. AND IT
HAS BEEN A GAME CHANGER. SO
JOSEPH ST PER IN THE EFFORTS A
LITTLE YEAR AND WE STOPPED HAND
HOW THESE PROGRAMS SAVE LIVES.
AS WE LOOK IN THE FUTURE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET WHICH
WILL ALLOW FOR A BRIDE
REPLICATION OF PROJECT HOME T.
AND LOS ANGELES WE APPLIED THE
AD HOC COMMITTEE'S FINDINGS AND
MADE A COURSE CORRECTION AND
HOW WE IMPLEMENTED THIS
PROGRAM. WE ENSURE THE
PLACEMENTS INTO PROJECT HUNKY
MATCH PROPORTIONALLY OUR
POPULATION EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WE URGE YOU NOW TO
MANDATE THIS APPROACH STATEWIDE
BY DIRECTING THAT RESOURCES BE
ALLOCATED SPECIFICALLY TO THE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY HOMELESSNESS WITH
THEM I TO ADDRESSING THE
DISPROPORTIONATE ALITY. AMONG
BLACK PEOPLE THAT I HIGHLIGHTED
EARLIER I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
SPEARHEADING AB SEVENTY ONE THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
HAVE BOTH TAKEN A POSITION TO
pCENTER JOIN WITH OTHERS IN THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY. ADVOCATE
FOR IT AS WELL SUSTAINABLE
RELIABLE RESOURCES MATTER AS%
YOU'VE HEARD AS AB SEVENTY ONE
MAKES CLEAR AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE RECENT STATE
INVESTMENT IN HOUSING AND
SERVICES ONE TIME FUNDING TAKES
ABOUT MINISTRY TO TIME AND
RESOURCES TO PREPARE FOR NEW
PROGRAMS AND THE ONE TIME
NATURE OF THE FUNDING LIMITS.
WHAT WE CAN DO WITH THOSE FUNDS
AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE EARLY
ENDORSERS OF THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME CAMPAIGN WHICH
WILL ALSO PROVIDE ON GOING
FUNDING FOR EVIDENCE BASED
MODELS I'VE TALKED ABOUT. FOR
BLACK PEOPLE TO FULLY BENEFIT
FROM THESE RESOURCES WE MUST
MAKE AN INVESTMENT PROPORTIONAL
TO THE PRESENT AND HOUSE
COMMUNITY AND WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THE SERVICES THEY RECEIVE.
ARE TRAUMA INFORMED AND
CULTURALLY TAILORED BEARING
THAT IN MIND WE ARE REQUESTING
A CAR ABOUT A DEDICATED FUNDING
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SERVICES
THAT CAN EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
THE NEED TO FIND HOUSE BLACK
PEOPLE. ANOTHER THING THAT THE.
AD HOC COMMITTEE LEARNED IS
THAT BLACK SINGLE DAHLE. ART AS
LIKE TO FALL OUT HOW. AS THEIR
WHITE AND LATINO CONTENT. WELL
BLANCA ARE TO AS LIKE TO FALL
OUT OF HOW. COMPARED TO WHAT
AND LYFT FAN. THIS SERVICE THAT
CAN HELP COUNTER THESE TRENDS
INCLUDE ACADEMIC SUPPORT FOR
CHILDREN MENTAL HEATH
TREATMENT ACCESS TO FOOD AND
HEALTH CARE LOCATIONAL TRAINING
AND MANY OTHERS. THE COMMITTEE
ALSO FOUND WHO PROVIDES THESE
CRUCIAL SERVICES MATTERS AS
WELL. THROUGH HUNDREDS OF HOURS
OF LISTENING SESSIONS WE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS CLIENTS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING SERVICES AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND THEIR INPUT WAS
UNANIMOUS. HIRING PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS WEBER CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE LANDS TO PROVIDE
DIRECT SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IS CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS. OF THE BLACK PEOPLE WE
ARE SERVING THUS IT IS VITAL
THAT WE EARMARKED DOLLARS FOR
HIRING AND TRAINING OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERTISE TO DELIVER TROM
INFORMED. CULTURALLY TAILORED
HOUSING RETENTION SERVICES. IN
CLOSING I JUST WANT TO SAY IN
THIS TIME WHEN SO MANY ARE
CALLING FOR JUSTICE WE MUST
ADOPT POLICIES THAT INCREASE
EQUITY. BY APPLYING A DATA
DRIVEN EQUITY LENS TO ENSURE
THE TARGETED PROPORTIONAL
IMPACT OF HOMELESS RESOURCES
CALIFORNIA CAN ONCE AGAIN LEAD
THE WAY AND INSPIRE OTHER.
STATES THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DR ADAMS COLUMN I
COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE
IN TERMS OF THE REGIONAL
APPROACH AND THE EQUITY
APPROACH IN TERMS OF ARE MOST
IMPACTED AND BEING FROM LOS
ANGELES. I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WE ARE
MOVINGON TO OUR NEXT PANELIST-
AND AGAIN I ASK IF YOU CAN
PLEASE. BE CONCISE WITH FIVE
MINUTES SO THAT WE CAN GET TO
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS FROM THE
MEMBERS- IS AND CHENEY ROWNTREE
ON THE LINE. YES I'M HERE GREAT
THANK YOU YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY LAB AT UCLA. EPL THE
NONPARTISAN RESEARCH LAB BASED
AT UCLA AND UC BERKELEY WE
DEVELOP INTENSIVE PARTNERSHIPS
RESEARCH PARTNERSHIPS THE STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES AND
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE OVER TWO
DOZEN PARTNERSHIPS. I'M
CURRENTLY AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL AND I'M GOING TO
FOCUS TODAY ON OUR RESEARCH ON
HOMELESSNESS IN LOS ANGELES. WE
HAVE HEARD POLICY LAB WORKS
WITH ADMINISTRATIVE DATA FROM
EIGHT DIFFERENT L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS AND SEIZE THE
HOMELESS POPULATION DOCUMENTED
NOT ONLY BY LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
SERVICE RECORDS. BUT ALSO BY
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS. USING ALL OF THESE
DATA WE SEE THAT IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND UNIQUE SINGLE ADULTS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND LOS
ANGELES THIS NUMBER IS QUITE A
BIT LARGER THAN THE PIT COUNT
BECAUSE IT IS AN ANNUAL
ESTIMATE OF UNIQUE PEOPLE AND
NOT A SNAPSHOT. ON ONE EVENING.
IT'S POPULATION IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE WITH VERY DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS INTO HOMELESSNESS
EXPERIENCES AND NEEDS. SO TODAY
I WANT TO GIVE YOU THREE DATA
POINTS FROM ARE COMPLETED AND
ALSO FROM I'M GOING ON
PUBLISHED RESEARCH AND TALK
ABOUT HOW EACH OF THESE DATA
POINTS CONNECTS TO THE STATE'S
ROLE. IN RESPONDING TO
HOMELESSNESS. I WANT TO START
BY TALKING ABOUT ARGUABLY THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
SPECIFICALLY UNSHELTERED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUFFERING
FROM SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS IN
RECENT YEARS LOS ANGELES HAS
GREATLY EXPANDED OF STREET
OUTREACH SERVICES. AND IN A
RECENT YEARS RETIREES WORKERS
WERE IN CONTACT WITH JUST UNDER
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. WE WENT TO THE
STREET ARE REACHED RECORDS TO
CLINICAL DATA PROVIDED BY THE
L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH. AND FOUND THAT
20% OF SRIDHAR REACH CLIENTS
HAVE A CLINICAL DIAGNOSIS THIS
YEAR IS MENTAL ILLNESS BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FINDING
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT RELY ON
SURVEYS OR SELF REPORTED
INFORMATION WHICH CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN ESPECIALLY
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY WELL.
ALSO 20% IS A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE AS MANY AS THREE HOURS
CLIENTS MIGHT BE UNDIAGNOSED OR
COULD HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED BY
ANY AGENCY OTHER THAN THE OUR
MENTAL HEALTH. WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT. WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
NEED INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING AND
HOUSING SUBSIDIES TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
WE SHOULD EXPECT THAT SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS ARE ALSO
SUFFERING FROM SEVERE
CONDITIONAL IMPAIRMENT IN
HOUSING ALONE IS NOT ENOUGH FOR
THEM THEY WILL NEED ACCESS TO
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
SOMETIMES CALLED BOARDING CARE.
UNLIKE MOST SHELTER STAFF THE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES CAN
ADMINISTER MEDICATION AND
MONITOR AND HANDLE BASIC NEEDS
ON A TWENTY FOUR HOUR BASIS.
EITHER CRUCIAL RESOURCES THEY
ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
ENCAMPMENTS AND THE MOST SICK
THESE FUNCTIONAL INDIVIDUALS
LIVING ON OUR STREETS. YES THEY
ARE CLOSING DUE TO FUNDING GAPS
IN A LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
THE STATE COULD PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN SHORING UP OPERATING
FUNDING AND EXPANDING THE
AVAILABLE BEDS. IN RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. I WANT TO TALK NEXT
ABOUT OUR RESEARCH INTO RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. YOU ARE
WORK WITH THE AADHAAR COMMITTEE
ON BLACK PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WE FOUND AND
FURTHER REFINES ARE FINDING
THAT A BLACK CLIENTS REPLACING
THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING OR NEARLY 40% MORE
LIKELY TO RETURN HOMELESSNESS.
I CLIENTS IN OUR FOLLOW UP
RESEARCH WHICH WILL BE RELEASED
LATER THIS YEAR THE KEY DRIVERS
OF RACIAL DISPARITIES APPEAR TO
BE THE TYPE AND QUALITY OF
HOUSING AVAILABLE TO BLACK
CLIENTS THE INTENSITY OF
SERVICES CASE MANAGER TURNOVER
OR SMALL CITY CONCERNS AND
WEBER DISCRIMINATION-
INTERVIEWS AND DATA ANALYSIS A
STARK PICTURE IS EMERGING.
BLACK CLIENTS EXPERIENCE WORSE
OUTCOMES IN PART BECAUSE OF THE
QUALITY OF HOUSING AND SERVICES
THAT HAPPEN TO BE AVAILABLE TO
THEM WHERE THEY AT WHERE THEY
ARE HOMELESS. THIS IS
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND ANY OF
ITS STRUCTURAL SOLUTION. THE
STORE A FEDERAL AND
OCCASIONALLY STATE FUNDING IS
PRIORITIZE FOR HOUSING
SUBSIDIES IN HOUSING UNITS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
NONPROFITS ARE LEFT TO FILL THE
GAPS- SERVICES AND FOR
OPERATING EXPENSES FOR OUR NON
PROFIT PROVIDER BASED. WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT AN
UNDERINVESTMENT IN THE SERVICE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CONTRIBUTING
A RACIAL DISPARITIES. H. SHOULD
CONSIDER STABLE FUNDING.
FUNDING SOURCES FOR SERVICES.
AND CLEARLY WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
THE INVESTIGATION AND
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
DISCRIMINATORY HOUSING
PRACTICES. FINALLY I WANT TO
END BY TALKING ABOUT SINGLE
ADULTS WERE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS FOR THE FIRST
TIME. I STARTED TALKING ABOUT
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS BUT IT'S
ALSO TRUE THAT 50% OF SINGLE
ADULTS INVOLVED IN HOW THE
SERVICES FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
A GIVEN YEAR I'VE NO PRIOR
SERVICE HISTORY WITH THE
COUNTY. THAT MEANS THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
INCARCERATED IN THE JAIL
TREATED FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER OR ENROLLED IN SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS IN FACT WE MERGED
STATE EMPLOYMENT RECORDS TO
HOMELESS SERVICES RECORDS WE
LEARNED THAT 47% OF PEOPLE
ENROLLED IN HOMELESS SERVICES
IN LOS ANGELES WE'RE WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA WITHIN. TWO YEARS OF
THE HOMELESS. THE HALF OF THE-
SINGLE ADULT DO YOU SERVICE.
OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT L. A.
COUNTY AND CITY COULD
POTENTIALLY PREVENT THESE
INFLOWS BEFORE THEY OCCUR. AND
COLLECTION LHASA WE ARE
DEVELOPING A PURELY VALID
SURVEY THAT CAN BE USED IN THE
FIELD TO SCREEN PEOPLE SEEKING
PREVENTION WHICH IS TYPICALLY A
ONE TIME CASH ASSISTANCE. WE'VE
ALSO DEVELOPED PREDICTIVE
MODELS TO HELP L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS IDENTIFY CURRENT
CLIENTS YOUR TIRE IS GOOD
POLICY THAT ARE IMPLEMENTING
AND PREVENTION PILOT. LED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES. THE GOAL IS TO REACH
PEOPLE OF UNITS. HOUSING AND
CERTAINLY BEFORE THEY'RE ON THE
STREET WHERE THEY ARE HIGH RISK
OF DEVELOPING PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES. I'VE
GIVEN THREE DATA POINTS TODAY
THAT IF YOU'RE DISCONNECTED AND
I'M RELATED TO EACH OTHER BUT
THEY ARE NOT THEY REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY AMONG THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND THE NEED TO FIND
A WIDE RANGE OF SOLUTIONS. WE
HAVE TO RESIST CHARACTERIZING
THE HOMELESS CRISIS AS ONLY
ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS ARE ONLY
ABOUT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
ARE ONLY ABOUT POVERTY AND
UNEMPLOYMENT. THE DATA DOES NOT
SUPPORT SUCH AN HEARING HERE.
WE NEED A HARD RANGE. OF
SOLUTIONS. AND THE COURAGE AND
IMAGINATION TO PURSUE THEM. OUR
RESEARCH ALSO CONSISTENTLY
SHOWS THE NEED TO INVEST IN
SERVICES AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
IN ADDITION TO HOUSING. I DID
NOT HAVE THE TIME TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT A RESURGENCE OF THE ONLY
HOMELESSNESS BUT I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
THAT TOPIC THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING ME. THANK YOU MISS MISS
ROWNTREE I WOULD ACTUALLY WOULD
LOVE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ON FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS- YOU KNOW. PERHAPS
A AND- WHEN WE HAVE MORE MORE
TIME- DURING THE Q. AND THE Q.
AND A OF THIS PANEL BUT I THINK
THAT'S A VERY INTERESTING TOPIC
IN TERMS OF KEEPING THE FAMILY
TOGETHER AND KEEP THE FAMILY
UNIT. OF SAFE. OUR NEXT
PANELIST IS DOCTOR JOHNSON
SHARON- WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH DR SHARON ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU MAY
BEGIN. OKAY YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE STATE
FOR EVERYTHING THAT IS DOING
ALL THE ATTENTION. I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THIS COMMITTEE AND
YOU. BY CHAIRMAN TRIO FOR
INVITING ME- YOU KNOW. I COME
TO YOU AS A DIRECTOR OF THIS-
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT BUT
ALSO AS THE STREETS ARE
CATCHERS- AND YOU KNOW CLEARLY
THERE IS AN OVERWHELMING. ISSUE
OF DEMAND AND THERE'S A
OVERWHELMING NEED TO DEVELOP
CAPACITY BUT- HOW WE DO THAT IS
CRITICAL AND IT MUST BE DRIVEN.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- AT THE
GROUND LEVEL FROM THE GROUND
UP- AND WE NEED TO LOOK TOWARD
DESIRED OUTCOMES. ALWAYS BUT
WHEN WE TAKE A STEP BACK AND I.
I YOU KNOW I'M I'M HAPPY TO BE
FOLLOWING DR ROWNTREE WE HAVE
TO ASK OURSELVES I THINK IN A
SOPHISTICATED WAY WHETHER WE-
COMBAT. I'M IT HOMELESSNESS IS
NOT ONE THING- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A TICKET COUNTER. AND THE PECAN
IS- IN MY OPINION A VERY DAHLE.
BLUNT TOOL- IT DOESN'T EVEN
ADDRESS THINGS LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
RECIDIVISM ARE PEOPLE FALLING
IN AND OUT WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
LOSING THAT BATTLE OF. INVERSES
OUT BUT ARE THEY RECIDIVISTS-
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
EARLIER THAT I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
ASKING ABOUT GAP ANALYSIS- AND
YOU KNOW IT AND. I'M WORKING
CAREFULLY WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
POLICY LED TO DRESS THESE
ISSUES- BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS I'M VERY BIASED I FOCUS
ON THOSE WHO FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE- OF THEIR
CONDITION. AND WHAT I'LL SAY
ABOUT THAT IS IT IS NOT. THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IT SAID BUT
IT IS A GROUP THAT NEEDS VERY
VERY FOCUSED EFFORT AND
FLEXIBLE I'M GOING FUNDS BEYOND
WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE AND WE
HAVE TO THINK IN A
COMPLIMENTARY FASHION. AMONGST
THE DIFFERENT GROUPS ABOUT HOW
WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM FOR THE
COLLECTED NEEDS TO BE
COORDINATED VERY VERY WELL I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRIORITY FOR LASSA.
I'M AND THE LOCAL REALITY HERE
IS THAT IT'S GETTING WORSE. I'M
WE HAVE DEVELOPED OF A SPECIFIC
TEAM THE WHOLE THE HOME TEAM
WHICH FOCUSES ON THE SEVERE
PERSISTENT. NOW ILL. I'M AND
I'M TRYING TO GET THE NOT ONLY
DOING THOSE. WHO ARE SO
DIFFICULT TO ENGAGE BUT ALSO TO
HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHAT'S OUT
THERE. IN COLLABORATION WITH-
THE POLICY LAB. AND I WILL SAY
THAT HERE'S PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE ARE A HUGE PART OF
THAT EFFORT AND NEED TO BE. I'M
GOING. WITH RESPECT TO
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED. THIS
IS A CONTROVERSIAL THING BUT I
AM A STRONG BELIEVER BECAUSE
PEOPLE FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS
FOR VARIOUS REASONS AND DUE TO
THE TRAUMA DEVELOP. MENTAL
ILLNESS TO BECOME MY CUSTOMER
THAT WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE OFF
THE STREET. AND THERE I WOULD
SAY TO YOU THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT HOUSING OR SHELTER IT'S
ABOUT COMMUNITY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
MILITARY WHEN WE DEPLOY.
HUNDREDS THOUSANDS OF MILITARY
MEMBERS ARE PUT INTO DIGNIFIED
WELL RESOURCE COMMUNITIES.
DON'T WAKE. AND HAVE THE ARE.
WITH PROPERTIES LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IN MY OPINION TO TAKE
THAT APPROACH AND BRING PEOPLE
FROM TRAUMATIZING ENVIRONMENTS
TO COMMUNITY EVEN IF IT'S- IN.
COMMUNITY I WILL ALSO SAY THAT-
ALL OF THE RESOURCES THAT WE
ARE FUNDING YES PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS GREAT AND
THERE'S TONS OF DATA TO SUGGEST
THAT IT IS. THE SOLUTION FOR
DECADES BEHIND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE DECADES TO GET CAPACITY.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WHEN IT COMES
TO BRING CALIFORNIA HOME NO
PLACE LIKE HOME MONEY AND I'VE
HAD MANY MANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT NO PLACE LIKE HOME WITH
ALL STEINBERG- OFF AUTHORED AT.
ANY TO SAY ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THAT FUNDING AUDIT NOT JUST BE.
USED FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT AND
FOR NEW PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH AS BOARDING CARE NEEDS TO
NOT ONLY BE SAVED BUT EXPANDED
IN THAT BUSINESS MODEL MUST BE
FIXED. AND IT NEEDS ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL STREAMS OF MONEY AND
I WOULD SAY THE SAME THING
ABOUT THE MANY MANY PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE- BUILDINGS AND
FACILITIES THAT ARE BEING
LIBERATED I BELIEVE AS WE
DEVELOP NEW MODELS FOR HOW WE
CONDUCT. OUR BUSINESS ARE THE
MALLS ARE THE DEPARTMENTS LIKE
MINE THEY DON'T NEED THAT
SQUARE FOOTAGE GOING TO
CONSIDER HOW TO USE IT AS-
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IS KEY
AND THEN LASTLY I WILL SAY THAT
THE ANSWER IS NOT JUST ABOUT
HOUSING PEOPLE IT'S ABOUT
GIVING PEOPLE OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE NOT
SO DISABLED THAT THAT'S WHY
THEY FALL OUT NEED OPPORTUNITY
TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DR
TURN I'M GONNA OPEN IT UP TO
THE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKING. YEAH
THANK YOU. AMAZON YES. OKAY I
JUST WANT TO ALL THOSE WHO
IMPORT THUS FAR AND FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AND I- I RESPECT
AND APPRECIATE THE FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT THAT WE HAVE MADE AS
A STATE AS A COUNTRY AND AS A
COMMUNITY IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND I AGREE THAT-
WE NEED A WIDE RANGE OF
SOLUTIONS AS MISS ROWNTREE
SUGGESTED BUT- I BELIEVE VERY
VERY FORCEFULLY THAT THE
EFFICACY. OF THE ALLOTTED
TAXPAYER FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITED. UNLESS
WE SERIOUSLY TAKE ON THE
CHALLENGES OF TWO MAIN
CONTRIBUTIONS. NOT BEING
ADDICTION AND MENTAL ILLNESS
AND I BELIEVE IT'S SO LARGE
THAT WE NEED TO PARTNER WITH
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES THE
CREATING A STRATEGY AND
IDENTIFYING AND SERVING PEOPLE
WITH THESE DIFFICULT.
CONDITIONS AND THAT'S ALL I
HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER LOOKING
SOME MEMBERSHIP. THANK YOU I
JUST WANNA RESPONDED LAST FOUR
IN SAYING THAT. BUT MANY OF US
AGREE ABSOLUTELY WITH HER PAW
THAT WE'VE TO INTEGRATE LOTS
DIFFERENCES THAT ARE SIDE. WHEN
IT COMES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS- SUCH AS ABOUT.
IT'S BEEN HEALTH IT'S FROM
JUSTICES AND MANY OF SYSTEMS
ARE PER THAT LET COMMENT ON A
NUMBER OF YOU THIS A RELIEF.
PANEL ON IN A PRE. THE THAT
HAVE MADE A NUMBER OF YOU A
DIFFERENT TIME OF TOUCH. ISSUES
OF RACIAL EQUITY AND CERTAIN
HEARD THIS A FOR OUT HOW TO
FIND. MORE TO ADDRESS THIS MORE
BROADLY BUT LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS IF BEEN. IDEAS THAT
YOU HAVE ON HOW TO THE
HISTORICAL AND ONGOING LIKE OF
RACE- MY STAFF AND I WE'VE BEEN
KICKED AROUND OF IDEA IN THE
SPACE BUT- YOU ARE. AND IT'S
LOVE THOUGHTS HOW WE CAN.
REALLY VERY SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS OUR HISTORY OF THIS.
IMPACT OF PASSED INVOLVED. IN
ADDITION. DID YOU WANT TO TAKE
THAT FIRST NIGHT COMBAT UP. I'M
I'M I'M HAPPY TO I'M GONNA DO A
EAR DOCTOR CAL HAS THE ACCESS
BETTING. I MENTIONED IN PASSING
THAT- JUST IT'S- IMPORTANT THAT
WE IN. ON AND THAT'S- INTO OF
THEIR HOUSING. NOT THAT A MAJOR
IT HI COMMITTEE REPORT I DO
IT'S AN GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSED
BUDGET I NOT MISTAKEN- AND THEN
I'LL JUST GO. INTENTIONS BY
INDIVIDUALS BUT THEY ADD UP TO
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENT FACTS AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DISPARATE
IMPACTS IN LOS ANGELES YOU
REALLY SEE THAT. ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST CLIENTS
BUT ALSO THE NONPROFIT SERVICE
PROVIDER BASED. DO YOU HAVE THE
FUNDING AND RESOURCES. TO
MAINTAIN PERSONALITY AFRICAN
HEAD OF SALARIES TO CASE
MANAGER WORDS- TO SHORE UP
THEIR OPERATING COSTS IF YOU
EXPECT YOUR NONPROFIT. PROVIDER
BASED CONSTANTLY. FIND REYES.
OR COSTS THEN YOU START TO
DISPARITY AND THEY WERE ALL UP
INDUSTRY THIS. IN- IMPACT. LOCK
QUITE WHO ARE HOME SO. I'VE MY
REMARKS. HOW TO AFFECTED THAT
WE SEE IN THE HOMELESS SYSTEM
AND ALL ALL MAYBE LIKE DR OUT
ON TALK ABOUT OF THE DRAW-
INSTANCE OF THE HOW. FAR PEOPLE
END UP BEING AT HIGHER RISK OF
AND THE FIRST PLACE. THANK YOU
IN THE YOU MAKE A PLAY. ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THE- PAY. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF BLACK PEOPLE WHO.
PROPERTY IN. WHO WOULD BE HAPPY
IN MANY HAVE A THERE'S I WAS IN
AVAILABLE TO. I'M HOW BLACK
PEOPLE IN PEOPLE OF COLOR VOTE
NEED. OFTEN TO THOSE NEED THE
AND THEY- AND I IMPRESSED.
INVEST IN ORDER TO. BE TO HIGH.
AND TO GET. AND BE A PART OF
THE CITY THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS
PAY. ON TIME AND SO THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF INVESTMENTS THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO SEE THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN WHO IS
SHELTERING AND SERVING. WHEN IT
GETS TO THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
IT'S ABSOLUTELY THE CASE THAT
THERE IS DISPARITY OF
INVESTMENT IN A BLACK
COMMUNITIES AND THAT DOES
IMPACT. STRUCTURES IN NON
PROFITS AND AGENCIES. THAT ARE
ON THE- FRONTLINE OF. TO THE
NEED OF BLACK PEOPLE. AND IF WE
DON'T BASS. AT COULD IN THOSE
AND IN THOSE AGENCIES YOU WILL
NOT HAVE THE FOLKS WHO ARE
CLOSEST TO THE PROBLEM WITH A
CULTURAL LANDS I'LL BE
AVAILABLE TO SERVE WE REALLY
MUST CHANGE SOME OF THE
STRUCTURES IN THE WAYS THAT
MONIES ARE ACCESSED AND I THINK
IT ALSO SPEAKS TO THE DECISION
MAKER. WE NEED BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE AT THE TABLE NOT JUST
REPRESENTING AN AREA ARE BEING
AT FILLING A SEAT BUT HAVING
DECISION MAKING POWER AND
AUTHORITY AND WE NEED TO SEE
THAT ACROSS BOARDS IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR AND AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF AGENCIES THAT
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT WHERE
RESOURCES WILL BE INVESTED AND
THAT ALSO MEANS WE NEED TO BE
HIRING PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE. PROVIDING TRAINING
AND HAVE ONGOING INVESTMENT IN
SUPPORT SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS AND NOT TO MENTION
THE OVER REPRESENTATION OF
BLACK PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED YOUNG KIDS WERE
NOT GETTING ADEQUATE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A GREATER
GAP WE KNOW DO Và C. AND
SOME OF THOSE INVEST THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE UPSTREAM THE OVER
REPRESENTATION OF BLACK KIDS
ARE IN FOSTER CARE THEN FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS ONCE THE
EMANCIPATE AND YOU CAN SEE THE
TRAJECTORY ON AND ON- OVER THE
YEARS THAT THAT STARTS TO
CREATE THAT TERRIBLE GAP- THAT
KEEPS BLACK PEOPLE FROM BEING
ABLE TO COMPETE. AND HAVING.
EQUAL ACCESS TO RESOURCES IF
I'M THIS THIS IS- JOHN I AYE
WHY IT YOU KNOW ECHOED SOME OF
THESE HIS POOR I THINK THERE.
TO WAY WE- IS CRITICAL AND THE
VOICE. IS CRITICAL THE WAY WE
LEVERAGE PEOPLE OF THE NEXT I
SAW BEFORE. IS A HUGE. PART OF
THE SO BUT ONE OF THE THAT I
LEAD WITH IS ISSUE THAT WE DO
RE UNDER. EXACTLY WHAT'S OUT
THERE WITH NEARLY THE LEVEL
SOPHISTICATION THAT WE NEED AND
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OUTCOMES
BASED ON WHAT'S THERE AND BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE
OUTCOMES OF THE OUTCOMES FOCUS
ON GROUPS THAT WE WANT. TO
FOCUS ON BASED ON VULNERABILITY
BASED ON HISTORIES OF TRAUMA
BASED ON CONDITION THEN WE WILL
DRIVE THE FUNDING TO ACHIEVE
THOSE OUTCOMES. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SILVA.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I WANT
THANK ALL OF THE- OF THE FROM I
THINK CONGRESS I- I. WISH THAT
WE WERE NOT IN A PEN SO WE
COULD. ALL OF OUR- STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED IN HERE AND IN PERSON.
SOME OF THE BIG THINGS THAT
I'VE HEARD- PARTICULARLY UNDER
THE MENTAL HEALTH PART IS UP WE
FIRST KNOW THAT AS WE SEPARATE
OUR HEALTH SYSTEM- FROM OUR
MENTAL HEALTH. WE START TO GET
THESE NAVIGATION ISSUES AND I
KNOW FOR HOMELESS IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SOMEBODY WHO'S
ALREADY STRUGGLING. AND THEN
ASKING THEM TO NAVIGATE NOT
ONLY A HOUSING- OPPORTUNITIES
BUT MENTAL HEALTH WE LOSE MANY
PEOPLE RIGHT THERE THEY SIMPLY.
EVEN JUST TO GET AROUND FROM
ONE BUILDING TO ANOTHER BECOMES
VERY YEAR- BUT AGAIN AS A
BROKEN RECORD I DO WANT TO. SAY
TO THOSE OUT THERE THAT I RAN A
BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS SIGNED
AND THAT WAS TO CLARIFY THAT
MHS FUNDS CAN BE USED NOT ONLY
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES BUT
ALSO FOR ADDICTION AS WE KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE CO OCCURRING
SOMETIMES AND- THAT WE CAN NOT
BE PUSHING. ARE A PATIENTS FROM
ONE BUILDING TO ANOTHER IF YOU
WANT TO SAY IT THAT WAY. THEY
NEED TO GET HOME CARE AT
ANOTHER AREA THAT I'M REALLY
REALLY HOPING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO WORK ON. BEYOND I
REALLY THINK THAT WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF WORK TO DO- AND I SAID
IT AT THE BEGINNING SO I'LL
JUST AND THEN WRAP UP HERE. IS
AFTER THIS PANDEMIC WHICH WE
KNOW IS IN SIGHT- IT YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S SIX MONTHS OR EVEN
A YEAR. WE HAVE PUT IN MANY
STRUCTURES FOR COVE AND WHETHER
IT'S PROJECT ROOM KEY WHETHER
IT'S AGAIN THAT TEMPORARY
MOBILE HOUSING UNITS WHETHER
IT'S TENSE WHETHER IT'S HYGIENE
STATIONS. AND THOSE NEED TO
REMAIN SO MY PLEA OUT THERE IS
TO ANYBODY WHO'S WATCHING IT
THAT ARE ON THE HOUSING
COUNCILS THAT ARE WORKING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH THAT ARE WORKING
WITH HOUSING. THOSE NEED TO
REMAIN INTEL WE ARE IN A PLACE
TO BUILD BACK THE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING UNITS THAT WE NEED- SO
EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE TEMPORARY
WE NEED TO CONTINUE THOSE AFTER
WE START TO SEE KOBE. DWINDLE
BECAUSE AS WAS NOTED BY DR
JONATHAN SURE AND WE'VE GOT TO
GET PEOPLE OUT FROM THE
ELEMENTS WHETHER IT'S THE HEAT
OR THE COLD. WE KNOW THAT JUST
CHRONICALLY ENDS PEOPLE'S LIVES
JUST FROM BEING OUT IN THE
ELEMENTS LASTLY I'LL. JUST SAY
RIGHT HERE AT OUR CAPITAL.
BECAUSE OF KOBE HIM TO OF ALL
THE THINGS HAPPEN- THERE'S A
LOT OF SECURITY SO PEOPLE THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN ENTERING THIS
BUILDING- DON'T HAVE THAT
ACCESS AND I KNOW FOR SURE.
BECAUSE I WALK HERE THAT THERE
ARE HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LIVED ON OUR PART BROWN'S THAT
LIVE AROUND THE CAPITAL AND NOW
WE'RE LOCKED OUT AND- THIS IS
THE SAME THING I GO BACK TO
WHICH IS WE HAVE BIG THINGS TO
DO. BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
DO THE LITTLE THINGS SO I WOULD
SAY THESE HYGIENE STATIONS
THESE BATHROOMS. WE NEED THOSE
AND WE NEED THEM NOW BUT I
THANK YOU FOR THIS VERY ROBUST
PANEL FOR THESE EXPERTS THAT I
KNOW YOU'RE WORKING TIRELESSLY
AND FOR. OUR CHAIR. CHAIRS AT
MADAM CHAIR AND- MISTER CHAIR
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT.
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE CAN BE
HAVING. THANK YOU. IT I TRULY
CARILLO APOS TO MAKE IT QUICK
COME AB DOCTOR SHARE PLEASE.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY FOR- YOU
KNOW HOW TO CLARIFY THAT THE
USE OF- INTEGRATED FOR
INTEGRATED YOU KNOW WHEN IT
COMES TO. I TO COME ABILITIES
WHAT ALSO WOULD THREE. TO
LIVING CAN. AND THE TRAUMA
BECOMING HOMELESS IS THAT YOU
KNOW AS I SAID BEFORE I JUST
WANT TO REINFORCE. IT'S
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
ENGAGE PEOPLE ON THE SIDEWALK
IN THE STREET IN CAMDEN. BUT IF
WE CAN CREATE. TEMPORARY
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE. IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE SERVICES
ARE AVAILABLE. WHERE- YOU KNOW.
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE REMOVED FROM
THE STREETS STILL BE HOMELESS
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN AN INTERIM
SETTING IT'S GOING TO IMPROVE
THE SITUATION IS GOING TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH. PUBLIC
SAFETY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ENGAGE INDIVIDUALS OR OTHERWISE
NOT ENGAGED WILL MUCH MORE
EASILY AND I THINK WHEN WE
FOCUS- SO HEAVILY ON PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN THE MIDST
OF A- TRUE HUMANITARIAN- CRISIS.
THAT WE MISSED THAT THERE ARE
TWO MANY PEOPLE HOMELESS FOR US
NOT TO CREATE INTERIM SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE REALLY REALLY ROBUST
AND I. RETURNED TO MY COMMENT
ABOUT THE MILITARY AND HOW THEY
STAND UP LARGE INTENTIONAL WELL
ORGANIZED SAFE CLEAN
COMMUNITIES IN VERY SHORT
PERIODS OF TIME.
BUT NOT
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE BUILT FROM
GROUND UP WE CAN TAKE.
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN USED
BEFORE AND WE HAVE THEM. BUT WE
HAVE TO GET MOVING WE I JUST
DREAD THE IDEA OF HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS YEAR AFTER YEAR
MONTH AFTER MONTH- WE'VE MADE
PROGRESS SO THANK YOU TO THE-
PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES BUT WE HAVE SO MUCH
WORK TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I ALSO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL
BUT BEFORE. I PROCEED WITH WITH
THE QUESTIONS I DO WANT TO
INFORM FOLKS ARE TRYING TO GET
ON THE LINE THAT WE ARE HAVING
SOME. TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THAT ARE
BEING ADDRESSED AT THE MOMENT
AND AS SOON AS I HAVE AN UPDATE
FOLLOWING. UP A FEW MORE
MINUTES WITH Q. AND NAY I WILL
ANNOUNCE THAT AS WELL SO JUST
HOLD TIGHT AS US WE TRY TO
RESOLVE. OF ISSUES WITH THE
PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO DR SHARING I REALLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
ON. EXPEDITING AND THE
SERIOUSNESS AND URGENCY OF THE
ISSUE AND THE COMPARISON TO
MILITARY OPERATIONS. CAN YOU
PLEASE SHARE AND REALLY IT'S A
IT'S A QUESTION FOR FULL ARE
FOR ALL THREE PANELISTS BUT IN
OUR CONVERSATIONS WE'VE SPOKEN
BEFORE ABOUT THE BUREAUCRACY OF
BEING ABLE TO MOVE WITH URGENCY
CAN YOU PLEASE SHARE WITH US
WHAT ARE SOME THINGS THAT MAYBE
THE STATE CAN DO TO. REMOVE
SOME OF THAT RED TAPE THAT DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR THE COUNTIES TO
MOVE AS QUICKLY OR WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE BUREAUCRACIES EVEN
WITHIN THE COUNTY THE DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR ASSISTANCE TO MOVE AT
THE LEVEL OF URGENCY THAT IT
NEEDS TO MOVE THAT. AND WHAT
CAN WE DO TO HELP. THANK YOU-
AND I. I'LL I'LL GET STARTED
I'M SURE MY- FELLOW PANELISTS
HAVE COMMENTS ABOUT THIS TOO I
MEAN I ALWAYS TALK ABOUT-
OUTCOMES BEING- THE DRIVER
BASED ON THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FLEXIBILITY
WITH OUR RESOURCES IS CRITICAL
CHIEF US OUT. YOU KNOW IT THERE
IS A EXAMPLE. THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. YOU KNOW IT. IT'S
GOT THESE POCKETS OF FUNDS THE
FUNDS ARE KIND OF CONSTRAINED
IT. AND WHAT ABOUT THEY DO IN.
I CAN I WILL I WITH WITH THAT
SO. THAT. I'M STEINBERG A LOT
ON ON HOW TO DO A RE. COMMENT
BLOCK. BUT BUT WE NEED TO DO IS
NEED TO SEE ARE THE OUT WE WANT
ACHIEVE A THAT RESEARCH. AND
THEN LET THEM- YOU KNOW-
JURISDICTIONS SHE THOSE GOALS.
AND IT WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET IT DONE WE WANT BE A CHILD.
THOSE ARE WANT TO BE CAN TO
PROCESS OR TO BE A CAN. TO YOU
KNOW I. YOU KNOW CHEATING GOALS
FOR SPECIFIC POPULAR A LOT OF
WHAT HAVING IN THE STATE.
OBVIOUSLY THESE KIDS BY THE AND
I WE SAY THAT CALAIS. IS MOVING
IN AND- AT DIRECTION. YOU KNOW
BUT THIS TIME ARE THINGS THAT
THE STATE IS. I AM. MANY PEOPLE
ARE IN THIS OR REALLY SO.
REQUIRE LONG TERM. I TREAT. IN
LOCKING UNLOCK SAID ME I. X. I
DOESN'T ALLOW TO PAY FOR THAT.
SO WE ASKED FOR A WAIVER WE'RE
WORKING THE FEDERAL. YOU IN SHE-
BUT THAT'S SOME THAT'S BEEN A-
TO THE STATE OVER YOU AND A
HALF. I'M A WHAT I'M SAY TO YOU
IS. WE NEED FLEX. WITH OUR
FUNDS AND WE NEED TO BE ASKED
AND HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN OUTCOMES I WOULD LOVE
IT IF I. TEAM. WAS CHARGED TO
GO. AND FIND OUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC PROFOUND
MENTAL HISTORY IN THE STREET.
AND THE DECREASE THAT NUMBER
AND TRACK IT. ABOUT PERCENT
EVERY EVERY YEAR- AND THAT'S
WHAT I DO IT'S NOT- IT'S YES
THAT'S DOLLARS YOU CAN DO YOU
FOR THIS. THAT'S YEAH SORTS.
YOU KNOW WITH THEM. ARE ON
MEDICARE AND LOCAL MATCH AS
WELL. THANK YOU DOCTOR. ARE OR
IS THERE AND MARK COMING TO
FROM THE PEN. NO NOT AT THIS
TIME. I GUESS AS A SERVICE
PROVIDER I WOULD JUST SAY. THAT
THERE ARE SOMETIMES BARRIERS TO
FULLY UTILIZING RESOURCES WE
USE A BLEND OF FUNDING MODEL
AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY ASKING
OURSELVES CAN WE USE THIS FOR
THIS AND THAT AND THE
FLEXIBILITY. AND MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IN OF COURSE YOU'VE
HEARD ME SAY HOW MUCH WE NEED A
SUSTAINABLE RESOURCE. BUT I
THINK WE ALSO NEED TO MOVE AWAY
FROM THIS- APPROACH OF A BINARY.
WAY OF LOOKING AT HOMELESSNESS
AND HOMELESS SERVICES. I THINK
WE CAN SAY WE JUST NEED
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
WE JUST NEED IN TERM WE NEED
BOTH WE ARE IN A CRISIS-
PROJECT ROOM KEY. SHOWED US HOW
RESPONSIBLE YOU CAN BE IN A
CRISIS HOW WE CAN MOVE ON A
DIME SUGGESTS CENTER OPENED UP.
A COUPLE OF HOTELS IN WEEKS WE
CAN DO MORE AND MORE THERE'S
MANY UNDER UTILIZED- PARKING
LOTS BUSINESSES WAREHOUSES AND
I THINK WE JUST. HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD IN USING THOSE UNDER
UTILIZED SPACES FOR THE GOOD
AND TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS WE REALLY. I AM A
CHAMPION OF A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING I BELIEVE IN
HOUSING CARS AND I KNOW THAT
THAT IS THE SOLUTION
HOMELESSNESS BUT I'M ALSO
SEEING. OUR BLACK AND BROWN
BROTHERS ARE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS DYING ON THE STREETS
EVERY DAY AND WE CAN'T BUILD
FAST ENOUGH AND CAN'T SEEM TO
HOUSE PEOPLE. FAST ENOUGH WITH
THE INFLOW AND AT SUCH A HIGH
LEVEL SO WE NEED TO DO WHATEVER
IT TAKES WE NEED TO BE. AYE
INDETERMINACY RESPONSIVE WE
WERE LUCKY ENOUGH BLESSED TO
GET- SOME OF THE TRAILERS FROM
THE GOVERNOR ABOUT. NINE OR
EIGHT. LITTLE BIT OF THE-
PANDEMIC HIT AND THREE WEEKS
WITH. A INTO PER LOT INTO A
FROM FORTY P. I AM A IT'S BEEN
LIVE SAY. AND WE NEED TO DO
MORE OF THAT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AS WE TRY TO OUT THE PHONE
SYSTEM FOR PUBLIC COMMENT I
KNOW IT'S CURRENTLY BEING
WORKED ON. I WILL ASK AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION HOW CAN
DIFFERENT POTENTIALLY SILO
SYSTEMS LIKE HEALTHCARE CHILD
WELFARE CRIMINAL JUSTICE. AND
HOUSING BE ALIGNED TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. I JUST WANNA SEE
QUICK SOME EXAMPLE ON THE- AB
OFFICE OF DIVERSION EVERY IN
SAY JOSEPH'S. AND ARM AND
HEALTH SO. FROM OUR THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL. IS ALSO
IN CONCERT WITH OUR HOUSING FOR
HELP MAKE SURE WE'RE GOING INTO
JAIL WOULD GET FOLKS THE DOOR
BELONG THERE WITH MENTAL. OR
ILLNESS WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HOW SOMETHING IS SOME PRO.
THAT ARE QUITE FROM THE- HOW
FOR HEALTH IS IN THE- OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH IS
GETTING GAUGE. IN SOLUTIONS
WILL PRONGED AND SO THAT'S THE
IN THE- OF HOW ARE BREAKING
DOWN SOME OF THOSE SILOS AND
IT'S IT AND HAS A GREAT EFFECT.
AND WE NEED TO SCALE THAT
CONSIDERS. YEAH I WOULD RATHER
A LOT OF. OUR RESEARCH OVER THE
LAST. THREE YEARS AS- ON THIS
EXACT ISSUE- SPANKING. ACROSS
THESE SILOS INSTITUTIONS AND
THEN FOCUSING ON STRATEGIC
SOLUTIONS JUST GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES- I MENTIONED
THAT HAPPENED SINGLE ADULTS
BECOME HOME FOR THE TIME. OUR
CURRENT CLIENTS AND SO HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES-
WITH STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
YOU'VE BEEN BOTTLING RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. THERE ARE
PATTERNS OF SERVICE UTILIZATION
INCLUDING INCARCERATION- AND
SUBSTANCE USE. INTENSIVE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT THEY DO PUT
PEOPLE AT HIGHER RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND WITH THESE
PREDICTIVE MODELS WE CAN SEND
RESTLESS CHIU THE DEPARTMENT OR
PROACTIVE OUTREACH TO TRY TO
STOP THESE CLIENTS ARE BECOMING
HOMELESS- AND PILOT IS UNDER
WAY NOW- WE WILL KNOW MORE IN
THE NEXT SIX TO NINE MONTHS
ABOUT WHETHER. THEY WERE PRE
SET OUT TO DO IS POSSIBLE BUT
THE ENTIRE OF THAT IS TO
LEVERAGE OUR MAINSTREAM SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PARTICIPATE IN
REDUCING INFLOWS. AND EDUCING
THE BURDEN. ON OUR EMERGENCY
HOUSING SYSTEM. I'M THE FAMILY
SIDE. THE STORY IS ACTUALLY
QUITE DIFFERENT. SINGLE ADULT
HALF OF THE HAVE A SIR TO WHEN
YOU AT FAN. IN UTILIZED
AMERICAN SHELTER. IT IS NINETY.
NOW PERCENT OF FAMILY. ARE
KNOWN TO THE FORTY BE HOME. AND
SECONDLY PRINCE PERSON FAMILY.
ARE IN ROLLED AND HOW. THAT
HAVE. SO IT'S PRESENTED
ENORMOUS OFF TO INTERVIEW.
BEFORE FAMILIES HOME AND WE'VE
BEEN WERE WITH THE SO SERVICE.
SO THE QUICKER WE ARE OKAY FOR.
THE MODEL THE PULSE OF MY
HOWARD AND ROLLED FAMILIES- AND
WE HOPE TO START A PILOT WITH
THE COW FROM SOMETIME IN THE
COMING YEAR AND RECEIVE FUNDING
FOR A GUY. SO I THINK THERE ARE
ON. TO BRING DOWN SILOS AND
STAY. THE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE MAJOR IN. AND TO
TRY TO THE BURDEN ON OUR
HOUSING. IT REQUIRES STATE IN
OVER BECAUSE- AND COORDINATION
AND I WE ARE ADVANCING THE IN
LOSS INTO I WOULD SAY THAT.
LANDED SOLUTIONS WE HAVE TO
THEM WE HAVE TO MY READ THEY'RE-
WE'RE HOPING THEY WERE MAKING
SOME PROGRESS. ENGINEER I'M
PRETTY SURE YOU BRINGING UP TO
I JUST- CALL OUT THAT. THE
FAMILIES. IN OUR- THAT COURTNEY
ENTRY FOR FAMILY. IS IN.
COMBINED OF THE- OF MEASURE A
D. S. AND OTHER RE. KEEP
HAPPENED SO WE SEEN WHERE.
BLENDED. WORK MAKES SENSE ENACT
THE COAL OKAY. OF DPS PROVIDERS
IN OUR VARIOUS OR- AS WELL AS
WE ARE HELLO. IN THE SAN OFFICE
I THINK THAT'S IN THE- OF WHAT
WORK TO BRING DOWN SO BUT IT
DOES NEEDS TO BE SCALED AND
DATA THE YOU'RE ON. WOULD MAKE
A HUGE DIFFERENCE AND HOW CAN
BE SO. CAN I JUST I WANTED-
FOLLOW UP ON OF YOUR WHICH I
PRE A LOT OF IT GETS BACK TO
THE FUN QUESTION OF WHAT WE
CALL. AND ARE WE TRY. WELL YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE CHALLENGE AND
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A GOOD
GRIP ON IT AND I WOULD SUGGEST
I DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER STATES
DO- OR OR OTHER JURISDICTIONS
BEYOND THE PIC COUNT BUT I
MEAN. I TRUE COUNTIES IN
ONGOING COUNTER IN THE STREETS
ALL DAY LONG WHY ARE WE NOT
FIGURING OUT EXACTLY WHAT'S OUT
THERE AND THEN FIGURING OUT
WHO'S GOING TO DO WHAT AND
THAT'S NOT A SIDE ROAD SYSTEM
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE WHEN I
GOT HERE. MY TEAMS THE MENTAL
HEALTH TEAMS WERE DOING THE
SAME WORK AS THE REST OF THE OF
THAT THE GENERAL OUTREACH TEAMS
AND I SAID NO. WE NEED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE THE MOST PROFOUNDLY ILL AND
WE COME ACROSS PEOPLE THAT WE
CAN REFER TO THE GENERALIST IN
THE GENERAL WAS CONFINED PEOPLE
WITH SERIOUS ISSUES. AND THEY
CAN REFER THEM TO US SO IT'S A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BUT IT'S
ABOUT SAYING WHO'S TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT AND
THEN BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
GETTING THE TEAMS TO WORK
TOGETHER BUT IN ORDER TO DO
THAT WE HAVE TO KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GOING AFTER. AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THE STATE REALLY
CONSIDER WHAT IS CALIFORNIA'S
APPROACH TO THE PIT COUNT
BECAUSE IT OUGHT TO BE AN
ONGOING EFFORT THAT WE'RE WE
EVEN THIS DESPITE OUR SIZE.
WHERE WE WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A REGISTRY AND THAT WE KNOW
WHAT'S OUT THERE AND WE DERIVE
THE SOLUTIONS IN TERMS OF THE
PROGRAM TYPES AND ALSO THE
LEVEL. OF FUNDING. THERE WILL
BE REQUIRED. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ASSEMBLY. QUIRK SILVA- ARE ARE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PEOPLE
WAITING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO OR ARE THEY PUBLIC
COMMENT PEOPLE STILL WAITING TO
GET ON YES SIR WE'RE TRYING TO
RESOLVE THAT PROBLEM SO OKAY
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO EITHER DO A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE OR- TAKE
A BREAK IF IT'S NOT RESOLVED
SOON OKAY. WELL I JUST YOU KNOW
I'VE I'VE KIND OF SAID A LOT
BUT I DO WANT TO AT LEAST HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A
GALLON BECAUSE I DO THINK AS WE
TALK ABOUT ISSUES OR THINGS
THAT WE'D LIKE TO. IN ESSENCE
GETS. WE ALSO SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WHEN
THINGS ARE DONE WHILE. A NEW-
MODEL IN ORANGE COUNTY IT'S
CALLED THE ORANGE COUNTY BE
WELL. SOME OF YOU MIGHT HAVE
HEARD IT ABOUT IT. BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY A COALITION OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
ORGANIZATIONS BELIEVE IT OR NOT
THAT MANY BECAUSE THERE'S MANY
MANY PROVIDERS OUT THERE SMALL
LARGE. BUT THIS COALITION ALSO
INCLUDES HOSPITALS WHICH I
THINK IS ONE OF THE UNIQUE.
ELEMENTS AND- THE HOSPITALS IN
ORANGE COUNTY A MANY OF THEM
PRIVATE- BUT INCLUDING. AND
HOLDEN ST JUDE ST JOSEPH HAVE
TOGETHER WTH THE COUNTY OTHER
HOUSING PARTNERS. AND HAVE JUST
OPENED WHAT THEY CALLED ORANGE
COUNTY OR BE WELL ORANGE
COUNTY. AND WHAT IT IS AN
ATTEMPT TO DIVERT. UP MANY
TIMES THE PATIENTS THAT WE SEE
EITHER BEING ADMITTED TO
EMERGENCY ROOMS OR TO OUR
JAILS. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. WE KNOW THAT- BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN PLACE
TO TAKE PEOPLE THAT TYPICALLY
IT'S EMERGENCY ROOMS. OR JAILS
SO THIS NEW CENTER THAT JUST
OPENED LAST WEEK IN ORANGE
COUNTY WILL BE A NINETY DAY. I
AM. HOW FOR MENTAL HEALTH WHERE
WHETHER IT'S ADDICTION WHETHER
IT'S MENTAL HEALTH WHERE
INDIVIDUALS CAN THEN BE TAKEN
AND WRAPAROUND SERVICES WILL BE
PLACE THIS IS A BEEN FUNDED
NOW- THROUGH PRIVATE BUT ALSO
THROUGH THE COUNTY. WITH MHS
DOLLARS- SO I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT AS I KNOW THEY'RE
DOING VIRTUAL TOURS I WAS ABLE
TO DO THAT. BUT IT THE IDEA
AGAIN IS INSTEAD OF HAVING
FOURTEEN BEDS ON A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY. WHERE THERE IS NOW UP TO
NINETY DADS AND THIS IS IN ONE
LOCATION AND ORANGE COUNTY BUT
THE PLAN IS OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS TO BUILD TWO MORE- I
THINK IT'S VERY VERY INNOVATIVE
BUT ONE OF THE KEY PARTNERS
THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN INVOLVED
BEFORE OR THE HOSPITALS. AND
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE VESTED
INTEREST THERE IS THAT IT'S
VERY EXPENSIVE TO HOUSE PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES I AND
MANY TIMES THEY COME IN AND OUT
IN THIS THIS IS MUCH OF MORE OF
A HUMANE DIGNIFIED WAY TO LOOK
AT OUR- PEOPLE SUFFERING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SO WITH
THAT. IT'S ONE MODEL I THROW
THAT OUT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY. A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT FOR FOLKS
THAT ARE TRYING TO GET ON THE
LINE WITH PUBLIC COMMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE WE ARE
HAVING- REALLY TOUGH TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. OUT WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE THIS IS AN
AN INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLY ROBUST
CONVERSATION. A DEALING WITH
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AND
MENTAL HEALTH THAT. IS REALLY
THE TYPE OF CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE SHOULD BE HAVING INTERNET
FIND STATEWIDE SOLUTIONS AND IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF OUR BIGGEST
BURDENS. SO IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE AND WOULD LIKE TO INCLUDE
YOUR YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. OUR
SUGGESTION IS THAT FOR THE TIME
BEING CONSIDERING OUR TECH
CHALLENGES- YOU EMAIL. THE
COMMITTEE AND BUDGET SUB FOR AT
ASM DOT C. DODGY OB AGAIN THAT
IS BUDGET SUB S. U. B. FOR THE
NUMBER FOUR SO BUDGET SUB FOR.
AT ASM DOT CA DODGY OVIH. AND
ARE VERY COMMITTED STAFF WILL
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE-
RESPONDED TO APPROPRIATELY AND
AGAIN WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
INCREDIBLE INCONVENIENCE I KNOW
THAT SEVERAL OF YOU HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR QUITE A BIT TO TRY
TO GET ON AND- IT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE- THESE
TECH. ISSUES TODAY AND WE ARE
UNABLE TO HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT AGAIN THE EMAIL TO SUBMIT
YOUR CUP YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
BUDGET SUB. FOR I ASM DOT CA
DODGY OB AGAIN IT'S THE NUMBER
FOR JUST WANT REPEATING IT
SEVERAL TIMES JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT- YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WRITE IT DOWN IT'S A BUDGET.
SUB FOR THE NUMBER FOUR AT ASM
DOT CA DOT GOP. I THINK AT THIS
TIME WE MAY BE AT THE MOMENT OF
CONCLUDING THIS JOINT HEARING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO DO YOU HAVE
ANY CLOSING REMARKS BEFORE WE
END I DON'T I JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE PARTICIPANTS
THE PANELISTS HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY INSTRUCTIVE I. THINK
FROM ALL THE QUESTIONS IN THE
ENGAGEMENT- CERTAINLY ONE OF
THE MORE- ROBUST INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE HAD- AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK MY FELLOW
MADAM CHAIR FOR. FOR
PARTNERSHIP IN THIS IN THE ON
GOING DISCUSSION WE WILL BE
HAVING MANY DISCUSSIONS BOTH IN
THE HOUSING POLICY COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR. ABOUT WHAT IS
THE APPROPRIATE WAY FOR US TO
INVEST WHAT HAVE BEEN SCARCE
DOLLARS. IN THE SPACE OF IN THE
FOR THE CONVERSATION AND I ALSO
WANNA JUST ECHO- THE CHAIR
THAT- RAIMES SUPER DISAPPOINTED
THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM PUBLIC
COMMENTS- AND CERTAINLY. LOOK
FORWARD- IF FOLKS ARE ABLE TO
REACH OUT TO US VIA EMAIL TO-
REVIEWING THAT- AND WITHOUT
PROTECTIVE. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT HEARING TODAY AND HOUSING
AND HOMELESS AND- BUDGET OF
FOUR FOR PARTICIPATING. AND
ENGAGING AND ONE OF THE STATE'S
BIGGEST CHALLENGES HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS AND TRYING TO COME
UP WITH CREATIVE APPROACHES
THAT ARE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT.
WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE PAST TO
ADDRESS THIS VERY REAL ISSUE
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE FEELING ON
THE GROUND. I OPENED UP MY
COMMENTS EARLY ON BY STATING
THAT THIS IS A AND AN ISSUE
THAT IS ABOUT HUMAN LIVES IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT IMPACTS- BEANS
THAT ARE HOMELESS ON VARIOUS
DIFFERENT LEVELS. CHRONIC
EPISODIC TRANSITIONAL AND
HIDDEN HOMELESSNESS- AND
THERE'S SO MUCH. THAT IS SO
MUCH TO TAKE AWAY FROM THIS I'M
VERY REAL BUS AND- A
CONVERSATION THAT I THINK HAS
GIVEN A IDEAS TERMS OF. WHAT
CAN THE STATE DO TO MORE HELP
MORE ENGAGE. I HAVE A-
APPROACHES TO VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ISSUES RELATED TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING. MENTAL
HEALTH AND HOW. CONVERSATIONS
ARE OFTEN IN A SILO AND THEY
SHOULDN'T BE THE CONVERSATIONS
NEED TO BE. COMPLETELY
INCLUSIVE. WITH CONVERSATIONS
ON SOLUTIONS AND PATHWAYS TO
SOLUTION SO I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS AND THINK THIS
LAST PANEL- WHICH INCLUDED.
LOST MY PAPERWORK HERE
APOLOGIES DOCTOR OF LISA ADAMS
COLUMN WITH THING JOHNSON- A
MISS CHENEY ROWNTREE THE
EXPECTED DIRECTOR OF THE CALL
THE CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB AT
UCLA AND DOCTOR JONATHAN SHERIN
DIRECTOR OF THE L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE
WE APPRECIATE YOU AND AGAIN
THANK YOU TO OUR VERY DEDICATED
TEAM AND STAFF FOR ENSURING
THAT WE- MOVED AS AS PROFICIENT
AS POSSIBLE GIVEN OUR
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES AND AGAIN
APOLOGIES TO THOSE ON THE LINE
THAT COULD NOT GET THROUGH. THE
THANK YOU AGAIN AND THIS
CONCLUDES THIS JOINT HEARING ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU.